PICK A GOOD AFTERNOON.
BECOMING TO ORDER WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT.
NOW WE HAVE A VERY LONG HEARING
TODAY.
MORE THAN.
NEARLY THIRTY BILLS.
IN THE SPIRIT OF MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE IS HER TODAY HOW
WE WILL BE HEARING.
TO THE SAME GUIDELINES ON ALL
PRESENTATIONS WE WILL OUT TO
WITNESSES.
ARE WE WILL ALLOW THOSE
WITNESSES TO SPEAK FOR UP TO
THREE MINUTES.
I DO NOT HAVE TO TAKE THE ENTIRE
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATES YOUR
BREVITY BECAUSE WE WANT TO LEAVE
THE MAJORITY THE TIME FOR THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
LAST SERGEANTS TO CALL THE%
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE CANNOT.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM JUST YET
SO WE WILL BEGIN THE MEETING.
AS A SUB COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE.
AND WE WILL WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM AND WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 23-14.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
MANY WHO'VE COME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY WE
WELCOME ALL OF YOU.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL WE HOPE TO JUST HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO STAND.
NEXT PRESSURE SUPPORT.
BUT THAT SAID I WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARE AS
WILL KNOW THESE ARE VERY
CHALLENGING TIMES FOR US AS
WORKERS.
AS GRIM GRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY I
AB 23-14 WILL ESTABLISH AND
MAINTAIN A DOMESTIC WORKER.
FORCED FOR PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT.
AB 23-14 IT'S COULD PROMOTE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF LABOR
STANDARDS FOR THE DOMESTIC WORK
INDUSTRY.
IN CALIFORNIA ESTIMATED TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS RELY ON
DOMESTIC WORKER SUPPORT THEIR
EVERYDAY LIVES.
HOPING FOR A CHILD CARE. CARE
FOR SENIORS AND OTHER SYSTEMS
AROUND THE HOUSE.
YEAH ONE IN SIX DOMESTIC WORK
EMPLOYERS FAILED TO PAY THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
IN FOUR IN TEN EMPLOYERS PAID
LOW WAGES
DEFINED AS TWO THIRDS OF THE
MEDIAN FULL TIME WAGE.
INCOMING CALIFORNIA.
I'M PROUD TO HAVE A BROAD
COALITION SUPPORT.
I'M FOR A BI 23-14 I THINK IT'S
SO CRITICAL. THAT.
WE SHOWED DOMESTIC WORK THING
RESPECT AS WE DO EVERY OTHER
WORK AND WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES. ARE MARIA COLIN WHO'S
A MEMBER OF A EL MES OF THE
CROWD AND DAY LABOR CENTER IN
NYC YOU BROWN HANDED HIM THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
WE WELCOME YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
MARIO ENOUGH THAT IS NAY
NORMATIVE MUDDY ACCORDING.
HE SAW A MEDIUM BUT OF THE
INNOCENT ARE LOWER BECAUSE THEY
CREATE THEM. ELECT QUALITY
THEON.
THAT THAT I HAD OR OTHER LOW
THAT THEY CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
COLLEEN AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CREIGHTON DAY LABOR CENTER AND
OF THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION.
IF YOU'LL BE IN YOUR BE NAY A
CALIFORNIA AND AND MADE THIS HE
PUT MORE TRUST ANNUAL IF EVER A
LOCAL MOTHER HAD THOUGHT THAT
THEY'D ALL THAT.
WELL MONNING YEAH. UP BLOOD
MEANT THAT CORNING PSI THE
CUFFS.
I CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE AND FOUR
YEARS I HAVE WORKED AS A
DOMESTIC WORKER. FIRST AS A
NANNY AND CURRENTLY AS A HOUSE
CLEANER.
WHATEVER ASEAN WATER LOTUS INDIA
AT THAT PICKED ONE PLAN I MEAN
ASEAN AND IF THEIR BODIES THEN
WILL ME IN THE.
MESSI IMPORTANCE THERE WOULD I
EAT BUT THE APP BY APATHETIC
ALMOST SAID I WON'T KNOW THEM IS
THAT IT SHOWS LEVEL AND I THIS.
MUCH OF THIS IS MADE AND THOUGHT
THAT THEY WERE MUST MISS THE FEE
THAT THAT THAT NET WON'T ALLOW
FOR ESTABLISH.
BONTA BROUGH IT MEAN BUT A
BRAVE.
WATER ME EVEN IF I MEAN THEY'RE.
NOT NECESSARY THAT THEY ASKED IT
ABOUT IT. THAT IT SHOWS.
LAWS THAT THAT TO ACTUALLY
EXERCISE MY
RIGHTS WHEN THEY ARE BEING
VIOLATED.
ONE OBVIOUS BUS UP BY SCO.
THAT IT PANDEMIC EVICTING
PASSER.
AARON AND GONE AHEAD OF ALL HOPE
WILL MONNING YEAH DE LOS NINOS
THEY SAY SMITH SAYS IT THAT IT
SONYA.
NOTICE.
I EIGHT THERE ARE AIRPORT ASSAYS
I KNOW.
CORD ITSELF A MEDIA LITTLE NEST
IBM THIS THEY'LL A CHORE I ADMIT
I WOULD SHOW BAY IN ME.
SO LAW MAY PAN OUT ONE C.
INCIDENT THAT THE LATEST PUSH
THEM ON A.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT OF ALL
LOUDEST BORDER A NOW ORDER WATER
COOLED NO THEY HAD LOST IT OR
DEATH.
WHEN MY HUSBAND DIED
UNEXPECTEDLY I FOUND MYSELF
HOMELESS
AND I FOUND WORK TAKING CARE OF
TWO CHILDREN A THREE YEAR OLD
AND A SIX MONTH OLD. I WORKED
FOR SIX YEARS WITHOUT FAMILY
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY FROM EIGHT
AM TO EIGHT PM.
THEY ONLY PAID ME A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY DOLLARS WEEKLY.
THAT MEANS ONLY TWO DOLLARS PER
HOUR FOR TWELVE HOUR SHIFTS.
FACE IT NO MATTER WHAT THE ACT
FAT. FORGIVENESS AND THE EFFORT
OF ONE THAT MEANT THERE AND I
SEE THAT.
QUOTING UP HOME PULLOUT WILL PUT
PONY THAT IT NEVER HAD BAY YET
CUOMO WOUND NOW OF WATERGATE
LEFT THERE SO ENOUGH MADE HIM
BILLY AB ONE. UP BESIDE THE SAID
AMY AROUND THAT HE THEN ALL I'M
GLAD ENDING RELEASE.
I COULDN'T COMPLAIN BECAUSE I
FELT PROFOUNDLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK I SIGHED AS
A HUGE FAVOR THAT THE FAMILY
WOULD EMPLOY ME. EVEN AS AN
IMMIGRANT WHO DIDN'T SPEAK
ENGLISH.
AND IF ANY MAN THAT MAY MAY I
AYE I THINK WHEN I LOOK AT
CENTRO LEVEL ARE NOT THAT GREAT
DON'T GO ON THEIR* THREE
ACID.
LONDON AUSSIES ASSISTE. OFF BY
DID IS THE APPLE I LEFT OR WHAT
BERNIE THAT IS FUNDED ACADEMY.
SODIMM IS THAT IT A. FORMER BEST
ON I MEAN AROUND THEM OKAY IT IS
THAT I HAVE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT.
RECENTLY I HAVE BECOME INVOLVED
WITH A GREAT IN DAY LABOR CENTER
WHERE I HAVE ATTENDED WORKSHOPS
AND TAKING ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THEY PROVIDE. SO
THAT I CAN LEARN ABOUT MY RIGHTS
AS AN INDIVIDUAL AS AN IMMIGRANT
AS A WOMAN AND AS A DOMESTIC
WORKER.
OUR GUESTS THINKING OF YEAH ONE.
MANY MONTH WATER OUT ORDER
ORDER.
GIVE EVERY YEAH VAN.
THEY SAY VETO E. SICKBED YOUR UP
ON THE AT THEM ON THAT FLOOR
ABU'L SO HE IS NOT MESSIAEN.
FEDERAL LAW THAT THEY MORE
CHUBBY AMPLE.
MISS IN THE AYE ALLOW THAT YOU
JUST BROKE THE HE THAT.
NOT AYE VIA.
NO ALSO VM IS THAT IT DOESN'T
HAVE LONG THEY.
IN COMBAT IN FOUR MONTHS HE ON.
NOW I KNOW THAT I WAS VOTER
MINIMUM WAGE AND I KNOW THAT I
COULD HAVE TAKEN ACTION AND
DENOUNCED THOSE LABOR
VIOLATIONS.
BUT DURING MY TIME AS A NANNY I
FELT ISOLATED I DID KNOW MY
RIGHTS AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE
TO GO TO FIND THAT INFORMATION.
I'M MORE CHEST.
THEY LET HIM OKAY THIS SCHEDULE
CUOMO YA ANDCALIFORNIA AND I'M
I DO IDEA.
THAT THE ABOUT HOW THE LORD IS
THAT ALL THAT OF SADDAM OKAY
THIS EVENING AROUND THIS.
IN WHICH IS NOT ONE OF THEM ON
THOSE THAT IT SHOWS THAT THE EPA
AND THEN ME AND ALL THAT THEM ON
THAT NOISE.
NO IS THAT A LOT ITS BLOCKBUSTER
ORDER SAID ME AROUND THEY ORDER
SAID OKAY.
FOR NO OTHER LEADING IS HE NOT
THAT MAN. WON'T ALLOW APPLE IT.
CASE STUDY I MET HIS BODY
COMMENT THEN NO HAN SIDO BY LAW
AND EITHER.
THERE ARE MANY WOMEN LIKE ME IN
CALIFORNIA. THE MAJORITY OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE IMMIGRANT
WOMEN AND MANY TO DO NOT KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS ARE AFRAID OF A
CERTAIN THEIR RIGHTS IN THE FACE
OF EXPLOITATION. BECAUSE WE ARE
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE WE ARE WOMEN
BECAUSE WE MAY NOT SPEAK ENGLISH
AND BECAUSE WE WORK IN JOBS THAT
HISTORICALLY HAVE NOT BEEN
VALUED.
.
YOU'LL BE NAY IT BUT I SAID.
WHAT BROUGHT THE BY THAT AND I
ELAINE PAYMENT BESSIE ON THEM IS
THAT IT SHOWS?
GET ALL THEY NEED NOW.
THIS BAD THOUGH. WHAT MYTH ABOUT
FOURTEEN IS THAT IT SHOWS THE
YEAR OLYMPIC OUTLAWED AND SEES
THEM ALLOW OR MONEY THAT?
APPLE YET NOT MUCH BUT A
PROPHECY ON.
WHAT IS SO?
GET BEALL SAID THIS I WILL NOT
FLY WATER.
AVE SAY AVERAGE UP MANDATE BEAT
THAT IS THAT THOSE DEPEND UPON.
NOISE THAT OPEN UP OUR PHONE
LINES THREATENING ME THAT.
THE MORE CHANCE THAT I SERIOUS.
BUT IF WHICH HAD MAKE.
YES YES BUT I APPLAUD THE TO
EXPEDIENCY CLASS YES THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
SHOULD I TRANSLATE THE LAST
PIECE SHE SAID.
I CAME HERE TODAY TO BE
PROACTIVE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF MY RIGHTS I WANT DIGNITY AND
RESPECT FOR MY WORK FOR MY
RIGHTS AND THAT THE EMPLOYER THE
SYSTEM AND THE BROADER COMMUNITY
SUPPORT THIS PROFESSION. IT'S
FOR THESE REASONS THAT I ASK YOU
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF A. B. 23-14
FOR WORK FOR DIGNITY THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING TO ME.
IF YOU NEXT WILL ASK.
MY NAME IS MICKEY BROWN BOOKER.
AND I'M A MEMBER OF A HAND IN
HAND THAT THE MEXICAN PLAYERS
NETWORK.
I HAVE A DISABILITY ALL MY LIFE
AND I RELIANT PERSONAL CARE
ATTENDANTS FOR CARE.
I STARTED HIRING AND EMPLOYING
ATTENDANTS WHEN I LEFT MY
PARENT'S HOUSE AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I NOW AM POINT SIX ATTENDANCE ON
A REGULAR BASIS. AND THEY HELP
ME TO THINGS LIKE GETTING ME IN
AND OUT OF BED PREPARING MY
MEALS DOING MY LAUNDRY AND
DRIVING INTO WORK.
USING ATTENDANT CARE SERVICES
HAS MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO
BECOME AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF
A NONPROFIT THAT SERVES PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
THE NEED FOR EDUCATION ON
DOMESTIC EMPLOYMENT IS GREAT AND
GROWLING.
ONE NEARLY TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS WHO CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY RELY ON DOMESTIC
WORKERS.
THAT NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO
INCREASE BY AT LEAST FIFTY TWO
PERCENT BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO.
DUE TO THE UNPRECEDENTED
COUNTERPLAN WE ARE EXPERIENCING
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AS THE FOR HOME CARE RISES.
SO DOES THE URGENCY TRIP SHORING
THAT WORKERS CAN ACCESS QUALITY
CARE GIVING JOBS. THAT PROVIDE
MUTUAL DIGNITY WITH CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON LABOR LAWS.
GOVERNING THE SECTOR FOR BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS.
CURRENTLY THAT GUIDANCE IS HARD
TO FIND.
WHEN I FIRST BECAME AN EMPLOYER
AT AGE EIGHTEEN I HAD NO IDEA OF
THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS AROUND
I'M FLYING A DOMESTIC WORKER.
I HAD TO FIGURE IT OUT ON MY
OWN.
AND I WAS FRUSTRATED WITH HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS TO FIND ANY
INFORMATION. ON HOW TO BE A
RESPONSIBLE DOMESTIC REQUIRE OF
A CAREGIVER.
AND I WANT TO BE AGAIN EMPLOYER.
IN MY JOB AND AS A TRAINER WITH
HAND IN HAND GIVING WORKSHOPS TO
NEW ATTEND AND INQUIRES. I HOW
TO BE A FAIR DOMESTIC EMPLOYER.
I WORKED WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS THAT
HAVE HAD THE SAME QUESTIONS THAT
I DID.
MANY OF THEM EMPLOYEE CARE
URANUS EVERYDAY. BERNARD
CHALLENGE BECAUSE THEY ALSO DO
NOT KNOW THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AROUND DOMESTIC
WORK.
MOST EMPLOYERS LIKE ME VALUED
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT DOMESTIC
WORKERS MAKE SURE THEIR HOMES
AND LIVES. BUT DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS TO IN OUR
CURRENT RESPONSIBILITIES AND TO
BE AN AFFAIR EMPLOYERS.
AB TO 23-14 WOULD CHANGE THAT BY
CREATING A CENTRALIZED PLACE TO
FIND RELEVANT INFORMATION.
AND IT WOULD CREATE A PROGRAM OF
EDUCATION TO REACH THE GROWING
POPULATION OF EMPLOYERS.
TO EMPOWER THEM TWO HUNDRED
STAND THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND UPHOLD FAIR PRACTICES IN
THEIR HOMES.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB 23-14 IT IS
VITAL TO BRING RESPECT FAIRNESS
AND DIGNITY TO DOMESTIC WORK SO
BOTH WORKER AND EMPLOYER ARE
SUPPORTED. THINKING.
THANK YOU MS BROWN BOOKER WE DO
NOW HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS
PRESIDENT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SO LET'S DO THAT AND. THEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THURMOND HERE FLORA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER PRESIDENT KALRA.
MCCARTY.
WHEN I MEAN MATHIS.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WE APPRECIATE THEIR BY AND
MORE UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED PEOPLE
WHO'VE COME HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THEY'VE AGREED TO HAVE A OF
MUTUAL MOMENT OF RECOGNITION.
WHERE EVERYONE WHO'S INTERESTED
IN THE BILL?
WILL COME FORWARD WILL STAND IF
ABLE ON AND BE RECOGNIZED AS
BEING HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SO THAT WE CAN.
EXPEDITE TIME BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY WITH THAT SAID
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A
SIMILAR TING HE LIKE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO FIELD ANY QUESTIONS OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR AND
THEN IT WAS A TING OPPORTUNITIES
CLOSE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
PALM I I WANNA THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF TING FOR BRINGING IS
TODAY. OPTUS HAS.
.
IT IS IT DIFFERENT SOME WAGES
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR ME IF THIS.
THIS.
HAS SOME SPECIAL MEANING FOR ME.
AS THE GRANDSON OF A DOMESTIC
WORKER.
A DOMESTIC WORKER WHO WORKED IN
THE SOUTH.
IN THE FIFTIES.
WHERE?
NOT ONLY DID YOU.
WORK FROM SUN UP TO SUN DOWN.
BOB MY GRANDMOTHER RAISE A KID.
SO SHE WOULD LEAVE SOMETIMES
EARLY ON. ON LEAVING A MEAL.
FOR MY UNCLES AND. MY MOTHER AND
I AND MY AUNT AND THEN LATER
COME HOME NINE O'CLOCK AT NIGHT
SOMETIMES.
AFTER LEAVING THE MEAL. THAT
YOU PREPARED ALL NIGHT.
AND THEN GET BACK UP DO THE SAME
ROUTINE WORKING HOLIDAYS.
AND.
.
AND OTHER THINGS AND SO I I
HEARD THE STORIES.
A WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE A
PARENT THAT'S AND THAT'S A
DOMESTIC WORKER.
AND AND I KNOW THAT ALL EIGHT
HER KIDS ARE SUCCESSFUL NOW.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT SACRIFICE
THAT SHE MADE.
AND AND SO IT A GREAT GIVE ME
GREAT PLEASURE.
NOT ONLY.
.
TO BE ABLE TO CAST MY VOTE AS A
AS A YES FOR THIS.
BUT I GET THE CAST THIS.
IN MEMORY OF MY GRANDMA.
WHO FIFTY YEARS AGO?
BLAZE A TRAIL SO THAT I COULD BE
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
SO I COULD CAST HIS VOTE IN
FAVOR OF YOUR BILL TO DAY.
IT'S BECAUSE OF HER THAT I
PROBABLY.
WE'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER TING.
YOU.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER SOME A
MEMBER KALRA BUT WILL FIRST
AUTUMN OF THE BILL.
BILLS AND MOTION AND SECOND IT
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK SENATOR
RETAIN AS WELL AS THE WITNESSES
THAT THAT SPOKE TODAY.
MY AND A HUNDRED OR SO FOLKS
THAT ARE HERE IT IS.
FIRST LAWS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ON AGING A LONG TERM
CARE OF LEARNED FIRST HAND.
ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF DOMESTIC
WORKERS UP YOU FOR SENIORS AND
OUR AGING POPULATION.
AND THE REALITY IS WE'RE GONNA
NEED MORE AND MORE PEOPLE DOING
THAT WORK IN THE COMPASSIONATE
CARING. OF AND TOPPLE MANNER.
I DOMESTIC WORK REMAINS. A LOW
WAGE LARGELY UNDER REGULATED
INDUSTRY COMPRISED PRIMARILY AS
AS WE'VE HEARD OF OF IMMIGRANT
WOMEN WORKERS.
HOWEVER AS TO MATCH DOMESTIC
WORKERS YOU ARE ENTITLED TO THE
SAME PROTECTIONS OTHER
CALIFORNIA. WORKERS ENJOY THAT
IS YOUR RIGHT.
IT'S UP TO US AS LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED AND THAT AND THAT'S
WHY NOT ONLY MY SO GRATEFUL FOR
THIS BILL.
I'M HAPPY TO JOIN IN AS A CO
AUTHOR AND NO PUPPET SPEAKING
WITH DECEMBER TING STAFF WILL BE
HAPPILY ADDED ON. A SUBSTANTIVE
TO THIS HEARING AND I DO SO. NOT
ONLY BECAUSE THE IMPORTANCE
PROTECTING WORKERS BUT OF
EDUCATING EMPLOYERS AS WELL. AS
SOME EMPLOYERS OF THE DON'T KNOW
THE RULES WOULD LIKE COMPLY WITH
THE RULES WE KNOW WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY KNOW WHAT THE
RULES ARE. AND AS SOMEONE WHO'S
INDIAN AMERICAN I'LL TELL YOU
THIS FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
.
OUR FAMILIES FIVE FOUND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO COME HERE.
OF MY FAMILY'S GONE TO THEIR
STRUGGLES AND AND IT WAS TO BE
HERE BUT I'VE SEEN A NUMBER. OF
ANY AMERICAN FAMILIES THAT ARE
DOING RELATIVELY WELL. AND MANY
OF THEM HAVE PEOPLE HELPING AT
HOME AND MOST OF OUR OUR OF
LATINO.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE TREATING THEM WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY THEIR PAIN
THE MILE. RESPECTING THEM
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE ALL
DESERVE.
I NOT JUST OUR HUMANITY THE
DESERVES THAT BUT AS WORKERS IN
THIS STATE AND I'M GONNA BE HERE
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED IN SO. ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU SENATE RETAIN OF
RIPPING THE SUPPORT OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE AN
HONEST ACOSTA.
SO.
AB OTHER ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISHING TO ASK QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
MY TO WAIT A JOIN THE COURSE OF
THANK YOUS TO USE ON THE MEMBER
TING.
FOR THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
WILL BE HONORED IF YOU'D BE
WILLING TO HAVE ME ALSO AS A CO
AUTHOR ABSOLUTELY ON MY ON TO
HELP TO RAISE ME.
WAS A CARE GIVER FOR MANY. SHE
OFTEN CARE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SICK WHEN SHE HERSELF SICK.
ON AND WORK LONG HOURS AND OFTEN
FOR LITTLE PAY.
BUT SHE INSTILLED IN ALL OF HER
FAMILY MEMBERS IMPORTANCE OF
THE.
ETHIC OF SERVICE TO OTHERS AND.
SHE NEVER LET ANYTHING STOP HER
AND WE OUGHT TO CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO
PROVIDE LESS WORK IN OUR STATE.
TO BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
HAVE GOOD OPPORTUNITIES UP FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR THEIR FAMILY
SO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AYE SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I YOU KNOW I JUST WILL PURSUE
JUST WANNA THANK ALL THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS WHO ARE WHO ARE
HERE TODAY. UP MANY OF THEM
DROVE FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ARE A YOU KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS AS A DOMESTIC WORKER TO TAKE
TIME OFF WORK IT IS VERY VERY
CHALLENGING. SO I I JUST WANT TO
THANK THEM.
.
FOR FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION I
ALSO WANNA THANK COALITION FOR
THEIR VERY THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
ON THIS.
BILL BECAUSE.
YET THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
LEADING THE EMPLOYEES KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS BUT ALSO LETTING
EMPLOYERS IT'S KNOWING THAT MANY
EMPLOYERS STOPS THEY DO WANT
OTHER NOTE DO THE RIGHT THING.
AS WE DISCUSSED BUT JUST DON'T
KNOW WHAT EXACTLY IS THE RIGHT
THING WHAT ON THE LINE IS NOT
THAT EASY TO FIGURE OUT AS WELL
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIVE VOTE I REALLY WANT TO
THANK.
THE YEAR COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF A PARTICULAR FOR WORKING
WITH ARE VERY BROAD COALITION TO
ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE AND JUST TAKE
YOU SO MUCH FOR. LETTING US BE
APPEARED AT.
THANK YOU SO NUMBER TING.
DAY BEFORE WE VOTE OF CEMENT
MCCARTY DID YOU WISH TO HAVE
SOME COMMENTS.
I JUST SUPPORT THIS AND THAT IS
WHEN I TELL THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT I CAN'T THE ONLY ONE NOT
GOING TO BE A CO AUTHOR YEAH.
LEAVE THAT I ALREADY OUT OF YOUR
DAY MONTHS. DISTANT YOU JUST AND
OTHER.
THE POWER OF PERSUASION YEAH. IT
IS.
THANK YOU TO OUR WITNESSES.
I GOT JUST WHAT IT ALTHOUGH.
IT IS GREAT TO HAVE YOU ALL
HERE AS YOU CAN SEE OUR ENTIRE
CHAMBERS PRACTICALLY FILLED WITH
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL. AND AN
EQUAL NUMBER WHO JUST OUTSIDE
THE STORE.
.
A WE DON'T TYPICALLY ALLOW
APPLAUSE IN THIS ROOM BUT.
IF YOU SO FEEL SO. THAT THE
DESIRE TO DO SO THAT IF YOU'RE
HAPPY WITH THE VOTE.
.
WE HAVE VOTE YET.
THIS VOTE FOR.
IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS YOURSELF
AFTER WE'VE TAKEN THE VOTE. WILL
MAKE AN EXCEPTION IN THIS ONE
JOHN. OUT WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST
THE CREATIONS THURMOND. AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
THAT BILL IS OUT NOW I WANNA
.
YES YES HE SAID WHERE A.
THANK YOU EVERYONE
.
NBI
IT'S
IN THE
IN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN ONE
OTHER ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY WE WILL
NOT BE HEARING AB TWENTY FIVE OR
NINE BY WALDRON. THAT BILL HAS
BEEN COOL BY THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR IF YOU'RE HERE FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE OR NINE WALDRON. WE
WILL NOT BE HEARING THAT BILL.
SOME IN MEMORY AS WE ARE READY
WHEN YOU.
ALSO ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT WE
WILL BE JOINED IN THE COMMITTEE
JUST FOR TODAY BY SOME REMEMBER
MATHIS.
WHO FOR JUST TODAY WILL BE
REPLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ?
CHAIR PIKE AND BEGIN WITH.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES THE SHARE
ACT.
THE STOP HARASSMENT AND
REPORTING EXTENSION ACT.
STANDS OF TIME FOR FILING
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT
FIEGER.
CURRENTLY A HARASSMENT VICTIM
MUST FILE A CLAIM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING.
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THE UNLAWFUL
ACT
OR THE FACE AN ABSOLUTE TIME BAR
AND WILL BE UNABLE TO SEEK
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CIVIL
REMEDIES.
IN COURT.
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND THIS
FILING REQUIREMENT FROM ONE YEAR
TO THREE YEARS ALLOWING VICTIMS
ADDITIONAL TIME TO SEEK REDRESS.
AND MAKING IT MORE CONSISTENT
WITH THE FILING TIMES FOR OTHER
ACTIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES FROM WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT.
SCREAMING NATION.
RETALIATION.
AND PROVIDE DUE PROCESS.
TO PROTECT CHARACTERISTICS SUCH
AS SEX AND GENDER SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IDENTITY RACE
AGE RELIGION DISABILITY AND
MORE.
THE LEGISLATURE LIKE SO MANY
INDUSTRIES HAS BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH THE CHANGES IN THE WAKE OF
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
PARTICULARLY AFTER THE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
MEMBERS OF OUR OWN BODY.
HOWEVER THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO THE HALLS OF
GOVERNMENT.
THROUGH THE STORIES WE'RE HAVING
A LARGER SOCIETY Y. DIALOGUE
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THE
EVIDENCE IS THERE.
ONE YEAR IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
TIME TO BRING HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS FORWARD.
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT CREATES
INTIMIDATING HOW STYLE DEGRADING
HUMILIATING.
OFFENSIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THESE ACTIONS WREAK HAVOC ON ITS
VICTIMS.
AND CAN CAUSE LASTING EFFECTS
PHYSICALLY MENTALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY.
WE CANNOT LET THE FEAR OF
RETALIATION OF THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
WOUNDS
BECAUSE BY SUCH ACTIONS TO
PREVENT VICTIMS FROM SEEKING
JUSTICE.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT MOST
OTHER TYPES OF HARM HAVE LONGER
FILING DEADLINES FOR EXAMPLE THE
TIME. FOR FILING AN ACTION FOR
PERSONAL INJURY IN CALIFORNIA IS
TWO YEARS.
ACTIONS FOR FRAUD OR THREE YEARS
IN CONTRACT DISPUTES OR FOUR
YEARS.
IT IS CLEAR THAT OUR SOCIETY
NEEDS A LARGER EVALUATION
CONCERNING THE TREATMENT OF OUR
EMPLOYEES WHEN IT COMES TO
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION IN
THE WORKPLACE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
BRITNEY MCCARTHY WOULD WORK
EQUITY AND JESSICA STANDER WITH
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
RENDON.
I CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY NAME
IS JESSICA STENDER I'M SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR WORKPLACE JUSTICE
AND PUBLIC POLICY WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. OUR MISSION IS
TO PROTECT EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS AND FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS WEAVER BUT PROVIDED
LEGAL REPRESENTATION ADVISING
COUNSELING TO WOMEN AND MEN WHO
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE
WHERE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY WHAT WILL
EXTEND THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR FILING CLAIMS
UNDER THE FEE HA. VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL RESIDENT PHASE MERIAN
OBSTACLES TO FILING A CLAIM
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THEIR
HARASSMENT THEY OFTEN DON'T
IMMEDIATELY COME FORWARD BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID OF RETALIATION BY
THE HARASSER THEIR EMPLOYER
WHICH COULD RESULT IN ADVERSE
EMPLOYMENT ACTIONS INCLUDING UP
TO. A TERMINATION SOME VICTIMS
FEEL TO COME FOR DUE TO THE
TRAUMA THEY'VE EXPERIENCED OR
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BELIEVE THEY
WON'T BELIEVE BE BELIEVED.
AND ESPECIALLY VICTIMS WERE IN
LOW WAGE INDUSTRIES FARMWORKERS
JANITORIAL WORKERS OF THESE OF
TENS OF UP OF WORKERS THAT WE
REPRESENT ARE OFTEN VERY SCARED
BUT OFTEN DON'T EVEN KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS AND DON'T KNOW THAT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM IS UNLAWFUL.
AND BY THE TIME THEY FIND OUT
THAT THE BEHAVIOR THAT THEY
EXPERIENCED IS ILLEGAL THEY'VE
OFTEN PAST THEIR ONE YOU'RE SUCH
A LIMITATION THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR RIGHT TO BRING A CLAIM.
UPS WE BELIEVE THE STATUE
LIMITATION SHOULD BE EXTENDED A
WE BELIEVE THIS IS THE RESULT OF
TIME TO GIVE VICTIMS AT THE TIME
THEY NEED UP TO BRING THEIR
CLAIMS AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
MY NAME IS PRETTY MCCARTHY AND I
AM HERE TO GIVE A STRONGER VOICE
TO THE MANY WOMEN AND MEN WHO
HAVE COURAGEOUSLY COME FORWARD
WITH THEIR ME TWO STORIES. ONLY
TO FIND OUT THAT THEY ARE UNABLE
TO SEEK ASSISTANCE FROM THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM OR HOLD THEIR
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE
THEY MISS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS DEADLINE.
MY STORY INVOLVES FILM DIRECTOR
JAMES TOE BACK.
I AM ONE OF THE NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED WOMEN WHO HAVE COME
FORWARD TO SHARE THEIR STORIES
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
PERPETRATED BY HIM.
LAST OCTOBER MY PHONE BUZZED
WITH THE NEWS NOTIFICATION
THIRTY EIGHT WOMEN HAVE COME
FORWARD TO ACCUSE DIRECTOR JAMES
TAILBACK OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
A WAVE OF SHAME CAME OVER ME AND
I FELT A PUNCH TO THE GUT AS
MEMORIES OF MY OWN ENCOUNTER
WITH JAMES HER BACK CAME
FLOODING BACK.
A COMBINATION OF CONFUSION AND
SHAME HAD STUFF THIS EXPERIENCE
DOWN FOR NINE YEARS.
AFTER READING IN THE NEWS REPORT
THE TOE BACK HAD ACCUSED THE
WOMEN OF BEING LIARS I EMAILED
THE REPORTER AND TOLD HIM THAT I
KNEW THAT WOMEN WEREN'T LYING.
BECAUSE THE SAME THING HAD
HAPPENED TO ME.
I THEN DECIDED TO FILE A POLICE
REPORT WITH THE LAPD AND THE
BEVERLY HILLS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS PAST SPRING THE LOS ANGELES
CA INTERVIEWED ME AS PART OF
THEIR INVESTIGATIONS INTO TOE
BACK.
BRETT RATNER AND HARVEY
WEINSTEIN.
WHAT HAPPENS TO ME IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WHICH WAS
REPORTED IN THE LA TIMES IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN?
WAS SOMETHING I HAD CHALKED UP
TO WEIRD HOLLYWOOD EXPERIENCE
I DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS A
REPORTABLE OFFENSE OR EVEN
PROTECTED UNDER OUR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LAWS.
SO BACK APPROACH ME BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO HIRE ME TO BE IN HIS
UPCOMING FILM.
I BELIEVE THERE IS BEING
CONSIDERED FOR A JOB.
AND HE USE THAT POWER OVER ME TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ME AND TO
SEXUALLY ASSAULT ME.
WHAT HE DID WAS UNLAWFUL UNDER
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT
WHICH NOT ONLY PROTECTS
EMPLOYEES IT ALSO PROTECTS
APPLICANTS FROM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT?
I'M SURE THAT'S HOW ABOUT HAS
SEXUALLY HARASSED MANY OTHER
APPLICANTS JUST LIKE ME. AND
MANY OTHER EMPLOYEES THAT HE HAS
WORKED WITH ON FILM PRODUCTIONS.
HOWEVER THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR EMPLOYEES AND
APPLICANTS WITH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HARASSMENT CLAIMS IS
ONLY ONE YEAR FROM THE DATE OF
THE UNLAWFUL CONDUCT.
ONE YEAR IS FAR TOO SHORT OF A
TIME PERIOD FOR THESE KINDS OF
EXPERIENCES. EXTENDING TO THREE
YEARS WOULD ALLOW VICTIMS TO
PROCESS THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
MAKE THE BEST DECISION FOR HOW
TO MOVE FORWARD BEFORE THE TIME
TO FILE EXPIRES.
A PERSON WHO HAS EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT MAY NOT EVEN KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM IS
UNLAWFUL REPORTABLE. THEY MAY
NOT KNOW WHO TO GO TO.
THEY MAY NOT TALK ABOUT IT FOR A
LONG TIME TO FRIENDS OR FAMILY
OR COLLEAGUES BECAUSE THEY ARE
EMBARRASSED OR SCARED.
THEIR SILENCE KEEP THEM ISOLATED
AND WITHOUT SOMEONE SAYING HEY.
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU WAS WRONG
IT'S REPORTABLE AND AGAINST THE
LAW?
THEY MAY NEVER FEEL COMFORTABLE
COMING FORWARD.
THEIR LIVELIHOODS ARE AT STAKE
THEIR REPUTATION THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS THEIR SELF ESTEEM
THEIR WELL BEING THEY MAY BE
AFRAID OF BEING BELIEVES ARE NOT
WANT TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
PROCESS OF BEING AN ACCUSER.
WE ALL HAVE HEARD THE RESPONSES
TO
WILL COME FORWARD SHE JUST WANTS
TO PAY OUT.
SHE JUST WANTS ATTENTION WHAT
WAS SHE DOING GOING TO DINNER
WITH HIM WHAT DID SHE EXPECT TO
HAVE HAPPEN.
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE THESE
EXPERIENCES WE DON'T REALIZE ARE
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL AFFECTS THE
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM COMING
FORWARD. EMBARASSMENT SHAME
INTERNALIZE VICTIM BLAMING.
MY WIFE COMING FORWARD HAS BEEN
SCARY ON CERTAIN UNCOMFORTABLE
AND NOT NECESSARILY A SUPPORTIVE
EXPERIENCE.
I EVEN WONDER WHAT YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT ME AS I SIT HERE
NOW AND SHARE MY STORY.
I WONDER IF YOU QUESTION MY
MOTIVES MY EXPERIENCE WHETHER I
AM TELLING THE TRUTH WHAT AGENDA
YOU THINK I MAY HAVE.
THE EXPERIENCE OF AN ACCUSER CAN
BE ISOLATING AND CONFUSING.
WHY THE DA SEEMED VERY
INTERESTED IN INTERVIEWING ME
FOR THEIR CASE AND SAID THEY
WOULD FOLLOW UP WITH ME? I FOUND
OUT THAT THE D. A WOULD BE
DROPPING THE INVESTIGATION INTO
HER BACK
BECAUSE OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS WHICH IS SIMILARLY
TOO SHORT FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT BY
READING IT IN THE NEWSPAPER.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY AND THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING AT.
AND LENGTHENING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS
SO THAT MORE VICTIMS CAN SEEK
JUSTICE WHEN THEY'RE READY TO
COME FORWARD. HOWTO BACK BEEN
STOPPED BEFORE OR AFTER MY OWN
ENCOUNTER FEWER WOMEN WOULD HAVE
BEEN ASSAULTED AND HARASSED BY
HIM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS COMMITTEE WELCOMES YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON.
IN SUPPORT I'D NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS
MURREY GO YOSHIHARA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD TO COSPONSOR
THE SPELLING THINK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS. THANK YOU.
JACKIE SAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO PROUD CO SPONSORS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
NICHOLAS TRAVIS ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS' SIDE AFTER.
UNITE HERE AND THE MACHINISTS
IN SPORTS THANK YOU.
NICOLE MARKETS SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH WORK SAFE AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL
IF YOU.
HI JILL THOMPSON AND THE
DIRECTING ATTORNEY FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS RIGHTS AT PUBLIC COUNCIL
IN LOS ANGELES AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THIS BILL THINK TAKE
YOU.
CATHERINE FAITH BASED DOWN
BEHALF OF LEGALLY NETWORK AND
SUPPORT THINK YOU THINK YOU.
EVELYN THAT HAD MADE THE NOW I'M
BEHALF OF THE REST ON
OPPORTUNITY CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE A WORKER CENTERS THAT
WORK WITH LOW WAGE RESTAURANT
WORKERS ONLY STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
MARK CHARTER CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI GOOD MORNING LARA CURTIS WITH
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY WE
ARE HERE ON AN OPPOSING LOS
AMENDED POSITION. TO EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS FEEL
THAT IF THE EMPLOYERS DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE'S NO
ABILITY FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY
ERADICATE THE PROBLEM. IF THERE
IS A ONE YEAR STATUTE LIMITATION
WHICH IS CURRENTLY ON LAW AND
THAT ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO BE
NOTIFIED OF THE HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION AND ALLOWS
EMPLOYER TO DETERMINE WHAT TO DO
WITH THE EMPLOYEE THE ALLEGED
HARASSER OR DISCRIMINATE.
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
DISCRIMINATING ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL DOES IS NOT LIMITED TO JUST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IT EXPANDS
EXTENDS THE STATUE LIMITATIONS
FOR ALL FEE HOW CLAIMS. AND.
RIGHT NOW THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND FEE HA CLAIMS THAT WERE
FILED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING IF YOU
TRIPLE THAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY COME TO SEVENTY OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT ARE
DEEP FILED WITH APARTMENT
APPARENTLY HOUSING. NOT ALL OF
THESE CLAIMS ACTUALLY HAVE
EVIDENCE IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THEIR.
ALLEGATIONS AND SO THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY.
IMPOSE A MAJOR LIABILITY ON
EMPLOYERS FOR CLAIMS THAT MIGHT
NOT BE ACTION HAVE VALUED AND SO
WE ARE ASKING FOR TWO YEAR
SESSION LIMITATIONS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY THE SAME. AS AND THE
TORQUE STATUE LIMITATIONS FOR
ASSAULT BATTERY AND INTENTIONAL
INFLICTION OF EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
THAT WAY THERE STANDARDIZED TO
YOUR SUCH LIMITATIONS FOR ALL.
OF THESE TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S SOMETHING
IS SOME CLARIFICATION THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO.
SHARE IS THAT THIS DOES NOT
AFFECT THE ABILITY FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO BRING A CLAIM
AGAINST THE HARASSER OR AT THE.
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S ACTING
AGAINST THEM THIS ONLY HAS TO DO
WITH THE EMPLOYERS LIABILITY THE
INDIVIDUAL IF THERE'S NO AT THE
STATUE LIMITATIONS HAS RUN THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL CAN STILL GO
AFTER THE.
PERSON THAT HARASSED THEM AND
AND FINALLY WITH THAT THE.
THAT CHANGES THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR THE EMPLOYEE URK SORRY I'M
UNDER THE LAW IF THE EMPLOYER IS
ALREADY REQUIRED TO NOTIFY
EMPLOYEES OF THEIR WHEN YOU'RE
SUCH LIMITATIONS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING. NOTIFICATIONS THAT ARE
REQUIRED AND BY LAW TO BEEF
HANDED OUT TO EMPLOYEES THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE UPPER.
AGAIN WE WOULD REQUEST THAT IT
BE LIMITED TO TWO YEARS IN THE
LIMITED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TERM MEMBERS
FOR THE JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND ALSO OF MY
COLLEAGUE. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
EMPOWERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OTHERS WISHING TO
ADELINE OPPOSITION YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOU POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHADOWS OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION IN A BIT OF
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
JOHN DIRTY WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SUFFICIENT CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
GONNA SELL BEYOND IT WITH THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE.
IF YOU.
KATIE HANSON CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WERE
OPPOSED TO LIST AMENDED THANK
YOU.
AARON CAREER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO POSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU THAT'S STRONG OPPOSITION
MIKE.
BUT.
CUT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WISHING THAT I IN OPPOSITION.
I SAY NOT A THREAT TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SO REMEMBER JONES SAWYER I JUST
WANTED TO TO GIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES THAT TOOK
TO RESPOND TO.
TO.
WHAT WHAT'S SAID BY THE
OPPONENTS LE IN IN YOUR
RATIONALE FOR FOR ACCEPTING TWO
YEARS VERSUS NOT AND IN MANY OF
THE? OTHER THINGS SO WE CAN HAVE
CLARITY.
SUCH AS WE MOVE ON.
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS.
STEP OF THE SPECIAL LIMITATIONS
FOR PERSONAL INJURIES TWO YEARS
FOR.
.
AT CONTRACT DISPUTES FOR YEARS.
THREE YEARS WERE SELECTED AND.
THINK IT'S THE TIME PERIOD THERE
WERE SOME THERE ARE SOME REQUEST
THAT IT BE TEN YEARS OR SOME
REQUEST THAT THERE NOT BE A
STATUE LIMITATIONS AT ALL. AND
IT THREE YEARS APPEAR TO BE THE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE PERIOD
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION ALL OF
THE OTHER STATURE LIMITATIONS
THAT WE WERE CONSIDERING.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOUR OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
MCCARTY OFFERS WIDE MOVE THE
BILL.
BILLS IN MOTION AND A SECOND IT.
AND THEN MAYBE JUST THAT A
FOLLOW UP TO TO THE ISSUES SO
THE CURRENT LAW. IS HE YOU MUST
FILE A CLAIM WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING AS A PRECURSOR. WITHIN
ONE YEAR AND YOU'RE POLICY THE
GOOD WITH TWO TO THREE YEARS
CORRECT THAT DID I HEAR THAT
THERE WOULD IS FROM THAT CAL
CHAMBER SAY THEY'RE WILLING TO
GO TO TWO YEARS YES YES.
OKAY SO I GUESS THERE IS A
KNOWLEDGE OF IT THAT ONE YEAR IS
NOT.
LONG ENOUGH.
THAT'S POINT NUMBER ONE.
POINT NUMBER TWO.
AS WE HEARD FROM YOUR TESTIMONY
IS THAT SOMETIMES YOU'RE NOT
READY TO TO TO COME FORWARD
RIGHT AWAY SO. I'M NOT CERTAIN
BY HAVING IT THREE YEARS IT'S
GONNA STOP A PERSON WHO WANTS TO
TELL THEIR EMPLOYER AND FILE A
CLAIM TO. HAVE THE EMPLOYER TRY
TO STOP THE BEHAVIOR IN THE
WORKPLACE BUT. GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WHEN IT FINALLY
BECOMES RIGHT FOR THEM TO TO
STEP FORWARD AND YOU KNOW THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER REASONS ON A
WALK IN THE SHOES BUT.
SEE HOW YOU MAKE THE COMPELLING
CASE WELL AFTER A FEW YEARS.
BEYOND ONE ESSENTIALLY THREE
YEARS THIS IS THE RIGHT CASA.
I THINK THIS MAKES SENSE AND I
CERTAINLY AM A CO AUTHOR BILL I
SUPPORTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOOK
LIKE ADULTS FLETCHER.
FIRST OF ALL TO WITNESS THANK
YOU FOR JUST FINE AND.
I THINK YOUR SERIES OF
QUESTIONS KIND GOT ME AND YES WE
BELIEVE YOU KNOW WHAT WE THINK
OF YOU IS. THAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS ALL SERVICE BY BEING
WILLING TO COME OUT AND SPEAK
AND TELL YOUR STORY IN.
THAT IT IS A SYMBOL OF A LARGER
MOVEMENT OF COURSE THAT
HAS BEEN WILLING TO DO THAT SIR
THANK YOU.
I'M.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AYE I A WOULD JUST
REITERATE WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID.
I.
I I KIND OF WORRY EVEN THAT
THREE YEARS IS ENOUGH
YOU KNOW I'M WE KNOW WHEN.
A PERSONAL TRAUMA DEPENDING ON
WHAT HAPPENED.
CAN BE HARD FOR PEOPLE TO.
COME TO TERMS WITH MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT THAT THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT COULD COME
UP. AND SO I AM.
HAVING WORKING IN THE SPACE
RIGHT NOW I THINK WE'RE LEARNING
MORE AND MORE ABOUT HOW
DIFFERENT EVERYBODY REACTS TO
THE SITUATIONS SO I THINK. I'M
THREE YEARS IS MORE THAN
REASONABLE AYE I THINK IT'S A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
I'M HAPPY I. THINK OF ARTICLE
AUTHOR OF NOT TO. BE A CO AUTHOR
NOW WE NEED YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
SOME AREAS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I THINK THAT.
AND WITH IT THE HEARINGS WE
HAVE HEARD DURING THE HEARINGS
WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY OF THE
VICTIMS.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO DO MUCH
MORE THAN JUST SAY WE'RE SORRY
THIS HAPPENED TO YOU WE DO NEED
TO TAKE ACTION. AND I DO BELIEVE
THIS IS
ONE PART.
OF AN ENTIRE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO DO FOR THOSE
FOR VICTIMS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND TAKING THAT
ACTION.
THIS BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
THE BILL WAS OUT REGULATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH.
NEXT BILL.
REMOVING TO ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE TRACK.
THE TRUCKING RECORDS AND
COMPLAINTS ACT REQUIRES THAT
EMPLOYERS OF FIFTY OR MORE
EMPLOYEES RETAIN EMPLOYEE
COMPLAINTS. FILED THROUGH THE
INTERNAL COMPLINT
PROCESS OF THE EMPLOYER. FOR A
PERIOD OF TEN YEARS FROM THE
DATE OF FILING.
AS YOU KNOW THE RULES
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND RETALIATION
PREVENTION.
WAS CREATED TO MAKE A SERIOUS
AND COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO
REFORM THE ASSEMBLY IS
HARASSMENT POLICIES.
PROCEDURES AND TRAINING.
AT THE NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HEARING
OF THIS RULES SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
OF THE KEY TAKEAWAYS WAS OF
EXISTING LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS TO RETAIN RECORDS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS.
EXECS EXISTING LAW LEAVES
RETENTION OF THESE TYPES OF
RECORDS TO THE EMPLOYERS
INTERNAL POLICIES.
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION ONE TWO
NINE FOUR ZERO OKAY. REQUIRES
THAT EMPLOYERS TAKE ALL
REASONABLE STEPS
NECESSARY TO PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
FROM OCCURRING.
NOT MAINTAINING RECORDS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS
PUTS BOTH EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES AT RISK.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS OF ADDRESSING SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT IS HAVING DETAILED
RECORDS OF WHAT EXACTLY TOOK
PLACE.
IN ORDER TO DISCERN WHETHER
THERE ARE REPEAT OFFENDERS AND
WHETHER THE EMPLOYER TOOK
APPROPRIATE CORRECTIVE ACTION.
FOR PARTICULARLY LARGE COMPANIES
A FAILURE TO MAINTAIN RECORDS
COULD LEAD TO A PER A
PERPETRATOR SAMPLING SIMPLY
BEING ABLE TO SWITCH LOCATIONS.
START ALL OVER AGAIN.
FOR ANYONE BOTH VICTIM AND THE
ACCUSED WE HAVE TO FOLLOW DUE
PROCESS.
BUT WE MUST BE FAIR TO OUR
VICTIMS.
IF THE BEHAVIOR HAS BEEN THERE
IN THE PAST AND IS NOT BEING
DOCUMENTED PROPERLY.
THAT BEHAVIOR COULD BECOME A
PROBLEM OF THE BODY AND ADD IT
TO THE CULTURE OF LACKING
TRANSPARENCY AND PROTECTION.
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH DOCUMENTATION TO BE ABLE
TO REVIEW BEHAVIOR. ON BOTH THE
VICTIMS AND THE PERPETRATOR.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS MANDY J. BENSON WITH
MJ BENSON CONSULTING WHO
SPECIALIZES IN SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING.
AND RICO. ESQUIRE.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AND POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH CALIFORNIA PLUMMET
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION OR SELAH.
THANK YOU PERSUADE IS PLEASE.
WELL
HI.
I MANY BENSON AND AS A WOMAN AS
A SEXUAL HARASSMENT SURVIVOR AND
AS AN HR AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION SPECIALIST I SUPPORT
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
AT TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD I BEGAN
WORKING AT CLAIM JUMPER REST NOT
MANY OF US HAVE PROBABLY BEEN
TEARING YOU KNOW IT'S A REALLY
LARGE BREASTS NOT REALLY LARGE
CHAIN. AND WHEN I FIRST BEGAN
THERE WAS JUST IN THE. LAST YEAR
OF COLLEGE
AND.
MY FIRST FEW DAYS OF WORKING
THERE ANONYMOUS LA SHOWED UP TO
WORK.
AND THIS KEPT HAPPENING NOT A
BOYFRIEND AND HE OTHER THE
FLOWER SENDING TYPES OF IS
PRETTY CONFUSED AND ONE OF THE
OTHER SERVERS HELP ME OUT WHICH
WAS LIKE. IF THE KITCHEN MANAGER
HE DOES THIS ALL THE NEW GIRLS.
I'LL TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
YOU'RE GOING TO REJECT THEM HE'S
GONNA GET MAD IF IT'S GONNA COME
OUT LATE THE BUSBOYS ARE GONNA
CLEAN YOUR TABLES ANYMORE. YOUR
TIPS ARE GONNA START TO SUFFER
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
SO I COMPLAIN I WANT TO THE
MANAGERS THE TWO OTHER MANAGERS
THERE AND ARE NONE OF THEM ARE
WOMEN SO I ASKED THE HEAD
WAITRESS TO COME INTO THE
MEETING IS WHILE I HAD A VERY
FORMAL SIT DOWN MEETING
COMPLAINING OF THIS HARASSMENT.
AND THEY SHRUG AND ASK ME WHAT
THEY COULD DO ABOUT IT THEY
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT HE
WAS JUST BEING NICE AND FLOWERS.
SO THEN I EXPLAIN TO THEM AT
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD BUT
RETALIATION WHAT SOME THAT THERE
WAS A LOT CONSTRUED DELEGATION
AND ALL OF THESE BEHAVIORS ARE.
ACTIONS AGAINST ME WARRANTY
RETALIATION AND AGAIN THEY
SHRUGGED.
SO I GAVE MY FORMAL NOTICE RIGHT
THEN I'D I'D.
GIVE QUIT ON THE SPOT AND I TOLD
THEM I DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO
CEO AND. UP AT SO I'M NOT GOING
TO BE THE ONE BUT SOMEBODY
SOMEDAY IS GONNA NEED TO SEE IT
BECAUSE THIS IS RIDICULOUS THIS
IS HAPPENING TO MANY MANY WOMEN.
AND IF WE HAVE A LOT LIKE THIS
BACK THAT. THIS BEHAVIOR WOULD
HAVE BEEN TRACKED AND EVENTUALLY
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED.
NOW I'M RUNNING INTO A FENCE AND
CONSULTING TO PROVIDE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION SERVICES
SO I CAN HELP EDUCATE EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES ON THEIR RIGHTS
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO HELP
STOP. SEXUAL HARASSMENT I
SUPPORT EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
BECAUSE HARASSERS LIKE THIS
MANAGERS CAN HIDE IN A BIG
COMPANY THEY DO HIDE IN A VICTIM
COMPANY NOT ONLY DO THEY CHANGED
LOCATIONS A CHANGE POSITIONS AND
SORT OF. SPITTING CAN IMAGINE A
BIG MULTI OUR INTERNATIONAL
COMPANY RIGHT THEY CAN CHANGE
LOCATIONS IN THE WHOLE HISTORY
DISAPPEARS UP THERE'S NO PAPER
TRAIL TO FOLLOW THEM. BUT THE
OTHER THING THAT CAN HAPPEN IN
THIS CAN EVEN HAPPEN OF SMALLER
COMPANY IS THE MANAGER OR THE HR
PERSON THAT DID THAT AND AND
INVESTIGATE SHOWN.
THEY MAY LEAVE AND NOBODY ELSE
IN THE WHOLE ORGANIZATION MIGHT
EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT.
SO THIS BILL WOULDN'T NOT ONLY
HOW THE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BUT IT WOULD INDEED
HELP THE CORPORATIONS AS WELL SO
MANY HR MANAGERS I TALK TO WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THE FUNDING THAT
THEY NEED. AND THE TIME THAT
THEY NEED TO INSTITUTE THE KINDS
OF TRACKING SYSTEMS NEEDED FOR
THE S. BUT THEY DON'T GET THE
OKAY ON THE BUDGET NOR TO SPEND
THEIR TIME THIS WOULD HELP THOSE
HR MANAGERS. GET THAT BUDGETS
THEY NEED AND THE TIME AND
STAFFING THEY NEED TO IMPLEMENT
THE SYSTEM.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
MARIE CARRIER SHE HIGHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION OUR ATTORNEYS FOR
DECADES OF AND FIGHTING TO
DEFEND WOMEN LIKE MANDY WHO HAVE
BEEN SEXUALLY HARASSED IN THE
WORKPLACE. OUR JOURNEYS FIND
THAT WOULD IS VERY COMMON IN
WORKPLACES WHERE THERE'S RAMPANT
PERVASIVE SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
THAT THERE'S NO CLEAR RECORD
RETENTION POLICY THERE'S NO
TRACKING OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS. IF THE EMPLOYER IS
NOT WELL DOCUMENTING THESE TYPES
OF COMPLAINTS AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE WORKPLACE.
NUMBER ONE IT MEANS THAT THE
EMPLOYEE USUALLY FEELS LIKE
THEY'RE NOT BEING LISTENED TO.
OFTEN IT MEANS THAT THE
EMPLOYER IS NOT APPROPRIATELY
INVESTIGATING THE COMPLAINT AND
A LOT OF TIMES IT MEANS THAT THE
PERSON WHO IS. ENGAGING IN THE
HARASSING CONDUCT DOES NOT FEEL
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT CONDUCT.
ON AN AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
POINTED OUT IT'S ALSO VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY WHEN
THERE ARE REPEAT OFFENDERS
ESPECIALLY IF THE WORKER MOVES
AROUND TO DIFFERENT JOBS ARE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. ON IN A
VERY LARGE CORPORATION.
AND WE HAVE HEARD FROM MANY
CASES WHERE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS
ALLEGED AGAINST THE SAME.
EMPLOYEE BUT BECAUSE AGAIN
THERE IS NO DOCUMENTATION THERE
WAS NO COORDINATION OF THE
COMPLAINT THE HARASSING CONDUCT
WAS ABLE TO CONTINUE ON A LOT OF
TIMES IT'S.
IT ESCALATES
I'M AND THE FEE HOW DOES REQUIRE
THAT EMPLOYERS TAKE ALL
REASONABLE STEPS TO PREVENT
HARASSMENT FROM OCCURRING IN THE
WORKPLACE. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS WELL
DOCUMENTED OR ACTUALLY GONNA
HOLD EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THIS VERY IMPORTANT DUTY TO ITS
WORKPLACE UNTO ITS WORKERS SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE THINKS I'M
STRENGTHENING THE RECORD
RETENTION REQUIREMENTS FOR
EMPLOYERS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT'S.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT STRATEGY FOR
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT SO
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
JUST ONE SECOND WHILE WE GET THE
MICROPHONES READY.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT BAKE YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY AND SUPPORT FAKE YOU.
IT WAS CHVEZ ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL MARQUEZ WITH WORK SAFE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AKILI NESS RAN OF SSI IN SUPPORT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKER COALITION AND THE
FILIPINO WORKER CENTER. THANK
YOU.
CATHERINE PCDR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
LEGAL AID AT WORK AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JILL THOMPSON DIRECTING ATTORNEY
PUBLIC COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
EVELYN I HAD MADE THE NOT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA.
RESTAURANT PATERNITY CENTERS IN
SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS.
UNITE HERE SITE AFTER A. WHILE
W. MACHINIST AND SUPPORT THEY
KEEP ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FOR.
PLEASE HAS EIGHT.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON SO I
REALIZE I THINK GOOD MORNING
EARLIER THIRTY AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S LAURA CURTIS AND I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE AND
WE DO WANT TO. THANK THEM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES OFFICE
THEY HAVE BEEN I AM VERY OPEN TO
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL AND
WE APPRECIATE THEM REACHING OUT
IN DISCUSSING AND AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WITH US WE ARE ON AN
OPPOSE MUST AMENDED POSITION
BECAUSE CURRENTLY THERE ARE
SEVEN LAWS IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
DETERMINE WHAT TYPES OF
DOCUMENTS NEED TO BE RETAINED
HOW LONG THESE DOCUMENTS NEED TO
BE RETAINED AND EMPLOYERS CAN
BARELY KEEP UP WITH OF SEVEN
DIFFERENT LAWS. AND ADDITIONALLY
THIS BUT THERE ARE ALREADY LAWS
IN PLACE REGARDING GRIEVANCES
AND.
UP BY AN EMPLOYEE AND THAT'S
COVERED BY LABOR CODE ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT POINT FIVE THAT
PERSON THAT GOES ALONG WITH THE
PERSONNEL FILE THAT HAS TO BE
KEPT DURING THE DURATION OF THE
EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYMENT AND THREE YEARS
AFTER ADDITIONALLY UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING REGULATION CC ARE ELEVEN
NO TWO THREE THERE IS
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS OR.
COMPLAINTS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SO WE FEEL THAT THESE ARE
ALREADY COVERED UNDER THE LAW
THAT THESE DOCUMENTS SHOULD THAT
INVESTIGATIONS AND COMPLAINTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AM ARE BEING
REQUIRED TO BE DOCUMENTED UNDER
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD MORE THAN
TRIPLE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
PERSONNEL FILE BECAUSE PERSONNEL
FILE RETENTION IS THREE YEARS
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR TEN YEARS
WE FEEL THIS IS OVER BURDENING
ON EMPLOYERS WHO WOULD THEN HAVE
TO KEEP SEPARATE DOCUMENTATION
AND TRY TO KEEP UP WITH THESE.
DIFFERENT AND REQUIREMENTS AND
FOR THAT REASON WE ARE POSING
WITH AMENDED REQUESTING THAT IT
BE AND MITIGATED TO EITHER THAT
PERSONNEL FILE DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS OR FIVE YEAR
PROVISION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SUCH ON LOUIS NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND. SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO OPPOSE THE REASONS
ALREADY STATED WOULD LIKE JUST
ADD SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS THAT
SMALL EMPLOYERS HAVE ON THIS AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW.
VAST MAJORITY OF SMALL
BUSINESSES DON'T HAVE ENTIRE
DEPARTMENTS DEDICATED TOTHESE
ISSUES OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT DON'T HAVE.
AN HR DEPARTMENT OR A COMPLAINTS
DEPARTMENT OR LEGAL DEPARTMENT
OR PAYROLL DEPARTMENT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR MEMBERS THE
BUSINESS ON A THEMSELVES SERVES
TO TO MEET ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT NEEDS. AND SO THIS.
SO THESE ARE COMPLICATIONS THAT
WOULD ADD.
UNDER THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION TO THE THOUSANDS OF
BILLS AND LAWS THAT WE ARE TO
COMPLY WITH WITH IT WILL BE A
BURDEN TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
I THINK. ONE OF THE KEY POINTS
IS THAT.
WE SAW AS THE AUTHORITY STATED.
THE LEGISLATURE ITSELF IS IS
ADDRESSING THIS VERY COMPLEX AND
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
JUST DEFINING THESE THINGS WHAT
IS A COMPLAINT WHAT DEFINES IT
CONSTITUTES A FORMAL COMPLAINT
AND A COMPLAINT PROCESS IS A
COMPLEX ISSUE AND DIFFICULT TO
DEFINE.
AND WE HAVE VERY VERY BRIGHT
MINDS IN THIS LEGISLATURE TRIED
TO ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS.
SO FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
NOW HAVING TRIED TRYING TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS IS VERY
DIFFICULT WITHOUT THE CLEAR DEAN
AND GUIDANCE ON THOSE
DEFINITIONS. WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY ALSO OPPOSE THIS
TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GALGIANI A BE OUT THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED LOS
AMEND. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO ADD ON IN OPPOSITION.
THE SCENE ON I TURN TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
CEMENT FLOOR.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I DO WANNA
MAKES.
DISCOVER RECORD A STATEMENT ON
THE RECORD LIKE THIS IS A VERY
SERIOUS SITUATION AND SHOULD NOT
BE TAKEN LIGHTLY.
BUT THE BURDEN THAT IT DOES PUT
ON SMALL BUSINESS.
PRIMARILY COMING ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESS FAMILY THIS IS WHAT WE
DO. AND THE OPPOSITION RAISES A
VERY UNIQUE POINT IS WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY.
THE LEGIONS OF ATTORNEYS TO
FIGHT THIS AND TO REPRESENT SO
IT IS A VERYVERY BIG ISSUE.
SIDE PLEASE I'M CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AS I AM TO
BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY. BUT.
I DO HAVE SOME VERY STRONG
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS NOT BECAUSE
OF.
DIMINISHING THE ISSUES OF
HARASSMENT IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT THE ASPECT OF THE BUSINESS
AND THE RELATIONSHIP WITHIN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY I NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SOME OF.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A
SIMILAR RACE.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST REITERATE
THAT.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WILL
APPLY.
TO EMPLOYERS WITH FIFTY.
OR MORE EMPLOYEES
SO WE DID TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WAS VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IN COMING THROUGH THIS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THEIR
HOUSE TO BE A STANDARD WE HEARD
ABOUT THE VARIOUS SECTIONS IN
THE LABOR CODE IN DFU H.
REGULATIONS. ABOUT RECORD
RETENTION BUT WE NEED SOMETHING
THAT IS COHESIVE SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED A STANDARD. THAT IS
UNIFORM SO THAT ALL EMPLOYERS
WITH FIFTY EMPLOYEES OR MORE.
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED TO
RETAIN IN THE RECORDS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT A B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE TRACK
ACT IS THE RIGHT STEP. BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE NONE THE LESS TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO SEE
IF WE CAN ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS.
AND TODAY I DO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THIS BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR
THIS VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION HAS DO PASSED TWO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
THAT BILL IS OUT THE REGULATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EH THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE. ON AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN A BILL WHICH PROVIDES
EMPLOYEES MORE EFFECTIVE TOOLS
TO RECOVER THEIR WAGES WHEN THEY
ARE NOT PAID ON TIME.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK BEING PAID
ON TIME IS IMPERATIVE FOR MAKING
SURE THE COMPARISONS AND BILLS.
PURCHASE FOOD AND TAKE CARE OF
THE DAILY NECESSITIES.
IF PAID LATE MANY OF THESE BILLS
INCUR LATE FEES.
AT OR INTEREST CHARGES
DAMAGE THE EMPLOYEES CREDIT AND
PLACES THE INDIVIDUAL.
WHERE THEY FACE ONGOING COSTS
BECAUSE OF THAT DAMAGED CREDIT?
SIMPLY PUT BEING PAID LATE IS
NOT JUST AN INCONVENIENCE FOR
THE EMPLOYEE. BUT COSTS THE
EMPLOYEE AMPLE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
IN THE LONG TERM.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN
SIMPLIFIES A PENALTY STRUCTURE
TO ENSURE PENALTIES ARE GIVEN TO
THE EMPLOYEE TO COMPENSATE THEM
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL COST THEY'VE
INCURRED. BECAUSE OF THE LATE
PAYMENT
RATHER THAN HAVE THE PENALTY
PAID TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
IT ALSO ENABLES EMPLOYEES TO
ENFORCE THEIR RIGHTS ON PAYMENT.
LASTLY PROVIDES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WITH THE ABILITY TO
ADEQUATELY ENFORCE THESE
PROVISIONS AND ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE RECEIVING THEIR
DUE WAGES.
WHILE I UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY GROUPS.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER IN THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING BUILDERS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
MY OFFICE IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THESE GROUPS TO
FIND WAYS TO MITIGATE THEIR
CONCERNS.
WORKING CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO
BE PAID ON TIME.
TO ENSURE THEY DO NOT INCUR
ADDITIONAL COSTS ON THEIR BILLS
AND RENT.
AND THAT THEY CAN ADEQUATELY
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES
AS BUDGETED.
IT IS FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS IN
THAT THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
I'VE A FEW GUESTS HERE WITH ME
TO DISCUSS MORE ON THE ISSUE.
THEN YELLOW URBAN.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR WORKERS RIGHTS.
CATHERINE FI STIR AN ATTORNEY
AND LEGAL AID WORK. AND MARIE GO
YOSHIHARA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PLUMMET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU WE DO LOOK FOR TEAR
WITNESSES WE ARE ON BILL NUMBER
FOUR AND WE'VE BEEN AN HOUR
WE'RE GONNA BE ASKING THAT
EVERYONE APPLY TO TWO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES.
IF YOU ALL COULD AND YOU CAN
ARRANGE A TIME ACCORDINGLY
HOWEVER YOU WISH TO LOOK FOR THE
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT THAT THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DANIELLE
URBAN AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
WORKERS RIGHTS A LEGAL SERVICES
NONPROFIT.
I'VE ASSISTING LOW WAGE WORKERS
IN WORKPLACE ISSUES AND IN
PARTICULAR IN WAGE THAT'S
LOCATED HERE IN AS YOU KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY TH
DISTRICT.
WE OUR PROUD COSPONSORED AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN BECAUSE
UNDER CURRENT LAW THERE IS NO
PRACTICAL REMEDY FOR EMPLOYEES
ARE NOT PAID ON TIME.
THIS CAN CAUSE EXTREME FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FOR MANY EMPLOYEES WHO
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
AND NEED THEIR WAGES PAID ON
TIME SO THAT THEY CAN PAY PER
FOR FOOD RENT AND OTHER DAILY
NECESSITIES.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT EMPLOYEES
WERE PAID LATE HAVE NO CLEAR
EFFECTIVE RECOURSE.
I PRESIDENT EMPLOYEE COULD TRY
TO FILE A LAWSUIT UNDER THE
FEDERAL LABOR STANDARDS ACT WILL
BE CONFLICTS THAT.
TO RECOVER THE UNPAID WAGES PLUS
AN AMOUNT EQUAL TO LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES TOGETHER WITH
PREJUDGMENT INTEREST.
OR EMPLOYEES COULD TRY TO FILE A
CLAIM WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER UNDER LABOR CODE
SECTIONS ELEVEN NINETY FOUR AND
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR POINT CHU CHU
RECOVER UNPAID MINIMUM WAGES
PLUS AN AMOUNT EQUAL TO
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES.
BUT THESE EFFORTS ARE OFTEN NOT
REALISTIC FOR EMPLOYEES WHO
SIMPLY WANT TO BE PAID THEIR
WAGES ON TIME. AND COMPENSATED
FOR THE LOSS IS CAUSED BY THE
LEAGUE PAYMENT.
BY THE TIME THE CLAIM GET
STARTED EMPLOYEE MAY HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED THE BACK WAGES.
AND EVEN IF NOT THE EXPENSE OF A
LAWSUIT OR CLEANING EASILY
EXCEEDS THE AMOUNT OF FOOD.
EMPLOYEES ARE RELUCTANT TO ROCK
THE BOAT AND PURSUE A CLAIM.
BECAUSE THE COST OF CONFLICT
WITH THEIR EMPLOYER FOR A JOB
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEED TO
KEEP AND THEY FEAR RETALIATION.
UNDER THE CURRENT LABOR CODE
SECTION TWO TEN THERE ISN'T
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM FOR
EMPLOYERS WHO DO NOT PAY THEIR
WORKERS ON TIME.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY ONLY
ENFORCEABLE THROUGH AN
INDEPENDENT ACTION BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND ANY PENALTIES
GO TO THE STATE AND NOT TO THE
AGGRIEVED WORKER.
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITATIONS THAT
PROVISION IS SIMPLY NEVER
UTILIZED.
THAT LEAVES EMPLOYERS WITH
LITTLE OR NO INCENTIVE TO PAY
HIM EMPLOYEES ON TIME AND IN
FACT IN THE FACT IT TURNS
WORKERS AND PARTICULARLY LOW
WAGE WORKERS. INTO INVOLUNTARY
STEP CLIMB UP PRIME LENDERS A
FIRST RESORT AND IF PLAINLY
UNFAIR.
WELL DONE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KATHERINE FEES START I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGALLY AT
WORK I WORK SPECIFICALLY IN THE
WAGE PROTECTION PROGRAM. BUT WE
REPRESENTS SCORES OF LOW WAGE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS TO RECOVER THE
WAGES THAT ARE OWED TO THEM.
WE HOLD SEMI MONTHLY WAGE CLAIM
CLINICS AT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND WE
RESERVE OVER A HUNDRED WORKERS
EVERY YEAR.
THIS LAW IS ABOUT A MOST BASIC
WAGE AND HOUR RIGHT FOR
EMPLOYEES TO BE PAID THE WAGES
THEY EARN ON TIME. WE REPEATEDLY
GET CALLS FROM WORKERS WHO ARE
NOT PAID ON TIME AND WE SEE THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT LATE
PAYCHECKS HAVE ON LOW WAGE
WORKERS.
OUR SON OUR CLIENTS SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
SOME MANY TIMES THEY ARE FORCED
TO LIVE WITH THEIR EMPLOYERS
PAYING THEM LATE. BELIEVING THAT
SOME MONEY AT SOME POINT IS
BETTER THAN NO MONEY AT ALL.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THERE IS
NO PRACTICAL RECORDS FOR THESE
WORKERS WHICH IS PERHAPS WHY THE
VIOLATION IS SO PREVALENT.
THERE IS LITTLE INCENTIVE TO
COMPLY WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
REPRESENTING TEN WORKERS AT A
POPULAR SAN FRANCISCO RESTAURANT
WHERE THEY'RE REPEATEDLY PAID
NOT ONLY THEIR WAGES LATE BUT
THEIR TIPS LEAVE AS WELL.
AS A RESULT OF THESE LATE
PAYMENTS WORKERS ARE NOT ABLE TO
TIMELY PAY THEIR RENTS.
STUDENT LOANS OTHER BILLS
INCURRING LATE FEES INTEREST
CHARGES AND DAMAGING THEIR
CREDIT ONE OF OUR CLIENTS WAS
THREATENED WITH EVICTION
PROCEEDINGS IF HIS RUN CONTINUE
TO ARRIVE LATE.
THESE FINANCIAL PREDICAMENTS
CREE AND UNNECESSARY STRESS AND
ANXIETY FOR WORKERS WHOSE LIVES
ARE STRESSFUL ENOUGH ALREADY.
THESE TEN WORKERS WHO EARN THE
MINIMUM WAGE COULD AND JOIN US
TODAY AS THEY HAVE TO WORK BUT
HERE ARE SOME QUOTES FROM THEIR
RECENT DECLARATIONS. AN
INJUNCTION THAT WE FILED WITH
THE COURT REQUESTING THAT THE
COURT ORDER THE EMPLOYER.
TO PAY THEIR WORKERS ON TIME.
ONE ONE WORKER QUOTE THE TIME
I'VE SPENT SO.
SIMPLY ASKING TO RECEIVE MY
PAYCHECK IS ENORMOUS AND UNPAID
IT IS DEMORALIZING TO HAVE TO
ASK FOR MONEY THAT I HAVE WORKED
HARD TO EARN. IT IS ALSO VERY
STRESSFUL AND THE ANXIETY FROM
NOT KNOWING IF AND WHEN I'M
GOING TO BE PAID JUST GROWS.
ANOTHER WORKER QUOTE I LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND DEPEND
ON MY WAY JUST TO SUPPORT MY
FIVE YEAR OLD SON AND WIFE I
RELY ON MY WAY JUST TO PAY OUR
RENT. BUY FOOD AND PAY OUR BILLS
IT'S FRUSTRATING NOT KNOWING
WHAT I'M GOING TO BE PAID I
WORRY ABOUT HOW I WILL PAY FOR
MY FAMILY'S MONTHLY EXPENSES
FACE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CONCLUDE. YES.
THANK YOU THIS IS IMPORTANT
ILLEGALLY AT WORK BECAUSE OUR
LOW WAGE WORKER COMMUNITY AS
MOST VULNERABLE TO LATE PAYMENT
OF WAGES.
IF EMPLOYERS ONLY HAVE TO
EVENTUALLY PAY THE WAGES THEY
ARE OWED ALREADY WITHOUT
ANYTHING MORE THERE'S LITTLE
LEGAL INCENTIVE TO COMPLY.
AND TURN THE CURRENT LAWS
FEELING R. THOUGH WHICH CLIENT
COMMUNITY AND AB TWO SIX ONE
THREE AS A FAIR REMEDY TO THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS
WISHING TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IT PROVIDES YOU NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
HARIKA SHARPENING.
YEAH MY GAYDAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION FOR ALL THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED WHEREIN STRONG
SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
GERMAN RECESS IDEA FROM HELP THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OFTEN SUPPORT NOT
JUST OF SAY. A REAL QUICKLY THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE BILL
THERE'S INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ON
THE PREVIOUS BILL FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH WE AT THE NEGOTIATIONS AND
WE'RE. MAKING SOME TWEAKS A
LANGUAGE THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON YOU THAT THE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
EDUARDO SL YOU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARY CREWS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT TAKE YOU.
JESSICA CENTER EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL MARQUEZ WITH WORK SAFE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS SALAS ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT
IF YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE IN
SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EVAN AND I HAD MANY NASA.
BE HAVE THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
CENTERS OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LIKE MONEY GONNA BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS SO WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA STATE PIPER
IT'S COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BOB JEREMY HAVE THE NATIONAL
UNION HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
Q. ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON TO
SEEING NONE IS THERE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I SEAT GOOD AFTERNOON MARKER
TESTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO YOU AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN AND HONESTLY WE ARE I'M
CONFUSED BY THIS BILL.
CURRENTLY UNDER TWO TEN OF THE
PENALTIES CAN BE RECOVERED BY
THE STATE
I AM SO THOSE PAYMENTS GO
TOWARDS THE STATE FOR THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT AND FOR THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S DEPARTMENT.
THOSE PENALTIES CAN ALSO BE
RECOVERED UNDER FIVE FIVE EIGHT
OF THE LABOR CODE FOR UNDERPAID
WAGES SO THE EMPLOYEE DOES HAVE
THE SAME THIS BILL TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN AS WRITTEN. JUST ADDS
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES THE SAME
PENALTY DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE
IN FIVE FIVE EIGHT AND TEN AND
TWO TEN WOULD APPLY TO THESE
UNDERPAID WAGES OR LATE
PAYMENTS.
SO THIS JUST TRIES TO ADD
PENALTIES ON TOP OF PENALTIES ON
TOP PENALTIES AND ADDING THOSE
ON OF THOSE PENALTIES AND SIMPLY
WILL JUST CREATE ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION FOR EMPLOYERS.
CURRENTLY AS WE FOUND WILL BE
HEARING LATER TODAY THEIR PAGA
CONCERNS WHERE EMPLOYERS ARE
FACING EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
RECOVERY WHERE THE PLANE TO
WHERE THE ACTUAL PLAINTIFF THE
INJURED EMPLOYEE ONLY GOT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THAT EIGHT
MILLION. AND EACH ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYEE ONLY GOT FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHERE THE PLAINTIFFS
PARTICLE WAIT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE RECOVERIES
THESE ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON
EMPLOYERS JUST SIMPLY ARE AND WE
OBVIOUSLY DO NOT CONDONE WAGE
THAT BUT THIS IS A. PEELING OR
THIS IS.
REQUIRING A PAYMENT OF FOR
PENALTIES FOR AN INTENTIONAL
VIOLATIONS WHICH ARE ALREADY
COVERED UNDER THE LABOR CODE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
WHERE AND WE.
APPRECIATE OPPOSITION THANK YOU
JUST OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ARE HIS OR HER
MEMBERS CHRIS MCKAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE
ASSOCIATION AND A.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT TODAY.
.
WANTED TO RAISE THREE HAD.
WANTED TO RAISE THREE EDITION
DID SHE WRITE THIS ANALYSIS IN
YOU HAVE IF YOU HAVE THE
CONSULTANT HAS NO BEARING ON THE
POLICY YEAH.
AND WE WILL NOT BE CREDIT IN
YOUR TIME FOR HOW CAN THE PLEASE
CONTINUE EARLY.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF.
SPENDING TIME WITH US ON THE
DIFFERENT ITERATIONS OF THIS
BILL I WANT TO RAISE THREE
ISSUES.
THE FIRST IS STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS OF CURRENT CIVIL
CODE ART COULD CIVIL PROCEDURE
SECTION THREE FORTY. PROVIDES A
ONE YEAR LIMITATION ON.
THESE PENALTIES THAT SPILL
WOULD EXTENDED TO THREE YEARS
WHICH WE THINK INVITES
ADDITIONAL AND UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION. I THINK MISS CURTIS
IN PREVIOUS TESTIMONY ON SOME
EARLIER BILLS HAS INDICATED.
THE DIFFICULT NATURE OF
COMPLYING WITH CALIFORNIA'S
NUMEROUS.
LABOR CODE PROVISIONS WHICH
YOU'RE ADDING TO ROUGHLY FIFTY
TO SIXTY NEW STATUTES EVERY
SESSION LOOKING OVER THE PAST
HALF A DOZEN YEARS. AND THERE
ARE NUMEROUS COURT DECISIONS ON
DEFINING WAGES SO IT'S NOT. A
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR IN ALL
INSTANCES WHAT IS THE CORRECT
DEFINITION OF WAGES AND THEN
LASTLY OUR CONCERN.
INVOLVING LANGUAGE THAT STATES
THE PENALTY IN THIS SECTION
CANNOT BE WAIVED BY AGREEMENT OF
THE EMPLOYEE AND WE THINK THAT
THAT WILL LIKELY PRECLUDE.
THE POSSIBILITIES OF PROMPTING
EASY SETTLEMENTS OF THESE TYPES
OF DISPUTES SO FOR THAT REASON
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
BIRTHDAY WISHES ARE OPTIONAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHAUN LUIS AND
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS ALSO POST.
BRIAN THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
ALSO OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ANKARA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
DIDN'T BREAK AT THIS TIME I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT WE ARE
OPPOSED MUST AMENDED AND ARE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSORS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RELATED TO AB SEVENTEEN A ONE
FROM LAST YEAR. TO ENSURE THAT
THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR WHEN
COMPLYING WITH SEVENTEEN OH ONE.
AND PAYING.
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN ON PAID
BY THEIR DIRECT EMPLOYEE THEY
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THESE
PENALTIES AND.
DAMAGES SO WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS EFFORTS IN
THOSE DAYS YOUR COMMENT IN
RELATION TO THE COMMENTS EARLIER
FROM THE YEAH FROM ECHOING
SENSORS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WISHING AT ON IN
OPPOSITION SAY NONE TRYING TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SOME OF.
BILL'S BEEN SECONDED AND HAS HAS
BEEN IN MOTION AND SECONDED.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS BILL ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
SIMPLY PUT PEOPLE SHOULD BE PAID
FOR THE WORK. THAT THEY PROVIDE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA NO
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE KALRA MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
BILLS OUT REGULATIONS THANK YOU
IF YOU.
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
WHO IS HERE TO PRESENT.
AB THIRTY TO THIRTY ONE ITEM
TWENTY SIX.
FAMOUS CHAIR MEMBERS.
THERE'S A SIMPLE BILL MAKE SURE
ALL TRADES HAVE ACCESS
PROPOSED CHANGES TWO RAGS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WHO UP THE FIRST WITNESS?
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY NAME'S MIKE WESTON I
REPRESENT THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES.
EACH YEAR THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP COUNCIL AND THE
OFFICE OF THE CHIEF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS DO GREAT WORK AND MAKE
DECISIONS TO BENEFIT OUR
PREMISES.
IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET THIS INFORMATION INTO THE
HANDS OF OUR JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT TRUSTEES IMPLEMENTING
THEM AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF. THE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED STATE RECOGNIZED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
TODAY I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
POLITICAL DIRECTOR MEDICINE HOLE
FROM JUST COUNCIL SIXTEEN WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY.
ON MY RECOMMENDATION SHE
SUCCEEDED MYSELF AS POLITICAL
DIRECTOR AND IS ONE OF THREE
WOMEN IN THE IEP TEAM
NATIONWIDE.
TO ACHIEVE THE POSITION OF
POLITICAL DIRECTOR. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BUT YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PROCESS
IDEAS ABOUT HOW FOR THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OF THIS BODY PASSES
IMPORTANT LAWS AND STANDARDS. IN
ITS ONLY.
VERY MUCH APPROPRIATE FOR THE
ARE TO REPORT ON HOW THOSE LAWS
AND LAWS AND STANDARDS APPLY TO
PARTNERSHIP AND HOW THEY WORK
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT BUT ONE ZERO
IN BEHALF OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX WHICH IS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE SOME THIRTY CRAFTS THEY
ALL HAVE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
FLOOR LABOR'S CAR CARPET LAYERS
GLAZERS.
YOU NAME IT WE E
LIKE THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON TO
SUPPORT NAME AFFILIATION IN
POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
STEVE CASTER IN THE REHEARSAL
REGIONAL DIRECTOR IN SACRAMENTO
FOR THE PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES.
COMING FORWARD TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION AND URGING
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
A LITTLE SINCE SUPPORT SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE QUESTION I ON I
WAS. GOING TO SOLVE MISTER GRANT
PUREED MOVED BILL TO SUSPENSE
FILE BUT I REALLY LIKE THIS IS
THAT LABOR BILL. SO I'M GOING TO
MOVE TO BILL.
AS THE MOTION IS THEIR SECOND
I'M GONNA SECOND I DON'T THINK
I'VE EVER SECONDED A GRAVE BILL
THEN MISTER JIRO SPOKE ON SAID
THIS IS A LOVELY DAY A HISTORY
MAKING MOMENTS.
AND ON BEHALF OF OUR PET ISSUES
PROGRAMS IN THE GREAT STATE
ANYONE ELSE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
SEEN NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE
BE HAPPY TO ADD ALL VIEWS CO
AUTHORS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I WROTE.
THANK YOU THIS BILL DOES HAVE A
FEW PASS RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
CHAIR WITH COLORFUL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE.
YOU BILLS OUT THANK YOU. A NEXT
WEEK ALSO REMEMBER RUBIO. OF WHO
WILL BE PRESENTING AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY.
WELCOME SEVEN MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRESENTING
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY WHICH WILL
CREATE A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM WHEN THAT THEM WITHIN
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF INCREASING. LONG
TERM EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR YOUNG ADULTS WITH AUTISM.
ARE THE AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER
IS THE FASTEST GROWING
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY IN THE
UNITED STATES SEVENTEEN YEARS
AGO ONE IN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CHILDREN WERE BORN WITH. A ES DE
TODAY ONE IN SIXTY EIGHT.
I ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN REPORT BY AN EMPLOYMENT
FOR YOUNG ADULTS WITH AUTISM IS
ESTIMATED AT NINETY PERCENT
NATIONWIDE. WHILE MULTIPLE
FACTORS CAN CONTRIBUTE TO LOW
EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS FOR YOUNG
ADULTS WITH ASD A FUNDAMENTAL
COMPONENT IS A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DISABILITY
ITSELF.
PROPER EDUCATION OUR REGION
TRAINING EMPLOYERS CAN HELP THEM
TAKE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION TO
RECRUIT HIRE PROMOTE AND RETAIN
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO SHARE
THEIR OWN PERSONAL STORIES ABOUT
HOW THEY COULD BENEFIT FROM A
PROGRAM SUCH AS THE ONE THE ONE
THIS BILL INTENDS TO PILOT IS
MEGAN. HENDRICKSON.
AND HARRISON LANE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S MY NAME IS MEGAN NIXON
AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS.
MY SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE AS AN ADULT WITH AUTISM
AND WITH MY PAST WORK EXPERIENCE
I KNOW FIRST HAND EMPLOYERS NEED
TO SUPPORT. IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO WORK WITH THE
AUTISTIC POPULATION.
IN MY PAST WORK EXPERIENCE I
HAVE FELT MARGINALISED DUE TO
THE TENDENCY IS THAT COME ALONG
WITH BEING ON THE SPECTRUM.
AND TREATED WITH LESS RESPECT
THAN GIVEN TO MY WORK.
THESE BEHAVIORS FROM EMPLOYERS
HAVE MADE IT DIFFICULT TO REMAIN
IN THE JOB.
MY PAST EXPERIENCE.
MY PAST EXPERIENCE COULD HAVE
ENDED.
COULD OF HAD A DIFFERENT ENDING
FATHER EMPLOYER KNOW THAT
UNDERNEATH MY QUIRKY BEHAVIORS.
AS A HARDWORKING CARING ADULT
WANTING AND COUNTRY A SUCCESSFUL
JOB
AND COUNTRY.
BEAUTY INTO SOCIETY THANK YOU.
VERY WELL DONE THANK OUR NEXT
WITNESS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HARRISON
LANE.
I AM HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY. AT THIS BILL WILL
HELP ME BECAUSE IT WILL BETTER
PREPARE EMPLOYERS TO WORK WITH
THE AUTISTIC POPULATION.
I HAVE HAD SOME WORK STRUGGLES
AND PASSED IN THE ANY. SUCH AS
TIME MANAGEMENT AND SOCIAL
ANXIETY DISORDER.
ALSO I OFTEN NEED SOMETHING SUCH
AS INSTRUCTIONS REPEATED
MULTIPLE TIMES.
I FEEL LIKE MY PAST EMPLOYERS.
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF ME.
SUCH AS HIRING ME FOR ONE JOB
AND THEN ONCE I GET HIRED. GIVE
ME AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT JOHN.
IT WOULD HAVE HELPED ME
IMMENSELY.
THE EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE OFFER ME
ENCOURAGEMENT.
EMPATHY AND UNDERSTANDING.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP IF THE
EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE FAITH IN ME
AND WILL EVEN ME.
AND NOT GIVE UP ON ME FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY AND FORTY THANK YOU.
VERY WELL DONE THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESS
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROTH
HERE ON BEHALF OF BOTH AUTISM
SPEAKS AND THE CENTER FOR AUTISM
AND RELATED DISORDERS. ON THE
STAGE TO ON THE LAST SIX OR
SEVEN YEARS HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN TERMS OF EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENTS. FOR CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM BUT THE NEXT STEP IN THIS
PUZZLE IS LOOKING AT HOW TO
TRANSITION THESE KIDS.
FROM CHILDHOOD INTO EARLY
ADULTHOOD AND EMPLOYMENT IS A
KEY COMPONENT OF THAT WE ARE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
MARIA GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
MERISTEM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRENDA MARK AND
I SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SEAN RUSSELL AND I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL MANY
FORTY.
IF YOU.
MY NAME IS CAROLINE EGGERT AND I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MADELINE BOND
AND I SUPPORT. TWENTY EIGHT.
FORTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S DEVERILL DANDA.
I SUPPORT ASSEMBLY THE BILL.
TWENTY ABOARDING. THANK YOU.
HI I'M RESURRECT SHAIVA. I
SUPPORT.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BEN LUIS ARE YOUNG
ADULTS AND YOUNG ADULT ON THE
SPECTRUM AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
I KNOW THAT WE TYPICALLY DO NOT
ALLOW FLAWS IN THIS CHAMBER BUT
TO SEE SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
YOUNG ADULTS WHO CAME TO CREATE
AND SHARED REALLY GREAT MESSAGES
I THINK WE OWE THEM A MOMENT OF
APPRECIATION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING GREAT
LEADERS AND FOR SHARING YOUR
TESTIMONY IS FANTASTIC THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I I I HATE TO EVEN ASK YOU BUT
ANY OPPOSITION THERE BETTER NOT.
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED.
THE VICE CHAIR HE IS NOT
OPPOSED.
I HAVE A GOOD AUTHORITY HE IS
NOT OPPOSED IN THIS.
BUT TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR.
SOME OF A MCCARTY THEN MISTER
MATH.
WELL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
OF COURSE IS THAT PILOT HELPING.
LA AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY SO
PLEASE THAT WE'RE DOING IN OUR
IN OUR BE AFFECTED AREAS AND.
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY ONE DAY WE
CAN HAVE THIS ALL ACROSS
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES THAT'S
NOT YOU.
SELECT A MAP. SO FIRST ALL OF
THOSE BRAVE SOULS ON THE
SPECTRUM THAT HAD THE COURAGE TO
GET UP HERE.
THANK YOU.
MY SON IS ALSO ON THE SPECTRUM.
SO I KNOW HOW MUCH IT TAKES TO
TO DO WHAT YOU JUST DID.
VERY IMPRESSIVE IN THE APPLAUSE
IS VERY MUCH WELCOME.
TO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
BLOCKER.
.
LA I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THIS GO
STATEWIDE SO WHEN YOU'RE READY
TO EXPAND THE BILL THAT WAY I'D
LOVE TO JOIN AUTHOR WITH YOU. AT
THAT POINT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
HOLIDAY
LIKE IF HE. MAKE YOU ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISHING TO
MAKE A COMMENT OR QUESTION.
SEEN NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF FORMER
US SCHOOLTEACHER YOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR KIDS TO. TO
BE EDUCATED AND WE DO SPEND A
LOT OF TIME AYE AN ENERGY TO
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
EDUCATED BUT WHAT HAPPENS
AFTERWARD IS. IS A REALLY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE AND
HOPEFULLY WITH THIS PILOT
PROGRAM WE CAN BEAT BRING IT
STATEWIDE AND AND I MAKE SURE
THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE ALL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
ASK FOR YOUR IDOL THANK YOUS A
MEMBER RUBIO. IN HIS TESTIMONY.
MISTER LANE TALKED ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR AN EMPLOYER
TO SAY THAT THEY BELIEVE IN YOU
AND I THINK THAT. SAYS IT QUITE
WELL AND ONE ALSO COMMAND THIS
YEAR'S AND FOR YOUR GREAT
TESTIMONY THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING GREAT WITNESSES THINKING
BEING GREAT LEADERS THANK YOU
SOME ANOTHER RUBIO FOR VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. TO SUPPORT MANY
IN OUR STATE IT DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR THINK THESE CALDERON.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE.
THAT GOES OUT TO GRADUATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU
.
NEXT UP WE RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE WHO IS HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
ONE.
WELCOME SOME A MEMBER STILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THERE IS A SITUATION.
THAT WE'RE THIS BILL LAST THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD TO ADDRESS AND THAT IS.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN FARMWORKERS
HAVE VOTED ON RATIFIED PUT
TOGETHER A CONTRACTS.
AND HAVE GONE THROUGH MEDIATION
PROCESS WITH THE GROWERS AND YET
SEE SEEMS THAT IN A NUMBER OF
CASES IT CAN TAKE DECADES TO
GET.
BACK ON TRACK ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS THAT ASK TAYLOR BE TO
LOOK AT THE SITUATION.
SEE WHAT THE SCOPE OF IT IS AND
THEN COME BACK IN AND GO THROUGH
ITS REGULATIONS ITS RULE MAKING
PROCESS. TO WITH SOME REAL
EIGHT.
METHODS TO TRY AND ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
ALBUMS.
THANK YOU WE WELCOME YOUR FIRST
WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARIO
MARTINEZ SOME THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS.
I WON I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. THE UFW SUPPORTS AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE.
DESPITE THE PASSAGE OF THE
MANDATORY MEDIATION LINE TWO
THOUSAND TWO.
DELAY REMAINS ONE OF THE MAJOR
ROADBLOCKS FOR FARMWORKERS TO
FULLY REALIZE THE BENEFITS OF
THE FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS THAT
THEY ONE OFTEN. DECADES AGO.
AS YOU MAY RECALL MANDATORY
MEDIATION WAS ENACTED AFTER
EMPLOYERS REFUSE TO AGREE TO A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
FOLLOWING A VOTE TO HAVE UNION
REPRESENTATION BY FARMWORKERS.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT BACK
MANDATORY MEDIATION LA WAS
RECENTLY UPHELD BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. AS
CONSTITUTIONAL.
.
THE PROBLEM WE'RE DEALING WITH
THIS THAT THE LENGTH OF TIME IT
TAKES FOR A MEDIATION DECISION
BY THE BOARD TO BECOME BY DEAN.
CAN BE THE RESULT OF.
LEGAL MANEUVERING AND CONTINUED
DELAY BY EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS
THE RESULT OF.
ENFORCEMENT LOOPHOLES WITHIN THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
ACT.
WHILE THE PROCESS BETWEEN THE
MEDIATOR AND THEY'LL ARE BE A
STRAIGHT FORWARD UNDER THE
MANDATORY MEDIATION LAW. A COURT
CAN STAY THE MEDIATION ORDER
INDEFINITELY. WITHOUT EXPLAINING
THE REASONING FOR THE STAY OR
WITHOUT AN AVERAGE EVIDENTIARY
PROCESS.
THAT ESTABLISHES IF A PARTY
WOULD STOP FOR SOME TYPE OF HARM
IF THEY IMPLEMENTED THE
AGREEMENT.
IN ADDITION EMPLOYERS ROUTINELY
REFUSED TO FOLLOW THE TERMS.
ORDERED THROUGH THE MEDIATION
PROCESS WHILE THEIR APPEAL IS
PENDING.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE THE ELLERBEE TO STUDY
THE ISSUE OF DELAY AND IDENTIFY
ANY ENFORCEMENT LOOPHOLES IN THE
TWO THOUSAND TWO LAW.
SUCH AS WHEN THEY A LAWYER BE IS
UNABLE TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE THE
MEDIATOR'S DECISION.
THIS WILL HELP PREVENT CASES
TAKING TWENTY FOUR YEARS AS WAS
WITH BASS TOMATO BEFORE
FARMWORKERS RECEIVED THE RIGHTS
AND BENEFITS.
UNDER THE LAW THAT IT WAS
INTENDED TO HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES.
IF YOU.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
MARK SCHACHT CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AT
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING AT ON
IN SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SPORTS THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
ONE.
I SEEN NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION OUTSIDE TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THANK
YOU FIRST I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BELL.
THANK YOU.
SECOND AND AND I I JUST LIKE TO
TO NOTE THAT TO. THAT I REMEMBER
THE DEBATE.
TWO THOUSAND.
TO.
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THAT MARCHES
UP AND DOWN THE VALLEY TRYING TO
GET THEN GOVERNOR DAVIS TO SIGN
THIS BILL. AND IT WASN'T THOUGHT
TO BE A PANACEA BUT THE IDEA WAS
IT WOULD BRING ABOUT SOME.
JUSTICE FOR SOME OF THESE.
.
SOME OF THESE.
WINS FOR THE FARM WORKERS IN
THE AREA WITH WHERE THEY GOT A
LEGAL. CONTRACT
AND THEY JUST HAD ESSENTIALLY
EMPLOYERS GUARDS SITTING ON
THEIR HANDS AND SO. THAT WAS THE
NOTION IS BILL AND.
I THINK IT HASN'T LIVED UP TO
TO ITS ITS INTENT AND SO I THINK
THIS IS NEEDED AT THE MINIMUM.
TO FOCUS ON HOW HOW WE CAN BRING
ABOUT SOME CONCLUSION TO THESE.
FAIR ELECTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME MOMENTUM MCCARTY
ANYONE ELSE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NINE SO I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I ESPERANDO.
IT'S BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA NO
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
IT GOES OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT SYRIA CALL SOME MEMBERS
WOULD MEAN WHO IS HERE TO
PRESENT AB NIGHT YOU KNOW TO IN
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
YEAH RIGHT VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU MAY I.
.
AGREE I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT IT'S
EYEWITNESSES I WITH SOME FLIGHTS
AND I'D LIKE TO HELP THEM GET ON
THEIR WAY LEAD ATTY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I TODAY OF MYSTERY
MEMBERS ARE PERCENT AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
REQUIRE TALENT AGENCIES TO MAKE
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION
RETALIATION. NUTRITION AND
EATING ORDERS EATING DISORDERS
AVAILABLE TO ITS ARTISTS.
THE BILL REQUIRES TALENT
AGENCIES TO TRAIN THEIR
EMPLOYEES ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO PROVIDE
MINERS. AND THE MINERS PARENTS
FOR LEGAL GUARDIAN WITH TRAINING
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
RETALIATION REPORTING RESOURCES
NUTRITION. AND EATING DISORDERS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING ON THIS
BILL AS YOU MAY RECALL IN
JANUARY AND PRIOR TO THAT.
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
THIS LEGISLATION IS NEEDED.
AS MUCH AS EVER.
AS YOU ARE AWARE OF RECENT
SCANDALS EMERGING FROM THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY TO
EMPOWER POTENTIAL VICTIMS WITH
INFORMATION HELP THEM IDENTIFY
AND SEEK RESOURCES.
FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS INTRODUCED
PROFESSIONALS ARE PROTECTED AND
KEEP A KEPT SAFE IN THE WORKING
ENVIRONMENT. HERE WITH ME TODAY
ARE KAREN STORE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
TALENT AGENTS INCUR CHRISTENSEN
NO THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS FROM THE
NATIONAL EATING DISORDERS
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
SINCE NOW AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL EATING
DISORDERS ASSOCIATION OR NITA.
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU TO ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY. ON BEHALF OF NEED AT THE
LARGEST ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED BY EATING
DISORDERS I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THAT
TRAINING AND EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION. RETALIATION
NUTRITION AND EATING DISORDERS
BE PROVIDED TO EMPLOYEES AND
ARTISTS OF TALENT AGENCIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC LEVINE FOR HIS
SPONSORSHIP AND LEADERSHIP IN
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD HELP PREVENT
BOTH SEXUAL HARASSMENT INTHE
PREVALENCE OF EATING DISORDERS
AND THE FASHION AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIES. NEARLY
THIRTY MILLION AMERICANS WILL
SUFFER FROM AN EATING DISORDER
AT SOME POINT IN THERE LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING WITH AN
EATING DISORDER IS ESTIMATED TO
BE OVER ONE MILLION.
EVEN JUST EATING DISORDERS CAN
AND DO AFFECT PEOPLE OF ALL
GENDERS RACES AGES AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS.
EATING DISORDERS SUCH AS
ANOREXIA NERVOSA BINGE EATING
DISORDER AND BULIMIA NERVOSA ARE
COMPLEX MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
WHICH LEAD TO CHRONIC HEALTH
COMPLETELY CMPLICATIONS. AND
HAVE THE HIGHEST MORTALITY RATE
OF ANY MENTAL ILLNESS
FOR FEMALES BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD WHO SUFFER
FROM ANOREXIA. THE MORTALITY
RATE IS TWELVE TIMES HIGHER THAN
THE DEATH RATE FROM FOR ALL
OTHER CAUSES OF DEATH.
MODELS AND OTHERS WITHIN THE
FASHION INDUSTRY AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIES
EXPERIENCE SUBSTANTIALLY
ELEVATED RISK OF EATING
DISORDERS BECAUSE OF
EXPECTATIONS PLACED UPON THEM TO
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN BODY WEIGHT.
FURTHERMORE TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES SUCH AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR HARASSMENT HAVE BEEN
FOUND TO BE A SIGNIFICANT RISK
FACTOR FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EATING DISORDERS.
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
WOMEN WHO ARE VICTIMS OF ASSAULT
WORK ALMOST TWO TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DEVELOP ANEMIA THAN
THOSE WHO HAD NOT BEEN
VICTIMIZED.
ALTHOUGH QUITE SERIOUS EATING
DISORDERS ARE TREATABLE AND CAN
BE PREVENTED ESPECIALLY OF EARLY
INTERVENTION EFFORTS ARE ENACTED
KNOWING THE SIGNS IS A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP. THE EARLIER AN
INDIVIDUAL RECEIVES TREATMENT
THE GREATER THE CHANCES OF
RECOVERY.
EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
TREATMENT HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
IMPROVE THE SPEED OF RECOVERY
REDUCE SYMPTOMS TO A GREATER
EXTENT AND IMPROVE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF STAYING FREE OF
THE ILLNESS.
EARLY INTERVENTION EDUCATION
INITIATIVE SUCH AS THOSE LAID
OUT IN AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT CAN TRULY SAVE LIVES WE
BELIEVE THAT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THESE EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
WOULD HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT IN THE
PREVENTION OF BOTH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND EATING DISORDERS
IN THE FASHION AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRIES.
THE REQUIREMENTS LAID OUT IN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT ARE
LONG OVERDUE AND IT IS TIME THAT
WE WORK TOGETHER TO IMPLEMENT
THESE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS.
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA LEADER IN PROTECTING
MODELS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
FASHION AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRIES FROM THESE DANGEROUS
ILLNESSES WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
SUCH A PLEASURE TO BE HERE AGAIN
I'M GONNA MISS COMING UP ON THIS
BILL. I'M KAREN STEWART ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF TALENT EIGHT TEN
CHAIRMAN THURMAN MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TO SPEAK TODAY.
I HAVE WE HAVE WORKED VERY HARD
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT OF I WAS JUST
TELLING THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT.
IT'S IT'S BEEN A TOUGH ROAD.
IT'S HARD TO MAKE SOME OF THESE
CHANGES BUT THEY'RE IMPORTANT
CHANGES.
.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL REQUIRE
LICENSE TALENT AGENTS TO MAKE
AVAILABLE TO ARTISTS CLIENTS
APPROVED EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
REGARDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT. AND
HEALTHY EATING AND EATING
DISORDER PREVENTION.
AND WE WILL WORK WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND OTHERS TO
CREATE THOSE APPROVED UP
MATERIALS TO MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE.
WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE TALENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA THEY REPRESENT
THOUSANDS IF NOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ARTISTS.
.
THIS IS REALLY MODEL LEGISLATION
AND IT WILL BE ONE OF A KIND
LEGISLATION WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT.
IT ALSO REQUIRES AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO ENSURE THAT
MINERS AND GUARDIANS RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING. AND OTHER
TRAINING FOR A NUTRITIONAL
TRAINING BEFORE THEIR GRANTED A
WORK PERMIT.
AND I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT HERE I THINK
THAT MINORS IN OUR INDUSTRY
REALLY TO LACK THAT INFORMATION
AND THAT KNOWLEDGE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER AND OTHER
INDUSTRY EXPERTS. TO HELP WITH
THAT MATERIAL TOGETHER.
WE'RE HERE AT SUPPORT WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE YOU. AND
ALL OF THE AUTHORS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN HIS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE I DO
REMEMBER THIS BILL WHEN YOU CAME
HERE IN JANUARY AND.
.
NO ONE WAS SMILING AT THE TABLE
LIKE YOU ARE NOW SO WANNA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK TOGETHER.
AND.
GLAD THAT YOU ALL WERE ABLE TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT ON WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED. AS MODEL LEGISLATION
AND I.
THANK YOU AND.
THEY TURN TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SOME AMERICANS ALL FLETCHER
THINK IT LIKE TO HAVE THE BELL
THAT AND I WANNA THANK YOU
MISTER LEVINE I MEAN AND HOPE
THAT WE HAVE HAD SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS.
ANNA IT TAKES A LOT TO GET THIS
KIND OF AGREEMENT SELL. YOU
HAVE.
EARN YOUR STRIPES ON THIS BILL
SO I'M THINK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR FOR EVERYBODY COMING
TOGETHER AND. DOING REALLY
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR WORK AND
THE SINCE THE WHERE I MEAN THE
WORKERS BUT.
.
I'M IMPRESSED
I'M IMPRESSED YOU DID IT YEAH
SOMETIMES I THINK THAT OUR JOB
CONVINCING MAYBE EIGHTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND AND SOME SENATORS TO
TO AGREE ON SOMETHING WE DON'T
NEED TO GET ALL OF THEM BUT. YOU
KNOW I REALLY CREDIT MS STEWART
FOR WORKING WITH HER ASSOCIATION
AND DIED THE RINGLING THAT HAS
TO BE INVOLVED IN THAT AS WELL.
AND I THINK THAT THE INSPIRATION
AND MORAL SUPPORT FROM NIDA.
YOU KNOW WHICH.
HAS BEEN WITH US WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES FOR YEARS SO I I
THINK ALL OF STAKEHOLDER SO MUCH
FOR HELPING TO MAKE THIS I GET
TO THIS POINT BUT THIS IS ONLY.
ONE MILESTONE GOT A FEW OTHER
COMMITTEES.
IT THAT TO GET THROUGH AS WELL
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH SOME REALLY BE OUR
SOUTHWEST FRANCO.
IS THERE A MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION.
IS OUR SECOND. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND SOUND THIS BILL
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
WE KALRA.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA I GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
YOU BILLS UP YOU REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
IT'S ANYONE SO A BILL A BE NICE
NOT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NO TWO
WHICH WILL REQUIRE COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE VALUED OVER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO PAY SUB
CONTRACTED SERVICE WORKERS WAGES
TIED.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT'S INCOME
LEVELS FOR THE COUNTYTHEY WORK
IN. MAJOR CORPORATIONS ARE
MAKING IMMENSE PROFITS AND A
REWARDING SKILLS CERTAIN
SKILLSETS WITH HIGH WAGES BETTER
UNDERVALUING SERVICE WORKERS
CORPORATIONS ARE CONTRACTING OUT
SERVICE LABOR. LEAVING THESE
WORKERS WITHOUT TODD THAT
BENEFITS OF BEING. AN EMPLOYEE
AND INCLUDES STUFF SUCH AS
SECURITY GUARDS BUS DRIVERS
CUSTODIAL STAFF TO SERVICE
WORKERS
AND MORE.
SINCE THESE WORKERS NOT HAVE
BENEFITS FOR WAGES THAT FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES RECEIVE
SUBCONTRACTED SERVICE WORKERS
FACE MANY OBSTACLES IN ACCESSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO FURTHER AND
SECURE THEIR FUTURES FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND OUR FAMILIES THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE
SUBCONTRACTED WORKERS
THE UPWARD MOBILITY THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
AND PLAN FOR THEIR FUTURES
ASPIRIN AIBO.
THANK YOU THAT WITNESSES TO CALL
FOR.
VERY GOOD A ANYONE WISHING TO.
ADD ON IN EXPRESSED SUPPORT TO
THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER BROWN TO HAVE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
PROPOSAL. AYE WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE.
BROAD AUTHORITY THIS PROVIDES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ONE TO VALUE THE OF
VALUE OF THE CORPORATION.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO ASSESS
THAT VALUE BASED UPON A
WHATEVER.
AYE ASSETS THE COMPANY MAY HAVE
BEEN WE'RE NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WOULD CONSIDER.
THE VALUE OF THE STOCK EXCHANGE
WHAT STOCK EXCHANGE THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY LOOK AT HOW THEY WOULD
ADD VALUE THAT AT ANY GIVEN TIME
DURING THE YEAR BECAUSE THAT
VALUATION OBVIOUSLY COULD GO UP
AND DOWN BASED UPON THEIR STOCK
PRICE.
AND HOW THEY EVEN MAKE THAT
ASSESSMENT FOR PURPOSES
DETERMINING WHETHER THEY'RE
COVERED AND THE MANDATE OF THIS
BILL WILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
DIR AS I'M EXTENSIVE AUTHORITY
TO DETERMINE WHAT THE AREA
INCOME IS WHICH IS UNDEFINED IN
THE BILL RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT
SURE EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS. OR
WHO THAT WOULD INCLUDE AND WHAT
PROFESSIONS THAT WOULD INCLUDE
IS THAT THE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA
AND ARE WE BRINGING AND
PROFESSION UP PROFESSIONAL
PEOPLE WITH ADVANCED SKILLS
TRAINING AND EDUCATION WHO DO
HAVE A HIGHER WAGE. AND
COMPARING THEM FOR PURPOSES OF
THESE PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS IT ALSO GIVES THE IDEA
OR A SENSE OF AUTHORITY TO ADD.
ADDITIONAL.
OCCUPATIONS WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACT AND WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH REGARDS TO HOW WHAT THIS
WOULD DO FOR PURPOSES OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE INDIVIDUAL
COMPANIES WHO HAVE THESE
CONTRACTS IF YOU PRICES
CONTRACTS AT SUCH A HIGH LEVEL.
THAT IT'S NO LONGER COST
EFFICIENT FOR THESE COMPANIES TO
CONTRACT FOR THAT YOU WILL GET A
SOME IN HOUSE BUT IT WILL BE
PROBABLY A ONE FOR ONE RATIO
WHERE YOU'RE BRINGING ON ALL THE
CONTRACTORS IN HOUSE SINCE WE
HAVE A CONCERN. WITH THE IMPACT
THIS WOULD HAVE ON THOSE
COMPANIES WHO ARE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES AND THEIR ABILITY TO
SUSTAIN SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHAUN KNOWS THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS REPRESENTS
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO POST.
THANK YOU.
ANGER WITH CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ALSO POST
MAKE YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE TRYING TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEE NINE.
IS OUR MOTION.
THERE'S QUESTIONS I REMEMBER
KALRA.
THANK YOU. AM SO THAT YOU KNOW
ACTUALLY.
OTHER I APPLAUD YOU FOR THE
GOALS OF THE BILL AND I THINK
THAT. THERE'S STILL SOME
RETURNEES BE DONE I THINK I
THINK.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT. I'M.
THEN SO I GUESS WHAT THAT
THERE'S STILL A GIVEN THE FACT
THEY'RE STILL.
TO QUESTION WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
NEXT STEP IN TERMS OF TRYING TO.
.
BUT THE MORE PARAMETERS ON THE
BILL THAT I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL LOVE FOR US TO KNOW IN
ORDER TO. ASSURE THAT THINK YOU
VERY MUCH SCARRY PREACHER THE
QUESTION.
THE THE AREA INCOME IS DEFINED
BY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE COUNTY THAT
IS THE THE LOCUS OF THE WORK
IT'S BEEN.
PRETTY CLEARLY DEFINE
THE INCOME LEVEL IS NOT.
AND THAT SIMPLY TO ENGAGE THE
STAKEHOLDERS OTHER NOT GOING TO
GET ENGAGED IF DEMOCRATS
DISAPPEAR. AND AREN'T HERE TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AND THE
BILL JUST FOUNDERS WHERE IT
STARTS ON.
THEY THEY NEED TO COME TO THE
TABLE TO SAY WELL WHAT IS THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OF MONEY TO PAY
PEOPLE FOR.
A SET OF SKILLS THAT IS REALLY
ON.
LOOK DOWN UPON YOU CELEBRATE.
STEM
SKILLS BUT YOU SAY THAT IF YOU
ARE AN IMMIGRANT AND YOU'RE A
JANITOR. THAT YOU CAN NEVER BE
ANYTHING ELSE.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY'VE
DONE.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE IN YOUR
TIMES.
LAST YEAR ABOUT A JANITOR AT
KODAK AT WORK IN ROCHESTER NEW
YORK IN THE EIGHTIES.
SHE HAD.
FULL TIME WORK.
AND AMOUNT OF PAY AND VACATION
TIME AND EDUCATION BENEFITS
INTRINSICALLY TO GO TO SCHOOL
SHOULD NEVER BECOME THE CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER. OF KODAK IN
ROCHESTER NEW YORK IN THE
EIGHTIES
EVEN TALKED ABOUT IMMIGRANT.
JANITOR AT APPLE IN CUPERTINO IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
MAKING INFLATION ADJUSTED.
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY FROM
THE EIGHTIES IN ROCHESTER.
WITH NO BENEFITS
NO RUNG IN THE LADDER.
EVER CLIMB UP AND GET HERSELF
OUT OF WORKING POVERTY.
AND THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT
WE'VE GOT.
THREE COMPANIES THAT DO GREAT
THINGS AND THEY DON'T DO
JANITORIAL WORK PRETTY WELL.
SO THEY GOING CONTRACT OUT FOR
THE CHEAPEST JANITORIAL WORK
POSSIBLE WHICH MEANS THAT IT
DEPRESSES WAGES.
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE. OUT
WORKING FOR VERY LITTLE THAT CAN
NEVER LIVE ANYWHERE NEAR WHERE
THEY WORK WHOSE KIDS CAN'T EVER
GO TO SCHOOL ANYWHERE AND DON'T
HAVE.
A FUTURE AHEAD OF THEM THAT'S
BETTER THAN WHAT THEY'VE GOT.
SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO ACTUALLY ADVANCE THE CAUSE.
OF.
O. WORKING POOR THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY. AND I I THINK I
PROBABLY TALK TO YOU ABOUT THIS
BEFORE IT AT A NEW CASTE SYSTEM.
OF UNTOUCHABLES
THAT WILL NEVER BE A PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WE PAY THEM SO LITTLE
THAT THEY CAN NEVER. GET ARE UP
AYE IN IN PURSUING SECURITY FOR
THEIR FAMILY AND AND WHAT WE ALL
THINK OF AS AS THE AMERICAN
DREAM THE CALIFORNIA TREAT
WITCHES YOUR CHILDREN AND YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN HAVE A BETTER LIFE
THAN YOU HAVE.
WELL LOU THANK YOU AND AS I
INDICATED AND.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE GOAL NOT
JUST THE GOAL BUT I THINK THE
PREMISE IS ABSOLUTELY VALID.
HAVING GROWN UP IN IN SAN JOSE
AND SILICON VALLEY IN HAVING.
GROWN UP.
WITHIN A BIKE RIDE OF IBM'S A
BUS BECAUSE HEADQUARTERS WHICH
IS NO LONGER THERE BUT THE TIME.
REALLY LIFTED UP SO MANY IN THE
COMMUNITY I DO THINK I DON'T
THINK IT'S UNIQUE.
THE TO ANY WELL ONE INDUSTRY I
THINK THAT THE PART OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN. THIS
ISSUE A CONTRACT NOT NOT DOES OF
OF TIME DETACHMENT FROM CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF WORK.
AS OPPOSED EVERYONE HAVING THE
SAME BADGER ONE CAN OF BOB
LOOKING UBER BEGINNING TO GET A
COMPARTMENT SAME TEAM AND WE'VE
SEEN SOME. PROBLEMS THAT IT WAS
HARD AND PART OF IT HAS BEEN
THROUGH ORGANIZING.
BUT I THINK THAT I THINK THAT
THERE'S BEEN BENEFITS TO IT FOR
EXAMPLE APPLE BRING IN THIS
COLLAPSES AND HOUSE.
I THINK JUST THE VALUE OF
HISTORY OF SNOBBY I'M AN APPLE
EMPLOYEE THAT BY ITSELF. I THINK
IS PART OF.
WHAT? ALLOW CERTAIN I'D BECOME
SO COULD I THIS PRIDE AIM IN
BEING PART OF SOMETHING.
THAT THAT IS GLOBALLY
RECOGNIZED AND AND SO I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO MAKE A MOTIONS
OF THAT YOU CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT OPPORTUNITY I DO THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF. QUESTIONS AS
SOME OF THE DETAILS.
BUT.
I ALSO KNOW THAT.
.
THERE IS. HOWEVER THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO COME
TO THE TABLE TO.
TURN A GOOD JUDGE OF RECOGNIZE
THIS VALUE OF WORK TO RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE OF WORK THAT.
BUT COMPANIES ARE DOING AMAZING
THINGS AND THERE ARE CREATING
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WEALTH THAT
I'M THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYONE TO FEEL PART OF IT.
UNLESS WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS AND AMOUNT OF WEALTH BUT
THE LEAST FEEL PART OF THAT
SUCCESS THAT REALLY CREATIVE
SILICON VALLEY THREE OR FOUR
DECADES AGO. AYE IN ITS INFANCY
SO WITHOUT A DOUBT.
A MOOD DEL.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEM NOT TO LIKE CLUB.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
I DO THIS BILL DOES HAVE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
BUT BILLS OUT THE REGULATIONS
MRS PROGRESS THANK YOU.
KAREN MEMBERS.
IF YOU.
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON IS PRESENT WE A WHO IS
REPRESENTING THREE BILLS TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN OUT.
AND MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
OF PRESENTING THAT THE THREE
BELLS.
WITH A VERY UP BRIEF LITTLE
PREMISE.
.
WHATEVER YOUR. INCLINATION MAY
BE WITH RESPECT TO THESE BILLS.
AND WHATEVER YOUR.
GENERALIZED PERCEPTION MIGHT BE
OF.
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE IT THAT
WITH FARM WORKERS IN THE FIELDS.
THESE ARE FARMWORKERS. UP AND
DOWN THE STATE.
I ASK THAT YOU HEAR THEM.
AND LISTEN TO THEIR CONCERNS.
THESE BILLS.
ARE AN EFFORT.
TO PUT THEIR CONCERNS INTO.
SUB MUCH CHANGES
THAT RECOGNIZES.
THE AREAS THAT THEY THEY THINK
NEEDS WHO NEED TO BE IMPROVED.
I IN MANY WAYS THIS MAY OF.
BLIND THE FACE OF CONDUCT
INVENTION OF WISDOM AND POINTS
OF VIEW.
BUT THEY ARE.
HONESTLY AND LEGITIMATELY HELD
BY THE INDIVIDUALS YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM.
FOR THE REASONS AND THE PURPOSES
THAT ARE.
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WE HAVE FARMWORKERS HERE FROM
COMMENT READ LEAVE ELAINE NO
RICH GROW BY SALIA SALINAS.
OVER A HUNDRED NOT ALL WILL LINE
UP.
AT SOME HAVE TO GO BACK HOME.
BUT THEY ARE REPRESENTATIVE.
OF A VERY DIFFERENT POINT OF
VIEW IN A VERY DIFFERENT REALITY
THEIR.
AND I'M ASKING.
AS WE PRESENT THE BILL'S.
OF FOR THE COURTESY OF UP.
YOUR ATTENTION TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS THIS IS A.
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO BE HEARD
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT
I WOULD SAY THAT I KNOW THAT
EVERYONE WILL BE HEARD TO DATE
THIS COMMITTEE WELCOMES ALL
PERSPEX AND STAN AND WE MAY NOT
ALL AGREE BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY THIS COMMITTEE CARES ABOUT.
HELPING WORKING PEOPLE EVERYONE
WILL BE HEARD EVERYONE IS
WELCOME.
I'M WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH AB THIRTY NINETY TWO
YES.
PLEASE PROCEED AND AND AGAIN THE
PREMISE WAS NOT TO SUGGEST THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE BUT WE ARE
IN AN AREA THAT IS A BIT UNUSUAL
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT.
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR THEIR
POINTS OF VIEW AND THEIR AND
THEIR NEEDS OUT THERE AND.
.
WITH THAT.
WILL INTRODUCE THE THE BILL'S
AND AND AND HEAR FROM THOSE WHO.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE MOB MOVED
FORWARD.
CALIFORNIA LAW ESTABLISHES THE
RIGHT OF AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEES
TO FORM JOIN OR ASSIST LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS.
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
ACTIVITIES WITH AGRICULTURAL AND
EMPLOYERS REGARDING WAGES WORK
CONDITIONS ARE OTHER ASPECTS OF
EMPLOYMENT.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW GOVERNING
AGRICULTURAL RELATIONS IS
SILENT.
ON INSTANCES WHEN A LABOR
ORGANIZATION WINS AN ELECTION
FOR THE IGHT TO REPRESENT A
GROUP OF WORKERS. BUT THEN IN
THE OPINION OF.
FARM WORKERS DISAPPEARS.
AB THREE ZERO NINE TWO REQUIRES
THE LRB.
THE NULLIFY A UNION CONTRACT IF
THE UNION ABANDONS THE WORKERS.
FOR A PERIOD OF THREE.
OR MORE YEARS.
IN MY DISTRICT AND IN OTHER
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
GROUPS OF WORKERS.
WHO HAVE BEEN ABANDONED?
BY THE UNIONS THAT THEY VOTED
FOR.
IN SOME CASES MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS AGO.
THE WORKERS THERE TODAY WERE NOT
PART OF THE DECISION MAKING NOT
PART OF THE VOTE.
WE'RE NOT EVEN EMPLOYED AT THE
TIME.
AND THEY RESPECT.
SPEC FULLY REQUEST THAT THE
UNION EARNED THE RIGHT TO
REPRESENT THEM.
NOT SIMPLY HAVE A CONTRACT
FORCED UPON THEM.
AND WAGES THAT THEY HAD NOTHING
TO SAY.
OR HAVE INPUT AND WITH RESPECT
TO.
TO THEIR PAYCHECKS.
SO THIS BILL WOULD OFFER
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THIS
PRACTICE.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT SO THAT
ANY AGRICULTURAL LABOR
ORGANIZATION THAT ABANDONS FOR
LONGER THAN THREE YEARS THE
WORKERS IT WAS ELECTED TO SERVE.
WITH THEM LOSE ITS CERTIFICATION
AND RIGHT TO REPRESENT THE
BARGAINING UNIT.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND EXPLAIN THE NEED
FOR THE BILL.
SILVIA LOPEZ AND JESSIE ROHA.
HI YEAH.
ON MY NAME IS SYLVIA LOPEZ AND
I'M A FARMWORKERS FROM FRESNO
COUNTY.
MEN MY WHOLE FAMILY WORKS AT
THAT THE FEEL SINCE.
WE CAME TO UNITED STATES FOR A
DREAM THAT.
THE MY DAD SAID THAT HE. IN THE
UNITED STATES WILL RESPECT US.
LIKE THEY COULDN'T DO IT IN
MEXICO COULD THAT'S WAY OUT I'M
HERE TODAY. I THINK YOU GUYS TO.
TO BE HERE AND.
I BELIEVE IS A HARD. POSITION TO
TO BE THERE AND LISTEN TO A LOT
OF THINGS THAT IS.
GOING OUT THERE.
.
I AM HERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE BE SUFFERING.
ARM IN THIS AREA AND.
FRESNO COUNTY.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TALL.
SOMETIMES I THINK THAT THIS
NEVER GONNA END.
BUT THEN I LOOK AT TUNE NORTH.
HERE'S SACRAMENTO AND I THINK.
AND I THINK THE CAPITAL IT IS
FOR SOMETHING I THINK IS THERE
BECAUSE MAYBE IT'S A HOPE THAT
ONE DAY THEIR WORD LISTEN TO US
AND HELP US IN.
AND AND TO BE HEARD.
ARM.
I WAS WITNESS THE A LOT OF A LOT
OF THINGS HAPPEN TO US THERE
MORE WE ARE MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND FARM WORKERS AND THIS
AREA FRESNO AREA.
THAT WOULD BE SUFFERING.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T BE
HEARD.
AND.
TODAY I CAME HERE WITH A LOT A
WHOLE ENDS.
IN A MOMENT I FEEL THAT.
I'M JUST WASTING MY TIME. BUT
THEN I THINK THEN I REMEMBER
THOSE OF THOSE THREE THOUSAND
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND FARM
WORKERS OUT THERE.
THEIR KIDS THEIR FAMILIES AND
THAT'S WHY GIVE ME STRAIGHT TO
BE HERE IN FRONT OF YOU GUYS.
AND ASSUMING THAT YOU GUYS
HERE'S.
ASSUMING THAT YOU GUYS
ARE HERE FOR US FARMWORKERS
IMMIGRANTS MEXICANS PANIC.
AND THAT GAVE ME THE HOPE AGAIN
TO BE HERE FRONT OF YOU GUYS
TODAY I BEEN HERE BEFORE.
INVEST SUPPORT THIS THIS LA
BECAUSE.
I'M THE UNITED FARM WORKERS THEY
ABOUNDED THOSE THIS WORKERS
WANTED TWENTY YEARS IN.
I THINK THAT'S JUST NOT RIGHT.
AND.
ONE OF MY. MY PARENTS DREAMS
THIS.
THAT.
THEY TOLD US THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE RESPECT LIKE.
HUMAN IN THIS COUNTRY.
HAD THAT'S ONE OF THE REASON
THAT I'M HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU.
JUST A ROBUST SPOKESPERSON FOR
PIC JUSTICE THAT THE VOICE OF
THE NINETY NINE PERCENT OF FARM
WORKERS IN THE STATE. SO AB
THREE ZERO NINE TWO.
THE OLD THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES
AT A LARGE A PEACH BERMAN FRESNO
COUNTY.
FOR MANY YEARS NOW HAVE BEEN
EARNING AT THE HIGHEST INDUSTRY
WAGES IN FACT SOME OF THEM EARN
MORE THAN A SCHOOL TEACHER. AYE
WHEN SUDDENLY THIS UNION ODD
THAT DISAPPEAR FOR TWENTY YEARS
BACK.
YOU KNOW THEY COME BACK TO
FORCED ITSELF ON THE WORKERS
WHICH MOST OF THEM ARE NOT EVEN
BORN BACK IN THE NINETIES.
THE UNION TO THE WORKERS THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
MONEY THREE PERCENT OF THEIR
WAGES TO THE UNION. OR THEY
WOULD BE FIRED IF THEY DIDN'T.
A CONTRACT.
WITHOUT LETTING THE EMPLOYEE SEE
IT REVIEW IT OR VOTE FOR IT
OUGHT TO FOURTEEN IS WORKERS.
ARE YOU KNOW THE CONTRACT WOULD
ACTUALLY LOWER THEIR PAY AND ON
TOP OF THAT IT WAS STRIPPED THEM
OF THE RIGHT TO PROTEST WHICH I
THINK THE CIVIL. RIGHT
FUNDAMENTAL A RIGHT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY'LL ARE BE EVEN ADMITTED
HIMSELF THAT THE UNION HAD
DISAPPEAR BECAUSE THEY HAD NO
WAY TO PROVE THAT THEY'VE EVER
SEND THE FATS A TELEGRAM OR EVEN
SMOKE SIGNALS AND OF TWENTY
YEARS.
BUT THE ELLERBEE SET THE LAW DID
IN OUR.
ALLOW THEM TO RECOGNIZE
ABANDONMENT.
IT'S PRETTY DISTURBING
IT'S LIKE IMAGININGS SEIU
ABANDONING THE HUNDREDS OF
WORKERS IN THIS CAPITAL IN THIS
BUILDING. NEVER RATIFYING A
CONTRACT NEVER NEGOTIATING ON
THE TABLE.
HE MET OF THE CHAOS THERE WELL
THAT'S HAPPENED FARMWORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
SO FOR THE SAKE OF THOUSANDS OF
REAL FARMWORKERS THE NINETY NINE
PERCENT IMMIGRANT LATINO FARM
WORKERS THAT CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY. SCAPIN MEDICAL LIKE
MYSELF.
LET THAT DEALER BE DID CERTIFY
UNIONS THAT DISAPPEAR THAT DO
NOT REPRESENT WORKERS.
SO I URGE YOU TO VOTE. YES ON
THIS A BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS WISHING.
TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
HELLO  MY NAME IS NOT ON THE
ULTIMATE I DON'T. KNOW TWENTY
TWO YEARS OLD A LIVE MADERA
CALIFORNIA. AND I SUPPORT HIS
BILL BECAUSE.
I'M A SINGLE MOM.
ANOTHER STILL PARENT BUT I HAVE
PARENTS HERE. AND NOW WIFE AND
KIDS AND THOSE THREE PERCENT.
THAT THEY'RE TAKEN AWAY FROM US
COULD HAVE BEEN FORMA KIDS.
WHICH I DON'T HAVE RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T HAVE THAT THREE PERCENT.
ADDING SEE NO CONTRACT ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. SO I THINK IT WOULD
BE FAIR IF.
THERE WERE AT LEAST LET US KNOW
OUR VICES.
.
I HAVE BILLS TO PAY. HAVE TWO
KIDS AND.
IT'S REALLY HARD I DON'T HAVE
SOARED TO FALL BACK ON ON HOW
PARENTS SO. THAT THE PERSON WILL
HELP ME OUT A LOT.
HOME LEFT IT THINK MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT IT AND I
APPRECIATE AYE I DO UNDERSTAND
THE. PROCESS IN THE RULES HERE
AND UP UP REMINDER. TO THEY ARE
AND THAT THEY SUPPORT THE BILL
IS CERTAINLY.
SUFFICIENT IF YOU. ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE TO TESTIFY THAT WOULD
BE FINE BUT WE WOULD CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE.
THE RULES OF COMMITTEE.
WE WE DO HAVE A RULE THAT NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION HOW
MANY SPEAKERS.
DO YOU HAVE SIR.
ABOUT ONE PRETTY TWENTY.
TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS ROSA LOPEZ I COME
FROM A DEREK CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT AT A. B. THIRTY NINE TO.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PLACENTA LOPEZ
I COME FROM MADERA.
AND AYE SUPPORT.
AB.
THREE ZERO TWO THREE THREE ZERO
NINETY TWO. THANK YOU.
OR LIKE WHEN ESTABLISHED Y.
YAMAMOTO THAT HE.
AND.
YOU ALSO DON'T HAVE VOTER THAT
CUMPLE.
THE.
YOU'VE ON IF THE FIDDLER YES.
E. GET OKAY SUMMIT US BUT THEY.
IN.
IF THE METASPECTRUM ME MOVIES
BOUGHT THE.
KIRKUK WANTED ME SMOG FILTHY.
E. YES THEY.
PROCESSED ALTHOUGH GOSSIPS.
YES YES MAKE YOU.
NO MINUTES INTO OFFICE.
I WOULD SUPPORT A BIG THIRTY
NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU.
HI MY LIMITS IN JORDAN CLONE.
I ALSO BORE.
A NEW PERSONAL THE AV DURING
NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
SO YEAH REALLY NOT BAD TO
SUPPORT THE LEAD.
A WEEK THEY THEY DEMO IN VEGAS.
AS HE
YES YES.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
WE NOTICED THAT THE THREE SPEAKS
THOUGHT ABOUT ONE INCOME PAUL E.
WBNS THEY.
OPAL URINATE A. LOT OFONE OF
THE NUMBER OF PERMANENTLY BUT
ACTUALLY.
THE KILLINGS THE PLAN THE PETA.
MENIFEE SEAL LIBERALS
COMPRESSING.
YES YES.
I MEAN I'M THIS CLOSE OF IT
LATER.
YEAH BOYLAN THEY HAVE A THING
DONE AND.
DRESSERS.
THE NUMBERS HURDLE BERMUDA'S.
YES PERCOLATE OF IT RENTALS.
PRECIOUS.
MY NAME IS FERNANDO AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THE A. B. VERY NAY
TO.
THANK THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
.
MY NAME IS MARIO MARTINEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS IN OPPOSITION TO IT A.
B. THIRTY NINETY TWO.
I DID WANT TO CORRECT SOME
SERIOUS.
MISINFORMATION AND FRANKLY THIS
HONESTY.
ABOUT.
STATE OF THE LAW.
THE AUTHOR.
TOLD EVERYONE HERE TODAY THAT
THE LAW IS SILENT ON THIS ISSUE.
THAT IS FALSE.
BUT IT'S PAUL.
THE LAW IS NOT SIGNED.
FOR ALMOST FOUR DECADES.
VARIOUS.
MEMBERS OF THE AGRICULTURAL
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD.
GOING BACK ALMOST FORTY YEARS.
HAVE REJECTED THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
ABANDONMENT DEFENSE.
BECAUSE IT WOULD PERMIT
EMPLOYERS TO REFUSE TO BARGAIN
WITH THE UNION SELECTED BY THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
THAT LA HAS BEEN NOT ONLY
APPROVED BY THE COURTS OF
APPEAL.
BUT RECENTLY.
IN A UNANIMOUS DECISION.
SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT SUPPORTED DOT
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW.
FOR THE AUTHOR TO SAY. THAT THE
LOT SILENT IT'S FALSE.
IT'S FALSE.
THIS IDEA OF ABANDONMENT HAS
BEEN REJECTED PRECISELY BECAUSE
EMPLOYERS REFUSED TO BARGAIN.
WITH UNIONS THAT ARE REPRESENTED
BY EMPLOYEES.
THE LAS VERY CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
APPROVED THIS INTERPRETATION
THERE IS NO NEED.
I TRY TO CHANGE THAT LAW BECAUSE
THE LABOR BOARD HAS EXPERTISE.
THE JUSTICES HAVE LOOKED AT THIS
ISSUE AND HAVE REJECTED IT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE ISSUE OF
WORKERS NOT HAVING VOTED.
THAT'S THE STATE OF THE LAW WITH
ANY LABOR LAW.
THE AUTO WORKERS' THAT VOTED FOR
UNION REPRESENTATION DECADES
AGO.
DON'T HAVE TO REVOTE EVERY YEAR
TO HAVE. REPRESENTATION.
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS THAT ARE
REPRESENTED BY THEIR UNIONS DO
NOT HAVE TO VOTE. EVERY YEAR
EVEN THOSE THOUGH THOSE
ELECTIONS TOOK PLACE DECADES
AGO.
THAT'S THE SAME PRINCIPLE HERE.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
RECOGNIZES THAT WHEN EMPLOYEES
LEGITIMATELY.
WHAT TO DO AWAY WITH THEIR
UNION?
NOT BECAUSE THEIR EMPLOYERS.
FORCING THEM TO OR SUPPORTING
THEM TO WHEN EMPLOYEES
LEGITIMATELY WANT TO DO AWAY
WITH THEIR UNION THERE ARE
PROCEDURES THERE IN PLACE.
FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES TO USE.
TO VOTE OUT THERE UNION.
BASED ON THAT THE UNION OPPOSES
AB THIRTY NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
SHOCKER CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN ABOUT
OPPOSITION. MAKE YOU.
SECURE MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO POST THANK YOU.
JESSICA STENDER EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES OPPOSED THANK YOU.
INVESTMENT BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS OPPOSED.
IQ ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL TURN TWO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIRMAN BACK CLOSE.
WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THEN YOU WOULD HAVE
KNOWN THEM FOR BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DRIVE US ABSOLUTELY.
SIMILAR GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
PATTERSON.
Q. DEFINE.
AND IN MEN.
.
YES I CAN I ACTUALLY.
IT WITH THE A LR BEES OWN
DEFINITION OF ABANDONMENT AND
I'M QUOTING.
A SHOWING. THAT THE UNION WAS
UNWILLING OR UNABLE TO REPRESENT
THE BARGAINING UNIT.
AT AN.
THEY ARE BE THEN AGREES WITH
YOU THAT THESE WORKERS WERE
ABANDONED.
NOW AT WHAT I'M WHAT I'M SAYING
IS THAT YOU'RE GIVING ME A
DEFINITION FROM THE A A RP YET
THEY ARE BE HAS REJECTED IN THIS
CLAIM. AND BROUGHT FORWARD
WORKERS GOD BLESS THOSE WORKERS
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR COMING
OUT.
AND USE YOUR TIME.
WHICH.
I'M SURE IS UNCOMPENSATED TO
COME.
TALK TO US BECAUSE I DO VALUE
FARMWORKERS A VALUE FARMWORKERS
SO MUCH THAT HE CONSISTENTLY.
VOTE FOR THEIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS TO INCREASE THIS IS NOT
A BENEFIT.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD DO FOR YOU.
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
ANY SUGGESTION THAT WE WHAT'S
CHANGED A LOT IN ORDER TO
ENCOURAGE GROWERS OR ANY OTHER
EMPLOYER. TO NOT INANE HONEST
WAY BARGAIN WITH THE UNION THAT
HAS BEEN CHOSEN.
BY WORKERS.
IS INCREDULOUS
THE THOUGHT THAT WE'D EVEN BRING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT FORWARD. TO
ENCOURAGE WHAT IS ALREADY
STANDARD PRACTICE THROUGHOUT
PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT TO NOT
BARGAIN AT FIRST CONTRACT IS
INSULTING AND THEN TO SOMEHOW
SUGGEST THAT ITS ABANDONMENT BY
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO WORK SO HARD
WITH THOSE WORKERS TO ORGANIZE
THEM INTO A UNION TO HAVE A
VOICE.
I AM SO SORRY.
THAT YOUR EMPLOYER HAS SO MISLED
YOU ON THIS ISSUE.
THAT IS REALLY JUST HEART NOW I
AM NOT.
ASKING I AM TELLING YOU.
I AM SORRY FOR THAT.
BUT IT IS INSULTING TO ME AS
SOMEBODY WHO SPENT A LOT OF MY
LIFE WORKING FOR FARMWORKERS TO
SUGGEST SOMEHOW. THAT THAT THIS
HELPS FARMWORKERS.
IT HELPS UNEMPLOYED HERE.
NOT HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE WILL
OF THE WORKERS.
BUT I WON'T BE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL TO.
Q. OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS HOMES ON
THE MEMBER MASSERIA'S SOMEONE
MISTER ROSS. HAS THANK YOU AND
IT'S NOT REALLY A BACK AND FORTH
JUST CLARIFICATION FOR THE
RECORD YES THEY ARE BE HAS
ADMITTED IN MULTIPLE TIMES AND I
WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
SUBMIT IT TO YOUR OFFICE MRS
GONZALEZ. THAT THEY'VE ADMITTED
TO THE ABANDONMENT FAQ YOU JUST
HAD THE MARK MARTINEZ HE DID HE
SHOW YOU ANY FATS OR ANY SINGLE
RECORD THAT THEY DID NOT ABANDON
FOR THAT FACT. KNOW THEY'VE
NEVER DID. THEY NEVER DISPUTED
IN THE FIFTIES RECALL OF
APPEALS.
THAT NET NAY NEVER DISPUTED IN
THE SUPREME COURT.
THEY'VE THEY ARE BE THEY NEVER
THE SPIRIT TO THEY'LL ARE BEING
THAT ALSO NEVER PROVEN THAT WITH
ONE SINGLE COMMUNICATION IN
THOSE TWENTY YEARS.
THE REQUESTED ABANDONMENT YES
THEY WERE ABANDONED THEY DON'T
EVEN REFUTE THAT THAT THERE WAS
NO ATTEMPT TO CHECK EVER
BARGAINED FIRST CONTRACT. THAT I
DON'T THINK WE'LL CHECK YOU THE
ATTORNEY SITTING RIGHT NOW AND I
KNOW THAT THIS IS AN ONGOING
CASE IN ALLER BEE HAS RULED IN
FACULTY ABOUT A MAN'S ON AN
ONGOING CASE OKAY AS ARRESTING
AND HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ROBUST
DISCUSS YES. WE'RE GOING TO
DISAGREE AND I'M JUST WE ARE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT.
IN A MANNER.
THAT AS A YES NOT OF AN
APPRECIATE THAT.
AGAIN.
.
BEYLERBEY HAS.
A DEFINITION.
SHOWING THAT THE UNION WERE WAS
UNWILLING OR UNABLE TO REPRESENT
THE BARGAINING UNIT.
AND THERE ARE FACTORS THAT THEY
TAKE UNDER CONSIDERATION IF THE
UNION SIMPLY CEASES TO
COMMUNICATE. WITH THE WORKERS.
OR EMPLOYERS MAKES NO ATTEMPT TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE
WORKERS.
FOR NUMEROUS YEARS HOW DOES THIS
ACTIVITY NOT QUALIFIED.
AS ABANDONMENT UNDER THE AARP'S
DEFINITION. AND BACK HAS BEEN
THE EXPERIENCE THAT THESE
FARMWORKERS HAVE HAD.
AND THAT WITH THAT.
IF THEY HAVE ASK THAT
ABANDONMENT BE SOMETHING THAT.
THAT WE CONSIDER IN THIS BILL
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE.
SUFFICE IT TO SAY THERE IS NOT
AGREEMENT.
AS IT RELATES TO THE ISSUES OF
ABANDONMENT BUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR POINTS.
WE HEAR THE POINT OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS DID YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OF COMET.
JUST DONE THEY APPRECIATE.
BIG JUSTICE MAKING THE TIME TO
TO MAKE IT APPEAR.
AND TAKING THE TRIP OUT OF THE
FILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I MOTION WITH
THE BILL.
SO MOTION IS IS A MOTION AND A
SECOND ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
QUESTION OF COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I SEEN THAT SIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL PREVENTS A
UNION FROM FILING UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGES FOR AN EMPLOYER
FAILING TO NEGOTIATE.
HOWEVER IF INSTEAD OF
NEGOTIATING.
THE UNION DOES IN FACT DISAPPEAR
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
NOT ONLY FAILS TO FILE AN UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE CHARGE WHICH HAS
BEEN GOING ON IN THIS CASE.
BUT ALSO DOES NOT TAKE ACCESS TO
THE THAT INTO THE FIELDS TO
CHECK ON THE EMPLOYEES THAT
ELECTED IT.
DOES NOT FILE GRIEVANCES DOES
NOT CALL THE EMPLOYER NOR SEND
ANY LETTERS OR EMAILS.
THESE REALLY ARE THAT THESE ARE
ACTS OF THE BAND AND BY ANY
DEFINITION.
AND OF COURSE NOTHING IN THE
BILL.
SAYS THAT THE UNION CANNOT TRY
TO WIN BACK THOSE EMPLOYEES.
IN ANOTHER ELECTION.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES DO?
ATTACK THOSE WORKERS WHOSE
UNIONS HAVE ABANDONED THEM FOR
THREE OR MORE YEARS HAS DEFINED.
IN THE VERY LANGUAGE OF THE ALE
I BE THAT I CITED AND THE.
SPECIFIED FAILURES IN MANY
CASES.
.
OF UP OF SHOWING UP AND DOING
THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF THAT THEY
WERE ELECTED TO DO TWENTY ODD
YEARS AGO SO AT SOME POINT THE
REPRESENTATIVE CAPACITY.
IN AN ABANDONED.
IS LOST
WHEN THE BARGAINING UNIT HAS
CHOSEN NOT TO REPRESENT FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
SO IN THESE RARE CASES AND WE'RE
ADMITTING THESE ARE RARE BUT
THEY DO EXIST.
THE LAW SHOULD ALLOW THE
ELLERBEE TO DETERMINE THAT A
BAND THAT HAS OCCURRED.
AND DE CERTIFY THE BARGAINING
UNIT BUT THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN NO
THURMOND NO FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER NO JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER NO KALRA. KALRA GNOME
MCCARTY. MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
THAT BILL FILL SIR THANK YOU
PICK YOU OUT NEXT TO A AB THREE
ZERO NINE THREE.
WITH A ARE SUGGESTING IT BUT THE
TITLE HERE THE RIGHT TO AN EQUAL
ENGAGEMENT.
ARE THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE OUR OWN
REPRESENTATIVES.
IS A BEDROCK PRINCIPLE OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEMOCRACY.
THAT PRINCIPLE APPLIES TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING THOSE WHO
WORK IN THE FIELDS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN AN
EMPLOYER AND A UNION
FAIL TO REACH A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
THE A A RP CAN CREATE AND
ENFORCE A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
MANDATORY MEDIATION.
MANDATORY MEDIATION IS
DIFFERENT.
THEN A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO MUTUAL
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE PARTIES.
AND IT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
WORKERS THEMSELVES TO BE A PART.
OF THE DISCUSSION.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE FARMWORKERS
THE LEGAL TOOLS THEY NEED.
TO HAVE A SAY IN DETERMINING THE
TERMS OF THE THEIR OWN CONTACT
THE LABOR CONTRACT
IF THOSE TERMS THEN THAT
CONTRACT OUR PRODUCT OF THE
MANDATORY. MEDIATION AND
CONCILIATION ONCE THE LRP SETS
FORTH THE TERMS UNDER MANDATORY
MEDIATION THE TWO PARTIES MUST
ABIDE BY THEM THE UNION. AND THE
EMPLOYER.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE FARMWORKERS.
THE PROCESS ALLOWS FOR AN
UNELECTED BOARD.
TO CREATE AN ENFORCED PROVISIONS
OF A CONTRACT.
IF FARMWORKERS HAD NO SAY IN
CREATING.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS CHANGE
THIS AND GIVE FARMWORKERS THE
RIGHT? TO VOTE ON A CONTRACT
CREATED BY THE BOARD.
BEFORE THE CONTRACT BECOMES
BINDING.
WITH NO LONGER
FORCED ON FARMWORKERS WITHOUT
THEM HAVING A CHANCE
TO APPROVE THE AGREEMENT WITH
THE MAJORITY VOTE.
THE ABILITY TO RATIFY OR
APPROVAL LABOR CONTRACT IS
SHARED BY OVERWHELMING UNION
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
YET IN THIS PARTICULAR PROCESS
THEY ARE BEING DENIED TO
FARMWORKERS
AND AGAIN SILVIA LOPEZ AND
JESSIE ROBOTS ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY.
THANK YOU WE WILL FIRST WITNESS.
MY NAME IS SYLVIA LOPEZ I
SUPPORT THIS AB THIRTY NINETY
TERRY BECAUSE.
I WAS LIVIN THIS AND.
TWO THOUSAND TOFF.
THEY'LL LEARN BE IN THE COMPANY
THERE WERE.
NEGOTIATED WITHOUT AS THE
WORKER WITHOUT.
ASKING US IF WE WANT IF WE WANT
TO SEE THAT CONTRACT.
JUST TO MAKE THIS VERY CLEAR I'M
LEAD AGAINST THE UNION.
AB BUT I JUST DIDN'T LIKE THE
WAY THEY WERE DOING IT WE WENT
TO MODESTO CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO
GET IT IN AND THIS.
NEGOTIATION AND WITHIN THE WITH
THE LRP.
AND.
THEY DIDN'T LET US TO SEE WHAT
WHAT IS THE CONTRACT.
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMEBODY THAT.
.
THAT IS NOT RIGHT.
I'M. AT I THINK WE WE I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME BRIGHT WE
DON'T HAVE TO WEAR THAT I'VE
READ TEE SHIRT.
TO HAVE THAT RIGHT AND TO BE
RESPECTED AND TO KNOW WHAT DATE
WHAT IT WHAT WHAT IS INSIDE THE
PACKAGE THAT WE GONNA BE BUYING.
BECAUSE ACTUALLY WHERE. WE CAN
PAY OUR FROM OUR CHECK EVERY
WEEK TO.
IBIDE SHOWING THAT BREATH
TEACHER.
AND SAYS WHERE OKAY IN THIS
COMPANY WE DON'T NEED A RED TEE
SHIRT AND WE DON'T NEED TO PAY
OUR WORK GROUP PERCENT.
AND WE THINK THAT WE DESERVE TO
KNOW WHAT IS IN THE PACKAGE.
ACUTE THAT'S WITNESS THANK YOU
ADJUST YOUR HOUSE AGAIN WOULD
PICK JUSTICE AB THIRTY NINETY
THREE ENOUGH I SAID PREVIOUSLY
THE CONTRACT THEY ARE BE WANTED
A FORCE ON UPON THOUSANDS OF THE
INDUSTRY'S HIGHEST PAID.
EMPLOYEES AND WORKERS WHAT HAD
ACTUALLY LOWER THEIR TAKE HOME
PAY.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT WOULD
INCLUDE THREE PERCENT OTHER GOAT
GROSS WAGES INCLUDING VACATION
PAY.
DOES NOT INCLUDE POTENTIAL
FINES ASSESSMENTS WORK PERMITS
INITIATION FEES ARE
REINSTATEMENT FEES ETCETERA
ETCETERA.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT THE CONTRACT
WOULD HAVE PROHIBITED THE
WORKERS FROM A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT.
WHICH IS TO PROTECT AND
DEMONSTRATE.
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT IN THIS
COUNTRY IT WILL ACTUALLY
PROHIBIT THAT FROM DEMONSTRATING
THIS ELLERBEE RAIN CONTRACT.
ARM.
NOW.
IT'S WRONG TO FORCE A CONTRACT
ON WORKERS WITHOUT LETTING THEM
CHOOSE
YOU NO WE HAVE A GENTLEMAN THAT
MEANT UNITED AUTO WORKERS.
WELL THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SEE THE CONTRACT EVEN IF THE
COMMITTEE.
OF WORKERS THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SEE AND VOTE ON IT.
THEY WERE NOT ABANDON.
SO LET'S NOT USE THAT SAMPLE
THAT THE NOT A CAR REALLY TO
THIS A PARTICULAR TEMPLE.
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THE
PREVIOUS BILL I ACTUALLY GET IT.
BUT AB THIRTY NINETY THREE.
ALL WOULD GIVES WORKERS THE SAME
RIGHTS THAT IS EVERY OTHER
CLASSIFICATION INDUSTRIAL
WORKERS IN THE STATE AND THE
COUNTRY HAVE.
VOTE ON THE CONTRACT IF THEY
LIKE IT OR NOT.
WE SUPPORT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
RIGHT.
WHAT COLLECTED PARTY SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT?
AND I'LL CLOSE WITH THIS I WOULD
ASK MYSELF AND I WOULD THINK
ABOUT THIS.
IF THIS UNION AND LABOR
ORGANIZATION THE NOT ABANDON THE
EMPLOYEES FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND IN ANOTHER CASE FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS.
WHY HAS THERE BEEN A CONTRACT?
WHY HAVEN'T THEY COLLECTED THREE
PERCENT WAGES FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS?
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND I'M CERTAIN THAT
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL WHEN THEY HAVE DROPPED TO
HE WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS
FRANCE.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I WOULD WISH AN ADD ON AND
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MY NAME'S DEROGATORY AND AS A
FORMER FARM WORKER I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LOSE HAD A LOPEZ AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA WRINKLE.
I SUPPORTER VOTED NINETY THREE.
BRAZIL THE SLOW I'M
LOPEZ.
AND I SUPPORT A. B. THIRTEEN
ANYTHING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NO I'M AN INTERLOPER IN SUPPORT
THIRTY NINETY THREE.
IF YOU.
NOBODY SAID THE P. UP REALLY.
THANK YOU.
BUT I SAY YES.
MINE IS FERNANDO AND IVES FOR IB
THIRTY THREE. TAKE A CUE.
WHEN AS A WHOLE LOT OF IT I
DON'T KNOW SPORTS HAS BEEN.
THANK YOU.
ME NUMBER I SAW HIM LEAVE NASA
PROPERLY AVE TAINT THEM I MEAN
THEY THIRTIES LAST.
GOOD ACTORS.
ONE LAST THOUGHT OF THIS ME
NOBODY'S MONEY THAT HE THOUGHT I
MEAN THIS.
THE APPLE YOU WASTED THE.
PRESSURES.
YOU MEAN NUMBER S. GLOW THE
ABOUT IT EARLIER PUT YOU A STEP.
BLESS HIS.
ME NO MEDICINES THE LIMITING
APPLE US TIGHTLY.
INTEREST
YES YES.
WE KNOW THAT A LOT ON HIP WITH
THE LATE. REST.
MY NUMBER ADDRESS LIKE CASF BOIL
UP FOR YOUR A. B.. USES.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING THAT ON IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MARIO
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. THIRTY NINETY THREE. I DID
WANT TO ONCE AGAIN CORRECT A
FEW.
MISSTATEMENTS.
.
FARMWORKERS DO HAVE A SAY IN
WHAT IS NEGOTIATED AND THAT'S
THROUGH A DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
NEGOTIATING COMMITTEE THAT.
AT LEAST
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS AND I
KNOW OTHER UNIONS USE.
IT'S A COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF
WORKERS WHO INFORMED THEIR
REPRESENTATIVE WHAT KIND OF
ISSUES THEY WANT ADDRESS THAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
I THOUGHT SO THE IDEA THAT FARM
WORKERS HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS
BEING NEGOTIATED SIMPLY FALSE.
.
THE IDEA THAT FARMWORKERS AT
THIS PARTICULAR COMPANY
CORRALLING FARMS DID NOT KNOW
WHAT WAS KNOWS NEGOTIATED IT IS
ALSO FALSE
THE FARM WORKERS KNOW VERY WELL.
COPIES OF THE.
OPPOSED MEDIATED AGREEMENT HAVE
BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO THE WORKERS
SO THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S IN
THE CONTRACT WAS NEGOTIATED.
THE IDEA THAT THIS OP MEDIATED
AGREEMENT LOWERED PAY.
SIMPLY FALSE THE MEDIATED
AGREEMENT CALLED FOR WAGE
INCREASES
ABOVE AND BEYOND ANY THREE
PERCENT.
ONE OF AROUND FARMS COMPLAINTS
IS THAT IT WAS BEING ASKED TO
PAY TOO MUCH.
OVER AND ABOVE BEYOND THREE
PERCENT.
IN ORDER TO GIVE WORKERS
INCREASED WAGES.
AGAIN THOSE THINGS ARE ALSO
FALLS.
THERE IS NO.
LEGAL.
RIGHT TO RATIFY A CONTRACT
THAT'S A THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S.
DISCUSSED AMONG
THE UNIONS IT'S AN INTERNAL
PROCEDURE THAT'S SOMETIMES
AFFORDED TO MEMBERS SOMETIMES A
SUPPORTED TO COMMITTEES WHAT THE
LAW SAYS. IF THAT THE UNIONS
HAVE A RIGHT TO DETERMINE HOW TO
DO THAT WITHIN THEIR OWN
CONSTITUTION.
AGAIN WITH RESPECT TO THIS
SPECIFIC EMPLOYER. THE IDEA THAT
IT.
IT WAS PAYING THE HIGHEST WAGES
IN THE INDUSTRY IS LAUGHABLE
BECAUSE IT IS BEING SUED FOR
MINIMUM WAGE VIOLATIONS.
AND HAS NOT PAID THE HIGHEST
WAGES IN THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE OF
THESE MINIMUM WAGE VIOLATIONS.
SO ONCE AGAIN THERE IS NO NEED.
THERE'S NO RIGHT LEGAL RIGHT FOR
WHAT IS BEING ASKED FOR HERE.
IT'S ANOTHER WAY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO INTERFERE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THIS EMPLOYER
WAS ALREADY FOUND TO HAVE
INTERFERED WITH THE RIGHT OF
THESE EMPLOYEES.
SELECT OR NOT SELECT THE UNION A
SECOND VOTE WOULD ADD AN ADDED
HURDLE AT GETTING A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THAT THE
MIGHT OF BINDING MEDIATION LA
WAS DESIGNED.
TO PROTECT SO FOR THOSE EASONS
THE UNION. IS IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTY NINETY THREE THANK.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT BE A
WITH CALIFORNIA LIBERATION OUT
ALSO ADD THAT THE HILLARY WOULD
ONLY THINK THIS ACTION WITH THE
EMPLOYERS ENGAGED IN.
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE AT THE
WORK SITE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE AIRLINE BICU DOES WIN THE.
WHEN THE EMPLOYERS BILL'S
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH WHEN THEY
SON WHEN THEY'VE DONE.
SAYS BAD DAMAGE DURING
NEGOTIATING PROCESS THE SIXTEEN
YEAR OVER YEAR THAT IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THOSE WORKERS TO
GET A FAIR CLICK THE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT SO.
WITH THAT WE'RE POST.
THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WERE OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
ON BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS IN
OPPOSITION MAKE YOU THINK YOU.
MARK SCHACHT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE ALSO ONE OF MY AYE IN
OPPOSITION.
Q..
TO THE LEVEL OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SO REMEMBER MATHIS AYE I'M
ACTUALLY A QUESTIONS FOR THE THE
UFW GUY.
THE FEET COME BACK NOW.
ATTORNEY.
CLAUDIA MARTINEZ FOR YOUR MONEY
NEVER GO MARIO MARTINEZ.
MISTER MARK USING IN YOUR
COLUMN INTO YOU STATED THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE YOU DOING
THESE THINGS ARTI MEAN.
AND IN GRANTED I'M I'M SUBBING
TODAY ON LABOUR'S IS MY FIRST
TIME HERE SO FORGIVE ME. AMONG
ME I'M USUALLY ON OTHER
COMMITTEES.
.
BUT.
THE IN I'VE READ SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN MY LIFE AND AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE HOW.
HOW OFTEN?
DO THE THESE GROUPS.
TO IT WHAT WALK ME THROUGH ESOS
THEY COME THROUGH THEY CONTRACT
THEY TAKE A VOTE. NOW YOUR
UNIONS IN CHARGE OF THE
EMPLOYEES CORRECT.
THE THE UNION ACTS AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE UNION ACT
PURPOSES OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OKAY SO HOW OFTEN DO
THEY ME IS A MONTHLY THING IS
THAT OUR QUARTERLY IS IT.
BY ANNUALLY.
IT DEPENDS ON WHETHER THERE'S AN
EXISTING CONTRACT OR WHETHER
THEY'RE TRYING TO NEGOTIATE A
NEW CONTRACT IF THERE'S A
CONTRACT IN PLACE THAT AND
THERE'S LESS NEED FOR MEANS IF
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE. IN THIS
CASE OF THE CASE OF OF
CORRALLING FARMS I BELIEVE THE
UNION.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND TO TELL THAT'S THE
AREA THERE'S NOT SO THERE IS A
ENTERED CONTRACT WHEN YOU GUYS
USE HER I'M TRYING TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION. MATH.
BOOK MAD ABOUT ELEVEN TIMES AND
THEN THEY HAD ANOTHER FIVE OR SO
MEETINGS WITH THE MEDIATOR TO
TRY TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT I'M
I'M NOT I'M NOT ASK ABOUT THE
GROOM LIKE IT'S AYE ASKING I
MEAN.
YEAH YOU EARN ATTORNEY FOR THE
UNION AND WHAT'S THE STANDARD
THAT YOU GUYS PUT TOGETHER I
MEAN I I WHAT I'M I'M TRYING TO
PICTURE THIS IN MY HEAD SO I CAN
EXPLAIN THIS.
THE FOLKS BACK HOME BECAUSE.
WE MUST ORGANIZATIONS EITHER ME.
MONTHLY OR QUARTERLY AND THEN
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU DISSEMINATE
THE INFORMATION BACK DOWN TO THE
THE PEOPLE THAT IT'S
REPRESENTING.
ENOUGH SAID ON NATIONAL BOARDS
ARE SET ON STATE BOARDS.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO YOU.
HAVE YOU GUYS SEEN THIS
INFORMATION BACK DOWN TO THE
UNION MEETS AS MANY TIMES AS
NECESSARY MEANWHILE MEETS WITH
HER. WITH THE EMPLOYER THEY WILL
HAVE A WORKER NEGOTIATING
COMMITTEE.
THAT IS COMPOSED OF
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED WORKER
LEADERS.
AND THEN BASED ON THE MEETINGS
THEY HAVE WITH THE EMPLOYER THEY
WILL THEN HAVE MEETINGS WITH THE
REST OF THE WORK FORCE TO ADVISE
THEM HOW NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING
AND IS THEIR STANDARD ON HOW
OFTEN THOSE MEETINGS ARE TO
OCCUR.
IT DEPENDS ON.
HOW NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING WITH
THE EMPLOYER IF AN EMPLOYER
TELLS THE UNION WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO SIGN A CONTRACT WITH
YOU? DON'T BOTHER MEETING WITH
US THAT MAY HAVE AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT I AND THAT MANY OF AYE AYE
FAMILY OUT THERE THERE WAS A
MACHINE MATHIS IF WE WILL ANSWER
YOUR RIGHT THAT THE WITNESS
FINISH ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION.
THAT MAY AFFECT HOW MANY TIMES
THE UNION MEETS WITH THE
EMPLOYER.
IF THE EMPLOYER REFUSES TO ME
THAT WILL AFFECT HOW MANY TIMES
THE UNION MEETS WITH THE
IMPORTANT ON SO IT DEPENDS ON
I'M I'M NOT CONCERNED WITH HOW
OFTEN THE UNION MEETS WITH.
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENTS ON THE
GROUND.
DURING ACTIVE NEGOTIATE THEIR
IT'S STANDARD WITHIN YOUR UNION
ON THAT.
DURING ACTIVE NEGOTIATIONS VERY
FREQUENTLY.
IT WILL BE.
ON A WEEKLY OR BI WEEKLY BASIS
THERE'S NOTHING WRITTEN IN IN
THE CAR THE UNION'S CONSTITUTION
BUT WHEN THERE ARE ACTIVE
NEGOTIATIONS. AND THERE'S A
RESPONSIVE IMPORTER IT WILL BE
VERY FREQUENT SO SO THE UFW YOU
ALL.
DOESN'T HAVE WITHIN ITS
CONSTITUTION.
AN ANNUAL MEDIAN TIME FOR
TALKING TO MEMBERS OF THE UNION.
NO AND I DON'T KNOW THAT ANY
UNION HAS THAT IN ITS
CONSTITUTE.
OKAY I'D I JUST I'VE EVER AGAIN
I'VE WORKED WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IT ACROSS THE U.
S. AND THEY ALL HAVE.
MEDIAN REQUIREMENTS AND WHEN
THEY MEET HOW THEY MEET AND AND
ALL THOSE THINGS RAN OUT OF THE
CONSTITUTION SO. I'M I'M JUST
THE GET I'M CURIOUS ON HOW THIS
WORKS.
SO.
NOT THAT THAT'S IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT THE WITNESS
ESTABLISHED A FEW TIMES THAT
THERE ARE.
THE FREQUENCY OF MEETINGS
INCREASES WHEN THERE IS
NEGOTIATING GOING ON YEAH AGAIN
I MISS HIM AND I'M I'M NEW TO
THIS AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THIS WORKS TO
THIS AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE STAND UNDER SCARES THE
CONSTITUTIONS AND BYLAWS USUALLY
HAVE. STANDARD MEETING TIMES
WHAT IT OR NOT SHE UNUSUAL AND
WE WANT YOU TO COME BACK AND
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW
ORGANIZATIONS TYPICALLY WORK. IT
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS HAVE AT
THEIR HEART TO REPRESENT.
THOSE THAT THEY REPRESENT IN
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS AND
ADVOCATE FOR THEM IT WOULD NOT
BE UNUSUAL FOR THEM TO NOT HAVE
SOME.
CURRENTLY ARTICULATED SCHEDULE
FOR WHEN THEY MEET BECAUSE THEIR
MEETINGS ARE OFTEN DICTATED BY.
ANY MATTERS THAT THEY MIGHT BE
DEALING WITH AT THE TIME AS A
WAY OUR I ABSOLUTELY AM I JUST
FIND IT SURPRISING THAT THERE'S
NOT A STANDARD MEDIAN TIME RAN
INTO THEIR. BY LAWS OF THE
CONSTITUTION
DEEP IT'S NOTED THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
BILL HAS A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEN NONE SO PATTERSON MAKE LIKE
TO CLOSE.
OB I THOUGHT I THINK WE STRAYED
JUST A LITTLE BIT FROM THE FOCUS
AND I WANT TO BRING US BACK TO
MANDATORY. MEDIATION AND
CONCILIATION.
IT IS IN THAT CONTEXT THAT THIS
BILL.
TEMPS.
TO BE ABLE TO PUT THE
FARMWORKERS.
IN THE ROOM.
I WENT THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
WITH THESE FARMWORKERS BACK IN
THE TIMES WHEN WE WERE GOING
THROUGH. THE MANDATORY
MEDIATION.
AND I WAS SURPRISED THAT THEY
WERE NOT ALLOWED IN THE ROOM.
THAT THEY COULD NOT HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE ROOM THIS
WAS.
SOMETHING THAT THE LRB BOARD
DID.
THAT JUST AMONGST THEMSELVES.
AND THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE THE THE THIRD LARGEST
STEAK.
IN THE DECISIONS THAT WERE BEING
MADE INSIDE THAT ROOM.
AND STEM THEM I ALSO WAS A BIT
BIG SURPRISE TO ME THAT THAT.
WHEN THE HELL ARE BE DETERMINE
WHAT. THEY WERE GOING TO REQUIRE
IN THE CONTRACT AND.
AND MANDATORILY.
PRESENTED TO THE UP.
TO THE FARMWORKERS THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT.
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THOSE DETAILS.
NOW THEY DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT IT STUDY
IT.
AND THEN THEY DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON IT.
THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A A A
REAL A DEPARTURE FROM I THINK
GENERAL. UP PRACTICE AND
CERTAINLY I THINK IT DOES CALL
INTO.
SOME QUESTION.
AT BUT WHETHER OR NOT THESE
THESE FARMWORKERS REALLY ARE
ENGAGED AND AND IT IT AND HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SIT LISTEN HERE AND VOTE.
ON WHAT'S GOING TO A AFFECT
THEIR LIVES.
.
I MEAN IF AND FUND A FATHER UP.
UNIONS AND UNION MEMBERS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SEE THE CONTRACT.
BUT I DON'T THERE WOULD EVEN
ALLOWED THE COMMITTEE.
IN THE ROOM.
SO THERE THERE IT WAS A.
THE FACT THOUGH MANDATORY.
WITHOUT.
SEEING IT UNDERSTANDING IT OR
EVEN HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO VOTE ON IT.
WE REALLY I REALLY THINK THE
CONTRACTS.
SHOULD NEVER BE FORCED ON
WORKERS.
A CONTRACT REALLY IS IN THE
WORKERS BEST INTEREST.
LET THEM VOTE ON. LET THEM SEE
IT LET THEM BE IN THE ROOM.
LET THEM HAPPY AT LEAST A
COMMITTEE IN THE MANDATORY ME.
IT'S NORMAL FOR CONTRACTS TO BE
RATIFIED BY A VOTE.
ESPECIALLY SINCE IT'S THE
WORKERS WHO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LIVE WITH IT.
AND I I JUST THINK THAT IF IF
THIS IS AG.
.
AND IMPORTANT RIDER PRIVILEGE
THAT.
.
MOST UNION MEMBERS HAPPEN STATE
CALIFORNIA THESE FARMWORKERS
SHOULD HAVE THAT. RIGHT AND
PRIVILEGE AND AGAIN THIS IS WITH
RESPECT.
TO ONLY THAT AREA OF THE
MANDATORY.
.
ABOUT.
CONTRACT THAT IS THAT THAT THEY
ARE FORCED TO ACCEPT WHETHER
THEY LIKE IT OR NOT OR WHETHER
THEY CAN.
VOTE ON IT.
YES OR NO FOR THOSE REASONS I
THINK THIS BILL.
NARROWLY A SCOPES THIS
PARTICULAR I THINK BLEMISH IN
THE.
DUE PROCESS AND THE OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES AVAIL ARE BE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
FIX HERE AND WITH THAT I I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS BETTER SOON WE KNOW THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU'VE MADE ABOUT
FORCED DECISIONS AND THINGS OF
THE LIKE WE ALSO NOTE THAT WE
HEARD FROM REPRESENTATIVES TODAY
WHO HAVE SAID THAT THERE ARE
REPRESENTATIVE GROUPS.
THAT WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
WORKERS IN
AND THAT IS THE WAY IN WHICH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CONTRACTS
ARE COMMUNICATED BUT THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR CLOSE UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN NO
THURMAN NO FLORA. FLORA AYE
INSULTS FLETCHER.
CONSULT WHICH ARE KNOWN JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER NO KALRA.
KALRA GNOME MCCARTY. MATHIS
BY MATHIS AYE.
OF THE BILL FAILS.
UP MOVING ON TO A. B. THIRTY
NINETY FOUR. AND.
I AYE IN PRESENTING THE FINAL
BILL I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE. COURTESY IN THE OPPORTUNITY
OF PRESENTING AND FOR. LISTENING
HEARING.
THESE FARMWORKERS WITH THEIR
WITH THEIR POINT OF VIEW ON
SOMETHING THAT OBVIOUSLY IS SORT
OF OUT OF THE. MAINSTREAM OF OF
OF ACCEPTED UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
THE FIELD BUT THESE ARE REAL
PEOPLE LIVING THROUGH THESE.
SIGNIFICANT CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THEY HAVE ASKED.
FOR ME TO PRESENT THESE ON THEIR
BEHALF BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE GONE THROUGH THESE THINGS
AND AND ASK REALLY CREATED SOME
SOME REAL HEARTACHE.
THIS FINAL BILL NOW IS REALLY A
DUE PROCESS.
BELT.
.
SEEKS TO PROTECT.
BUT RIGHT TO FARMWORKERS THE LRP
IS CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED.
TO THROW OUT THE RESULTS OF AN
ELECTION.
AND CERTIFY A LABOR ORGANIZATION
AS THE EXCLUSIVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNIT.
IF EMPLOYER MISCONDUCT IS FOUND
THAT MAY HAVE INTERFERED WITH
THE VOTE.
HOWEVER THERE IS NO RECOURSE IF
MISCONDUCT BY AN ENTITY. OTHER
THAN AN EMPLOYER.
IS SIX BUT IS SUSPECTED NOR.
IS IT AN OPTION TO HAVE A NEW
ELECTION IF THIS WERE TO OCCUR
SO IN FACT THERE IS NOT.
EVEN A JUDICIAL REVIEW
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE APPELLATE
COURT SYSTEM.
WHEN THE NLRB DECIDES TO VOID
THE RESULTS
AN ELECTION.
AND I.
WE NEED TO REMIND.
THIS COMMITTEE THAT THAT THAT.
THOUSANDS OF THESE FARMWORKERS
HAVE ALREADY VOTED AND THOSE
BOATS ARE SEQUESTERED THEY'RE IN
A BOX SOMEPLACE IN THE THAT
THERE THAT JUSTICE DISAPPEAR IN
THE NOT. THEY'RE NOT BEING
COUNTED.
SO THAT RIGHT TO CHOOSE EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATION IS REALLY CREPT
UP THE CRITICAL TO FARMWORKERS
AS IT IS TO ALL WORKERS BECAUSE
OF THE IMPACT ON WAGES AND
WORKING CONDITIONS AND BENEFITS
OF THIS BILL.
PROVIDES PROTECTION TO ENSURE
THAT THE VOICES OF THESE WORKERS
ARE IN FACT HEARD. AND AGAIN
THIS IS WITH SPECIFIC REFERENCE
TO THE MANDATORY NATURE OF THE A
A RP ACTIVITY SO UNDER THE BILL
THE ELLERBEE MUST ORDER. A NEW
ELECTION TO BE HELD IN THE CASE
OF MISCONDUCT BY AN EMPLOYER.
BOARD PERSONNEL OR LABOR
ORGANIZATION THIS GIVES THE
POWER TO DECIDE BACK TO THE
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL WOULD ALSO.
SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY AN
APPELLATE COURT
A BOARD ACTION THAT CERTIFIES
THE RESULT IN THE ELECTION
WITHOUT COUNTING THE BALLOTS OF
WORKERS AND THAT IS THE PRECISE
SITUATION WE SEE.
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA HERE AGAIN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SILVIA
LOPEZ AND JESSIE ROW HOUSE.
HI MY NAME IS HAVE A LOPEZ AND I
SUPPORT THIS.
BILL A. B. THIRTY EIGHT NINETY
FOUR. BECAUSE.
HONESTLY I REPEAT THIS AGAIN
ONCE MORE TIME.
.
MORRELL NINETY PERCENT OF FARM
WORKERS AND FRESNO COUNTY
REPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
AND THE AGES HE THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES LOCAL THEY
KIDNAPPED IN OUR OUR VOTES AND
THEY HAVE A BE COUNTED SINCE
FIVE YEARS AGO. IN THIS YEAR'S
GONNA BE FIVE YEARS THAT WE
PULLED IT AND THEY THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO COUNT OUR VOTES.
AND I'M JUST GONNA MAKE THIS
COMMENT.
WHAT WHAT IS THAT WHAT WAIT
THEY TOO AFRAID TO COUNT OUR
VOTES IF WE? IT. IF EVERYTHING
FLY LIKE THIS SAID WHITE THEY
WAY THEY SO AFRAID TO COUNT OUR
VOTES WHY THEY DON'T COUNT THEM
FULL IT'S AND. AND LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE WHAT'S THE
FARMWORKERS WHAT THEY WANT.
BECAUSE.
I RESPECT YOU GUYS ONE OF EACH
OF YOU GUYS LIKE A HUMAN BEING
BECAUSE YOU GUYS A HUMAN BEING
AND I WANT TO RESPECT PEOPLE.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO INVITE
YOU GUYS.
TO GO AND TALK TO THIS.
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS SO YOU GUYS CAN SEE.
WHAT IS THE REAL THING WHAT'S
GOIN NON REALLY OVER THERE
BECAUSE?
MAYBE I CAN'T COMMENT I CAN SAY
LICE OR OTHER ORGANIZATION THEY
COULD COME IN AND SAY OTHER
STORY. BUT THE REAL STORY IS OUT
THERE.
IT'S JUST.
TO GRAB SOME BOOTS AND SOME
JEANS AND TALK TO US THEIR WE
ARE MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND OUT
THERE. HE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
YOU GUYS THERE SO.
YOU GUYS CAN MAKE A FAIR
DECISION IN THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE THIS
SERIOUS OF THIS VERY SERIOUS
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KIDS
OUR FAMILIES OUR. THEIR AT THEIR
COTTAGE THEIR BOOKS THAT HAD THE
SPENT SERVE.
EVERYTHING'S ALRIGHT THE.
I SUGGEST THAT IN I SUPPORT THIS
BILL STRONGLY AND THANK YOU GUYS
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU JUST ACROSS WOULD PICK
JUSTICE SO FINALLY AB THIRTY
NINETY FOUR. I YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS WAS MOST IMPORTANT FOR
FARMWORKERS SPECIALLY THEY NEED
TO BE ALLOWED TO CHOOSE THE
REPRESENTATION OBVIOUSLY.
BUT THOUSANDS OF WORKERS ACHIEVE
THE BORDER AS WE MENTION WE KEEP
GOING AFTER THIS SITE SAMPLE IN
FRESNO AREA. ARE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM TWICE A
COMPLETE OF PETITIONS OR
SIGNATURES FOR THAT A VOTE.
THEY ALERT BE ADMINISTERED THE
ELECTION THEY'LL ARE BE ALLOW
THE ELECTION BOB ANOTHER ONE OF
THE THREE THE WORKERS BALLOTS I
MEAN YOU HAD STILL GET TOWARDS
BEGIN THE PHONE FORMER GENERAL
COUNSEL OF THE OTHER BE.
LITERALLY SEEN COURT.
ABOUT SUPPORTING OR ARE
SUGGESTING TO THE COURT THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE BALLOT TO ME
THIS IS AMERICA.
WHO WANTS TO DESTROY VOTES
THAT IS COMPLETELY WRONG? YOU
KNOW IS A BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
FARMWORKERS.
NO.
JUST IMMIGRANTS JUST LATINO
IMMIGRANTS I SHOULDN'T BE THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE IN THE RIGHT TO SEE THE
RESULTS OF THE VOTE.
HE LIKE ANY GENERAL ELECTION YOU
KNOW IF THEY THEY'LL ARE BE HAVE
A PROM WITH AN ELECTION THEY RAN
AND THEY ADMINISTER AND THEY PUT
THE RULES TO.
THEN DON'T PUNISH THE WORKERS
JUST TO ANOTHER ELECTION.
IF SOMETHING SO GOOD A BELIEVER
IN THE STATION AS SUCH SO CALLED
CONTRACT SO GOOD WHAT IS THERE
TO FEAR.
WHY TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SUCH A?
FEAR HERE IF IT'S SO IF IT'S SO
GOOD DON'T VOTE THEY SAID
THEY'LL VOTE THREE THOUSAND ONE
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
SENATE.
AND AND YOU KNOW I WANT TO SEIZE
INSULTING TO SAY TO ME AT LEAST
AND FOR THEM.
THEY'RE NOT PAID TO COME HERE
THEY LEAVE THE KIDS BEHIND THIS
OTHER PERSON TO DONE THIS DOZENS
OF TIMES YOU GUYS KNOW THAT. AND
TO SAY THAT IT'S JUST DRIVEN BY
A PARTICULAR THOUSANDS OF WORK
AT THAT PARTICULAR.
LOCATION IT'S ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
ARM WE DON'T HAVE TIME HERE TO
GET IN A DEBATE AND I WANNA BE
RESPECTFUL OF EVERYONE'S TIME.
BUT I WOULD ENCOURAGE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ACTUALLY VISIT AT
A PARK OR WHEREVER YOU WANT.
WORKERS FROM AROUND THE STATE
SALINAS MONTEREY SANTA MARIA EL
CENTRO BAKERSFIELD DELANO.
FRESNO I MEAN YOU NAME THE
PLACE
YET YOU WANT TALK THEM DIRECTLY
IN ASKING QUESTIONS DIRECTLY AND
HAVE THEM SHOW YOU THEIR PAYSTUB
TO YOU SEE THE REAL WORKER. I
WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE.
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST A FEW OF
THEM.
AND THEY ALL HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE RIGHTS AND THE
ME TELL YOU GROW WORSE THIS IS
NOT GROWTH ORIENTED.
PRO EMPLOYEE PRO LATINO PRO
IMMIGRANT POOR PEARL WORKFORCE
THERE THE ONE SCRAMBLING AROUND
TO COME UP WITH GAS MONEY.
THE ONES LOSING THOUSANDS OF
JOBS.
NOT THE GROWERS A BROADER SET
FOR LIFE.
THEY HAVE OTHER INTERESTS THIS
IS PRO EMPLOYEE PERIOD.
SO I URGE YOU TO LEAD A REAL
COURT FEEL THIS ISSUES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
THIS BEFORE THE.
GENTLEMAN FROM BAKER FOR THE
ATTORNEY COMES UP TO SPEAK AND
AND DISTORT THE FACTS ARMED.
WHICH I DON'T FIND CREDIBLE IN
ATTORNEY THAT ALLOWED HIS OWN
CLIENT TO BE SUED IN A CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT FROM WITH TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BREAKING
LABOR LAW. BUT WITH THAT BEING
SAID. I ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE FACTS HE
FAILED TO MENTION THAT THE
ABANDONMENT OR I'M SORRY THE MC
PROCESS.
WAS ACTUALLY BEING LEAGUE
LITIGATED IN THE FIFTIES RECORD
OF APPEAL BECAUSE AN EMPLOYEE.
WHO SHOWED UP TO MODESTO
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO GO IN AND SEE
THAT THE CONTRACT?
SO THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON SUPPORT
TO THIS BILL.
MOVED BILL.
BILLS MOTION A SECOND OTHERS
WISH AN ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S DEROGATORY AND I
SUPPORT DISPEL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO ET A LOPEZ AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SINDARIN GOAL. I'LL
SUPPORT NOT DOOR INACTIVE FOR.
IF YOU.
NUMBER IN MY BODY
I MEETINGS.
DROPPED OR GO ON LEAVE IT I'VE
BEEN PUTTING THEM.
YES YES.
ROSA LOPEZ I SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN
BEFORE THANK YOU.
BUT NOT OTHERS ME NOTICES THE
LIMITING. YUP OIL LOWLY. ASSESS
YES I.
YOU KNOW MUST GO THERE BUT I
DON'T YOU KNOW FOR YOU.
NO LATE THANK THEM WHEN THEY
QUIT
DRESSES.
MY NUMBER AT ALL SECTORS SAY YES
ME WHAT MY THAT AYE CALIFORNIA
BOY YOLO. A A. B. THIRTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR DRESSES.
WE KNOW MELISSA BE BANGOR ASYLUM
LAST.
BROUGH HULA COMPARABLE THE ONLY
KNOWN FOR A PILL RELIABLE.
E. PLEASE HELP.
I NEED THE HELP.
PLEASE.
AQ.
HELLO MY NAME IS INTERRUPTUS AND
SUPPORT A BIT THIRTY NINETY
FOUR.
THANK YOU.
MAN NUMBER DECIDEDLY NOT BOIL
LA.
I MAY THINK THAT.
FROM AND THEY QUIT FASTEST
LYRICISTS.
WHEN IS FOR NOT DOING TO WANT
YOU GUYS TO. COME OUR BOATS
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING.
THANK YOU.
AT ARE LARA METERS GONNA BRING
GOVERNMENT BUT WHAT. DESK.
IN THE LITTLE LITTLE ZIPPER ONLY
THAT THE U. BOOKS ON.
YES.
AND AS A LOT OF THEM ARE NOT
SUPPORTERS BILL.
I REALLY HOPE YOU GUYS THERE'S
TWELVE VOICE AND.
UNDERSTAND US THAT TALK THINKING
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON.
SEE NOT AS OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY NINETY FOUR PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
PLEASE PROCEED.
BUT YOUR THINNESS ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B.. THIRTY
NINETY FOR THE LANGUAGE OF THE
PROPOSED BILL TALKS ABOUT THE
REMEDIES THAT COULD BE ORDERED
IN CASES WHERE. I AM PLAYER
INTERFERES WITH AN ELECTION
PROCESS OR A UNION INTERFERES
WITH THE ELECTION PROCESS. THE
BILL ISN'T NECESSARY BECAUSE
THOSE STANDARDS ARE WELL LAID
OUT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW CASE LAW IF
THE COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED IN
DETAIL OF HOW THIS WORKS THE
LABOR BOARD'S RECENT DECISION
AND FORTY TWO A OR B. NUMBER
ONE.
DETAILS THE EXTENSIVE ILLEGAL
ACTIONS OF
ROWAN FAR MEAN.
HOW THEY IMPROPERLY INTERFERED
WITH THE ELECTION?
IN HOW THEY AND VALIDATED THE
ELECTION. THAT PARTICULAR
DECISION AS ACTUALLY BEING
REVIEWED BY A COURT OF APPEALS
AS IS PROPER SO THE IDEA THAT
THERE'S NO REVIEW OF THE BOARD'S
DECISION IS IS INCORRECT.
THERE ARE PROCEDURES FOR WHEN
EMPLOYERS INTERFERE WITH
ELECTIONS THERE ARE REMEDIES FOR
THAT UNDER WELL ESTABLISHED
LABOR LAW.
THERE REALLY IS NO NEED FOR THE
BELL IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER BUT UFW
OPPOSES AB THIRTY NINETY FOUR
THANK YOU.
OTHER.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION RUSSELL POST.
THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER IN GRADES
ADVOCATES VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
RIGHTS OF FARMWORKERS BUT DON'T
BELIEVE THIS BILL ACCOMPLISHES
THAT APPOINTMENTS WHICH WAS IS
THAT I JUST GOTTA HOLIDAYS BUT
OPENS ON WHEELS CASE TO BREAK
THE DAILY ACCO BLESSED. US MORE
IN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MARK SHUT CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION MAKE YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING AT ON IN
OPPOSITION CA NINE OUTSIDE TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SIMILAR GONZALEZ FLETCHER THIS
IS BEEN HEARTBREAKING TO SET
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE.
I THINK THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
LOOKED AT THE ENTIRE PROCESS OF
WORKER IRWIN HAS DONE.
THEY LITERALLY FIRED WORKERS IN
ORDER TO AVOID OR TRY TO AVOID A
UNION ELECTION IN NOW THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN.
YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
THE FACT IS IF WE DON'T ACCOUNT
FOR THAT IF WE DON'T ALLOW OUR
BOARD TO ACCOUNT FOR. THE IN
EVERY BAD ACT.
THAT THE EMPLOYER HAS DONE. IN
EVERY INSISTENCE THAT THEY
REFUSED TO ALLOW A UNION THEY
THEY WERE. POOR ACTORS AND IN
THE PROCESS PEOPLE LOST THEIR
JOBS.
THEY'RE POOR ACTORS IN EVER
WANTED TO NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT
THEY CREATED ALL THE SITUATIONS.
THAT WERE NOW HERE TALKING
ABOUT.
AND THAT'S HEARTBREAKING BECAUSE
I UNDERSTAND SELF DETERMINATION
OF WORKERS IN WANTING NOT.
IN WORKERS DESERVE THAT.
BUT WE CANNOT ALSO IT AND AND
ONE DAY HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE
RESOLVED.
BUT WE CAN'T ALLOW BAD ACTORS IT
IS ABOUT THE GROWERS WE CAN'T
ALLOW BAD ACTORS.
TO VIOLATE THE LAW OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
KEEP WORKERS.
FROM BEING ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
RIGHTS AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
CLEARLY WHAT HAPPENED.
AND I IT'S IT'S HARD BECAUSE OF
COURSE YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO SEE
IT HERE IN AND LISTEN TO AN
AUTHOR PROMOTE FARMWORKERS WHEN.
THAT AUTHORS NEVER VOTED FOR
ANYTHING THAT WOULD EXTEND THE
BENEFITS AND WAGES A
FARMWORKERS.
THIS IS THIS IS A PROXY FIGHT IN
ONE THE DOESN'T EVEN MAKE SENSE
IN IT IT HURTS ME BECAUSE I WANT
TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO HELP
ALL OF THESE WORKERS.
EVEN MY TO IN ITS GREAT WE CAN
SAY THIS IS WORKER DRIVEN IN
SURE BUT THE ADS THAT ARE COMING
UP ON MY FACEBOOK. ARE ARE ARE
NOT BEING PAID FOR BY WORKERS
THE SHIRT YOU'RE WEARING IT
THAT'S NOT BEING PAID FOR BY
WORKERS THIS ENTIRE GROUP ARE
YOU TELLING ME THIS ENTIRE
GROUP.
AND THE LAWSUITS AND EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN PLAYED IS BY THE
WORKERS NOW IT'S PLAY THE
EMPLOYER.
IN OUR LABOR LAWS ARE FULLY OUT
OF BALANCE INNATE ALWAYS ALWAYS
IN EVERY INSTANCE.
BENEFIT THE EMPLOYER OVER THE
EMPLOYEE.
AND RIGHT TO UNIONIZE.
SO I UNDERSTAND I MEAN.
I UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION. AN
END AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO
REPRESENTING WORKERS AYE AYE
AND.
EMPATHIZE THE FRUSTRATION BUT
THIS WAS ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE
EVERY SITUATION WHERE IN NOW WAS
CAUSED BY THE EMPLOYER IN THE
ONLY WAY WE HAVE RULES THAT WILL
EVER BENEFIT WORKERS IS WITH WE
HOLD THOSE EMPLOYERS
ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THEIR BAD ACTS SO I'M SORRY
I CAN'T SUPPORT IT I'D MEET WITH
THE WORKERS ANYTIME YOU ASK I
WILL COME DOWN AND TALK TO THE
WORKERS AB AS I'VE CONTINUED
TILL. I'M THROUGHOUT ANY PROCESS
ANYTIME A WORKER HAS ASKED ME TO
TO MEET WITH THEM I COME SEE
THEM.
BUT BUT I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND I'M GONNA BE WAITING
FOR YOU YES BUT I HOPE YOU
UNDERSTAND KNOW YOUR EMPLOYER.
CAUSED THIS
WHICH WHICH AND PEOPLE LOST
THEIR JOBS BECAUSE THEY
SUPPORTED THE UNION I'M NOT
SORRY THIS ALL STARTED IN THAT
HAS BEEN OUR LATEST A MOMENT
PLEASE POST THEM ON THE PLEASE
PLEASE ALLOW THE MEMBER TO
FINISH. SO I JUST I JUST WANT TO
STATE THAT BECAUSE IT IS IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR SOMEBODY WHO
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF FARM
WORKERS IN AND HAS A CLEAR
RECORD OF THAT NOT JUST COMING
FORWARD WHEN IT AT EMPLOYER. OR
GROW WHERE SUPPORTS A BILL.
IT'S IT'S HEARTBREAKING BECAUSE
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN LET DOWN ON.
IF
WE ARE GOING TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
AND NOT HAVE A DEBATE HERE. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
WISHES THE ASKS A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR OR TO WITNESS NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME TO DO SO.
I'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO HAVE
YOUR LAST WORDS. BUT LETS OUT WE
DO HAVE A LONG NIGHT I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T I DON'T SPEND
ENOUGH I CAN MAKE A QUESTION.
JUST BIGGEST CAN I MAKE A QUICK
AT SO THAT MEANS THAT WE COULD
NOT BE FORCED.
TO BE IN A CONTRACT WITH THE
UNION.
IF IT YOU SAY THAT IS THE
EMPLOYER FAULT.
IF THE THAT'S GONNA.
KEEP BOTH TO CHOI OR OF TO MAKE
A CONTRACT.
WITH THE UNION YET I DON'T KNOW
WHY I DON'T. THAT ME ASK YOU
THIS QUESTION EARLIER TODAY THE
ATTORNEY FOR THE UFW SAID.
THAT IF THE MEMBERS DON'T WANT
TO BE REPRESENTED BY THE UNION
THAT THERE ARE STEPS THEY CAN
TAKE TO HAVE THAT CHANGED.
HAVE YOU ARE TAKING ANY OF THOSE
STEPS.
YES PLEASE ELABORATE WAS THAT'S
WHAT STEPS HAVE YOU ALL TAKEN.
IF WE DON'T WANT TO JOIN THE
UNION.
THAT'S WHY I WENT TO THE NLRB TO
ASK FOR ANOTHER ACTION.
BUT IF THE.
IF YOU'VE GOT IT'S NOT THAT YOU
DON'T WANNA JOIN UNION IF YOU
DON'T WANNA HAVE A UNION THAT
THEY'RE CERTAIN. I DON'T NEED IT
UNION UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN PROCESS SEES THAT HAVE
TO BE FOLLOWED. IF THE UNION
EXIST.
THERE ARE MANY CASES WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE INDIVIDUALS WHO JUST
SAY THAT'S NOT FOR ME AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO. BUT IN ORDER FOR
THE UNION TO NO LONGER EXIST
THERE ARE STEPS THAT HAVE TO BE
PROCESS HAVE TO BE FOLLOWED.
TO REMOVE THE UNION FROM
REPRESENTING THE WORKERS AND I'M
ASKING IF YOU OUGHT TAKEN THOSE
STEPS.
TO REMOVE THE UNION FROM THE US
HAITIAN NOT JUST GOING TO THE A
A RP TO SAY YOU DON'T WANT BUT
WHAT STEPS HAVE YOU TAKEN
ANOTHER ACTION WE HADN'T
ELECTION TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN.
TO DECERTIFY THAT UNIT THAT WE
NEVER ASKED FOR.
THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW THE. IN A
WAY I THINK THAT THE COMPANY HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY TO NOTIFY US TO
THAT THERE WAS A UNION THAT WAS
CERTIFIED IN NINETEEN NINETY.
MOST LRB RULE AGAINST YOU IN
THAT MATTER.
YEAH THE SAID THAT I WOULD
COLLECT THE SIGNATURES.
THEY SAID THAT THAT SIGNATURE
WHAT'S OF FRAUD THAT WE MAKE UP
THAT SIGNATURES AND THAT MAKES
OF PHIL'S SOLO SO BACK
UNDERSTOOD. YEAH SO YOU HAD TO
VOTE AND THEY THEY A ARE BE
RULED AGAINST YOU IN THAT MATTER
WAS ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU
WANTED TO ACT. OUGHT NOT JUST IN
THIS AND I WANT TO CLARIFY THE
PROCESS SO THEY COLLECTED
SIGNATURES TWICE.
AND AND ELECTION ACTUALLY WAS
APPROVED BY THE ELLERBEE AND RAN
BY THE OTHER BEGIN ADMINISTERED
BY THE LRV WOULD KNOW ISSUES
THEY JUST LOCKED UP THOSE
BALLOTS AFTER THAT THE OF THE
ELECTION.
I HAVE NOT COUNTED THIS IS THAT.
BUT THE WHOLE PROCESS WAS
FOLLOWED BY HER IN A REST OF OUR
EMPLOYEES THE THE PGA PREPARE
PROCESS. NOT ONE THING I JUST IF
I CATCH THE QUICK POINT EARLIER
MISTER MARTINEZ MENTIONED THE A
A RP BOARD. ARE THE LRB BORE
WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
QUALIFY BOARD IS SUPPOSED TO BE
A KNOWLEDGEABLE BOARD.
WELL LET'S LOOK AT ONE OF THE
CURRENT AYLER BEFORE MEMBERS OF
THE HALL I'M GONNA STOP YOU
RIGHT THERE I'M TO STOP YOU
RIGHT THERE A PROBLEM THINK I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO NOT IMPUGN
THE MEMBERS OF A BOARD.
THEIR QUALIFICATIONS ARE NOT AT
QUESTION HERE IN FOR THIS MATTER
THERE'S A SPECIFIC BILL IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE ANOTHER POINT YET
IN ADVOCACY FOR THIS BILL. I
WILL ALLOW THAT SIR MID MAY I.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL NOT ALLOW
YOU TO IMPUGN THE PROP ONE IF
PRESS ROOM OR OUTSIDE HIS
RETIREMENT NO PRO MAY MAKE YOUR
POINTS. ACROSS ABOUT THE BILL
YES SIR THANK CHAIRMAN YASSER.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS FORCED THESE
MEMBERS TO SIT THROUGH. AN
EMPLOYMENT OF THEMSELVES
OVER THIS BILL.
THERE HAS BEEN ISSUES RAISED
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
SADNESS OVER THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE BEING FOOLED.
I AND YOUR OUTRAGED BY THIS
AND YOU'RE NOT OUTRAGED BY US
BEING LECTURED.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
BILL.
SIR I JUST ASK BIRTH A STIFF
FAIRLY ADJUDICATE WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND I WILL HELP. WITH
OUR WITNESSES TO DO THAT.
I APPRECIATE WITNESSES WHO'VE
BEEN HERE TODAY.
WE HAVE LISTENED TO EVERYTHING
THAT EVERY WITNESS HAS HAD TO
OFFER.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN AGREEMENT ON
MANY ISSUES INCLUDING ISSUES
AROUND THE BAND ADMIT. IN ISSUES
AROUND AND ARE BE.
I DO NOT THINK IT IS ACCURATE.
FOR YOU TO SAY.
THAT ANY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAS IMPUGN ANY MEMBER
WHO'S COME HERE TO TESTIFY.
EVERYONE WHO'S ASKED FOR IT HAS
BEEN GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD. UP I
THINK I MAY NOT HAVE AGREEMENT I
APPRECIATE THAT LIMIT AND I AM
NOT CLOSE IT IF I MAY FINISH.
AND AT TIMES
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN.
EMOTIONAL.
AND SPIRITED COMMENTS RACE.
BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE IT'S
ACCURATE TO SAY THAT ANYONE IN
THIS CHAMBER HAS IMPUGNED ANYONE
WHO'S ASKED FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD.
THEY WENT THROUGH THE NEFELUS
AGREE I UNDERSTAND WELCOME YOUR
CLOTHES I UNDERSTAND THAT THANK
YOU UP.
THIS HEARING.
IS A MATTER OF PUBLIC RECORD.
AND THE COMMENTS OF MEMBERS WHO
HAVE.
IMPUGNED ARE A MATTER OF THAT
RECORD AND.
IT'S THEIR.
I'M GONNA CLOSE WITH THIS.
THE OPPOSITION.
IT'S SAD THAT THIS IS
UNNECESSARY.
BECAUSE THERE'S.
LAW THERE'S PENALTIES FOR
MISCONDUCT BY ALL PARTIES.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
SECTION ELEVEN FIFTY SIX POINT
THREE HALF OF THE LABOR CODE
IDENTIFIES ONLY.
EMPLOYER MISCONDUCT
AS A CAUSE FOR IGNORING THE VOTE
OF THE WORKERS.
CERTIFYING THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION THERE IS NO.
OTHER COUNTERPARTS IN BATON LAW.
OTHER THAN THE EMPLOYER.
IT SEEMS TO ME INTHIS COUNTRY
IN THE STATE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
SOME VERY FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES.
OUT OF OF RIGHTS THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE
WITH THAT WE CHERISH THE CONCEPT
OF LEGITIMATE REAL
REPRESENTATION. THAT PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWED FREELY AND OPENLY TO
CHOOSE.
AND THAT WE ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEEK REDRESS THROUGH
A JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
WHEN WE HAVE BEEN WRONG.
WE WILL WE HONESTLY REFUSED TO
EXTEND THOSE RIGHTS TO
FARMWORKERS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE.
AND THAT IS WHY THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ASKED
FOR THIS KIND. OF SOLUTION
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN THE ONES
THAT HAVE BEEN HARMED AND THE
DOOR HAS BEEN CLOSED.
TO THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO.
REDRESSING A GRIEVANCE AND TO
HAVE.
LEGITIMATE REPRESENTATION OF
THEIR OWN CHOICE
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CLOSER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMAN NO
THURMAN NOW FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER NO KALRA.
KALRA NO MCCARTY MATHIS.
MATHIS BY THE BILL.
THAT BILL FAILS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY OF BEING HURT THANK
YOU APPRECIATE.
NEXT UP WE'LL BE HEARING FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
WHO'S PRESENTING AB TWENTY SIX
TEN.
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR
CURRY.
CLEAR THE AIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS AFTERNOON
AIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SIX TEN WILL GIVE
TRUCK DRIVERS WHO TRANSPORT
LIVESTOCK NUTRIENTS AND BUY
PRODUCTS TO RURAL AND REMOTE
AREAS THE OPTION TO START THEIR
MEAL AND REST PERIOD. ON THEIR
SIX HOUR OF WORK.
CURRENTLY DRIVERS ARE REQUIRED
TO STOP FOR A MEAL AFTER FIVE
HOURS.
SOMETIMES TRAVELING ON SMALL
ROADS THROUGH RURAL COMMUNITIES
CREATES A DIFFICULT SITUATION
FOR DRIVERS LOOKING FOR A SAFE
PLACE TO PULL OVER ONCE THEY
HAVE HIT THE FIFTH HOUR.
EVEN IF THE DRIVER CAN PULL OVER
HERE SHE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
SAFELY LEAVE THE TRUCK
UNATTENDED TO TAKE A REST.
BY GRANTING THIS NARROW ONE OUR
FLEXIBILITY AB TWENTY SIX TEN
WILL ALLOW DRIVERS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
TO COMPLETE THE ROUTE AND THEN
ENJOY THEIR WELL DESERVED BREAK
IN A SAFE AND SECURE LOCATION.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS GREG GARLAND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION AND ANOTHER
EHRENREICH BURGLAR CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES.
THANK YOU
PROVIDE SPEAK. LIKE THAT JUST.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE
YOU ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX TEN THAT'S BEEN
INTRODUCED BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND YOUR CURRY. MY NAME IS GRANT
GARLAND I AM THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF BOREAL INCORPORATED AND A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA GRAIN
AND FEED ASSOCIATION'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
MORRELL IS A FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS LOCATED IN WILLIAMS
CALIFORNIA.
THE COMPANY'S FOCUS TO PROVIDE
VALUE ADDED FEED PRODUCTS TO
COMMERCIAL LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY
INCLUDING DAIRY BEEF HORSE SHEEP
GOATS POULTRY SWINE. AS WELL AS
MANY OTHER SPECIES.
IN ADDITION TO PRODUCING AND
DISTRIBUTING BALL COMMERCIAL
LIVESTOCK FEEDS BARI ALSO
MANUFACTURES A FULL LINE OF SAC
PRODUCTS. THEY'RE FOR SALE
THROUGH RETAIL FOOD STORES.
THE COMPANY DISTRIBUTES ITS
PRODUCTS TO THESE RETAIL FOOD
STORES AND COMMERCIAL LIVESTOCK
OPERATIONS AND FIVE OF THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES.
IT OWNS AND OPERATES A FLEET OF
CLASS EIGHT TRUCK TRACTOR'S
PULLING FLATBED TRAILERS BULK
STRINGER TRAILERS AND HOPPER
TRADERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX TEN
ADDRESSES A SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT
IS RELEVANT TO BAR ALE AND THE
FEED INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS AMENDMENT TO THE LABOR CODE
IS NEEDED BECAUSE THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IS VERY RESTRICTIVE AND
PROBLEMATIC TO BOTH THE EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYEES AND THE EMPLOYER AS
WELL.
SOMETIMES OUR CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
DEVELOPED IN THE PROCESS OF
DELIVERING THE FEED TO OUR
CUSTOMERS IN RURAL AREAS. THAT
THEY AFFECT THE TIMING OF THE
MEAL PERIODS.
THE GEOGRAPHIC THAT AREA THAT WE
CAN EFFECTIVELY ACCOMMODATE WITH
OUR OWN FLEET OF TRUCKS.
IS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN OREGON IN NORTHWESTERN
NEVADA.
IN THIS REGION WE OFTEN FIND
OURSELVES USING REMOTE RURAL
ROADS TO REACH OUR CUSTOMERS
THERE OFTEN NARROW TWO LANE
ROADS TO TWIST ON WINE THROUGH
THE MOUNTAINS. AND THROUGH RURAL
AREAS THERE'S OFTEN NO SAFE
PLACE FOR THE DRIVER TO PULL
OVER. AND ENJOY A DUTY FREE MEAL
PERIOD.
OFFICIAL REST AREAS ARE FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN AS ARE THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES APPLY ALONG THE WAY.
THE REST AREAS A DO EXIST ARE
NOT SUITABLE ON BAD WEATHER. FOR
A MEAL PERIOD IS THERE ARE NO
INDOOR FACILITIES THERE.
AND YOU SEE A LOT OF TIMES AT
ARREST OR YOU'LL SEE TRUCKS
THEIR AND AND I'M SURE THEY'RE
THEY'RE TAKING THEIR MEAL
PERIODS AND BREAKS AND SO FORTH
BUT THOSE ARE. TYPICALLY GONNA
BE INTERSTATE TRUCKERS AND HAVE
SLIPPERS ON THEIR. TRUCKS WHICH
IT'S LEGAL FOR THEM TO TAKE
THEIR MEAL PERIOD IN THERE. AND
THERE A SLEEPER.
MOST OF OUR TRUCKS CHECKED ALL
OF OUR TRUCKS ARE ALL DAY CABS
THEY DO NOT HAVE SLEEPER SO IT'S
NOT.
ACCORDING TO THE RULES WE
CANNOT TAKE THE MEAL PERIOD
INSIDE THAT TRUCK IF WE COULD
ASK YOU JUST GRAB YOUR THOUGHTS
PLEASE.
I'M SORRY IF WE COULD ASK YOU TO
WRAP UP YOUR THOUGHTS PLEASE WE
APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY.
.
THE WELL OF THE THE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE A BREAK AND
PRACTICAL MATTER WE ARE ALSO
SUBJECT TO THE FOOD.
MODERNIZATION ACT
WHICH MEANS WE CAN'T LEAVE THESE
TRUCKS ON ATTENDED WHERE WHERE
THEY CAN BE SUBJECT TO REST FOR
ADULTERATION OR ANY OTHER KIND
OF CONTAMINATION SO. FROM A
PRACTICAL PERSPECTIVE THE WAY
THE RULES WRITTEN RIGHT NOW IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO COMPLY
WITH ITS OUR DESIRE. IS TO GET
THE EXTRA.
OUR OF FLEXIBILITY THAT THIS
BILL.
AFFORDS US THAT'S WHAT WERE
WHAT WERE LOOKING FOR NEXT.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD APPRECIATE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AND THANK
YOU FOR HEARING ME AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR CUTTING OUT WE
JUST HAVE A TWO MINUTES PER WITH
THE SIZE COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
HI AARON ROBERT WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE GRAIN
AND FEED ASSOCIATION JUST HERE
TO OFFER MY SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEY ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CA NINETY ONE OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING A BILL
FORWARD.
.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND RETIREMENT
I SERVED ARMY TRANSPORTATION
LOGISTICS FOR TWELVE YEARS TWO
TOURS IN IRAQ AND WE DID NOT
HAVE.
THE AG COMPLETE INTERSTELLAR
TYPE OF THE DAY CAP THERE IS
LITTLE TO NO ROOM IN THERE AT
ALL.
THIS BILL IS VERY VERY OF ALL
NEEDED SO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
ON AND BRING IT FORWARD.
I THINK ANY WHAT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE
HAVE TRUCK DRIVERS ARE SAFE ON
THE ROAD AND THEY'VE THEY CAN I
GET THE PRODUCT FROM POINT A TO
POINT B.. THANK YOU FOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN FLORA AYE
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
MCCARTY. THAT THIS.
MATHIS I.
GRADUATES THAT BILLS OUT BREAK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
SO WILL QUIRK SILVA. PRISON IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT DEBT
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY WHICH
ESTABLISHES SOFT SKILLS IN
STATUE.
A I WILL AGREE THAT AND.
LIGHT OF THE RECENT
CONVERSATION HERE AT THIS DYESS
IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF A SOFTBALL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN THE
SENSE THAT IT REALLY A REMOVE
LET BILL AT EIGHTEEN.
AND AGAIN JUST FOR THOSE OF.
THAT DATA FOLLOW THIS WE THIS
THIS REALLY CAME OUT OF THE MANY
MANY.
IS THAT WE HAVE HAD
HAVE HELD AS A CHAIR OF THE JOBS
COMMITTEE WHERE EMPLOYERS AND
OTHERS HAVE REPEATEDLY LET US
KNOW THAT WE ARE DOING QUITE A
BIT TO MAKE SURE. THAT OUR
WORKFORCE IS GETTING TRAINED IN
TECHNOLOGY MAKING SURE THAT.
THEY'RE BECOMING VERY
PROFESSIONAL GETTING
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING BUT IT'S
THOSE SOFT SKILLS WHETHER IT BE
A.
BEING ABLE TO WORK ON A TEAM
BEING ABLE TO LISTEN BEING ABLE
TO BE RESPONSIBLE THIS TYPE OF
OF.
AND I THINK.
TRAINING THAT WOULD BE EXPLICIT
I THINK IS NOW NECESSARY AS WE
SEE MANY OF OUR YOUNG WORKFORCE
WHO ARE MILLENNIALS AND UP MANY
TIMES AREN'T ENGAGING WITH ONE
ANOTHER THEIR UP VERY. LOOKING
AT THEIR PHONES AND SO FORTH SO
WE THINK THIS WILL ADD TO THAT
LAYER OF OF TRAINING TO GOOD
WORKFORCE AND WE'RE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU LET DIFFERENT
WITNESSES.
BUT WE DO NOT.
.
GOT IT OTHERS WHO WISH TO ADD ON
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE WISHING AT ON IN SUPPORT.
S. COMPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE DAY BUT WE REPRESENT
UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK
A SMALL NETWORK OF THE LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN THE
SECOND IN A MARKETPLACE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IS THERE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
YES I WOULD JUST LIKE TELL LET
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS SO
EXCITING THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
COST THE STATE ANY MONEY AND
IT'S TO
STONE WORDS SOFT SKILLS. ARE I'D
IX ASK FOR YOURSUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE DO BEST. A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
CONSOLES FLETCHER.
INSULTS FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
MCCARTY MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
THE BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE RECOGNIZE A SIMILAR FONG IS
PRESENT TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIXTEEN WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FILE.
THANK YOU.
BILL'S BEEN MOTION AND SECONDED
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY SIR.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
A BILL THAT WILL BRING MUCH
NEEDED REFORMS IN TRANSPARENCY
TO THE PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL
ACT ALSO KNOWN AS PAGA. LOW
RETAIN POCKETS PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION MADE UP OF BUSINESSES
AND INDUSTRIES WHOM EVERY SECTOR
OF OUR ECONOMY INCLUDING NON
PROFITS AND SCHOOLS.
AS I TRAVEL THROUGHOUT THE STATE
I HEAR STORY AFTER STORY BUT HOW
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN HIT
BY BICU SUE AND FRIVOLOUS PAGA
LAWSUITS.
THAT ARE INTENDED TO EXTORT
MONEY FROM THEM AND THREATENING
THEIR ABILITY TO STAY IN
BUSINESS.
SOME TRIAL ATTORNEYS ARE GOING
ACROSS THE STATE WITH TEMPLATE
THREAT LETTERS DEMANDING MONEY
TO MAKE A LIVING TO MAKE IT THE
LITIGATION GO WAY.
THESE TEMPLATE LETTERS DO NOT
INCLUDE ANY DESCRIPTION OF THE
ALLEGED VIOLATION OR HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES ARE BEING IMPACTED.
ACCORDING TO THE NONPARTISAN
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
OVER SIX THOUSAND PROGNOSIS ARE
FILED EVERY YEAR.
EVEN MORE EGREGIOUS THEIR
CENTRAL ATTORNEYS THAT HAVE
TARGETED IMMIGRANT OWNED
BUSINESSES BECAUSE THEY ARE
LEAST ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THESE
ABUSIVE LAWSUIT THREATS HAD
THEREFORE MORE LIKELY TO PAY THE
DEMAND IN ORDER TO BE LEFT
ALONE.
A PROVIDE EXAMPLE TO SHOW WHAT
THESE ABUSIVE POPULAR LAWSUITS
LOOK LIKE.
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN MY
DISTRICT WAS HIT WITH A FOURTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
LAWSUIT SIMPLY FOR PROVIDING HIS
EMPLOYEES WITH THE BONUS FOR
WORKING SAFELY.
THE OWNERS OFFENSE WAS NOT
INCLUDING THE HOURLY BONUS IN
THE REGULAR PAY RATE FOR
CALCULATING EMPLOYEES OVERTIME
RATE.
A MINOR LABOR CLIP CODE
REQUIREMENT THAT COULD HAVE
EASILY BEEN FIXED
WITHOUT A MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
LAWSUIT.
THE OUTCOME OF THESE*
LAWSUITS TOO OFTEN BY THE
ATTORNEYS POCKETING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BY THE ALLEGE AGGRIEVED
EMPLOYEES RECEIVED PENNIES ON
THE DOLLAR.
OUR BUNGALOW WASINTENDED TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION FOR EMPLOYEES
NOT TO BE USED AS A LEGAL WEAPON
BY TRIAL ATTORNEYS TO EXTORT A
QUICK BUCK.
I THE STATUS QUO ARE PAGA LAWS
HURT BOTH EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE OF THE ABUSIVE WAY OUR
LAWS ARE BEING USE.
EVEN NON PROFITS THAT SERVE THE
NEEDS OF LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
HOMECARE PROVIDERS AND THOSE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT HAVE BEEN
HIT.
BUT PAGA LAWSUITS THAT ARE
THREATENING THEIR ABILITY TO
HELP PEOPLE AND OUR VERY OWN
COMMUNITIES.
NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE SOME
COMMON SENSE REFORMS THE PAGA.
IS RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
INSTITUTIONAL BODY TO ENSURE
THAT OUR LAWS
ARE NOT ABUSED ENGINE SURE THERE
IS JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS.
FOR THOSE WERE VICTIMIZED
THIS BILL WILL REMOVE THE CLOUD
OF COSTLY LITIGATION HANGING
OVER THE HEADS OF SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND EMPLOYEES.
NOW WITH ME DID TODAY TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT IS KEN BARNES OF
CITIZENS AGAINST LAWSUIT ABUSE.
INVINCIBLE.
BUT SONNY SEE OWNER OF SANTA FE
IMPORTERS WHO WAS HIT WITH A
POPULOUS IS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS VINCENT
PASSING YOU SEE.
ON THE PRESIDENT SANTA FE
IMPORTERS WE OPERATE SEVERAL
TELLING DEL HE'S THE FIRST MY
GRANDFATHER STARTING LONG BEACH
IN NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. WE ARE
SEVEN MANUFACTURING PLANT REMAKE
FOOD PRODUCTS FOR COMPANIES ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
INCLUDING A BRAND CALLED
EXCELLENTLY TAMALES WHICH WAS
STARTED IN CALIFORNIA IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR.
WE'VE FOR NEARLY SEVENTY PEOPLE
MANY OF WHOM ARE LIKE FAMILY TO
PASS.
THREE YEARS AGO WE WERE SUED
UNDER THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACT FOR WAGING OUR
VIOLATIONS.
AT FIRST I THOUGHT LITTLE OF THE
LAWSUIT BECAUSE WE ENCOURAGE OUR
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE ALL THE REST
PERIODS AND GIVE THEM A WIDE
LATITUDE. REGARDING HOW AND WHEN
TO TAKE THEIR BREAKS.
IN ADDITION TO THEIR REQUIRED
BREAKS OUR TEAM MEMBERS WILL
OFTEN STEP AWAY TO USE THE
RESTROOM GRAB A CUP OF COFFEE
TAKE PERSONAL PHONE CALL.
NO PROBLEM.
BUT THE WAY JUDD THE WAGE ORDERS
ARE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT HOW
EMPLOYEES MUST TAKE THEIR
BREAKS.
.
BASICALLY THEY HAVE TO WORK TWO
HOURS TAKE A TEN MINUTE BREAK
WORK TWO HOURS
TAKE A LUNCH WORK TO HOURS TAKE
A BREAK. FOR TWO HOURS FINISH
THE DAY.
.
I COMPLETELY AGREE BREAKS ARE
NECESSARY BENEFICIAL AND
DESIRABLE.
BUT WHO WORKS LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE TEAM MEMBERS THAT WANT
TO TAKE A SHORT LUNCH OR SKIP
LUNCH BECAUSE THEY WANT TO LEAVE
EARLY TO SEE THEIR KIDS SOCCER
GAME. BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
LOSE A HALF HOUR OF PAID TIME.
WE HAVE TEAM MEMBERS THAT START
AT FIVE THIRTY IN THE MORNING
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKE
THEIR LUNCH AT TEN THIRTY THE
ONE TAKE AT LUNCH TIME WITH
THEIR. WITH THEIR TEAM MEMBERS.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE ASKED COULD
THEY TAKE A SINGLE TO A TWENTY
MINUTE BREAK EARLIER IN THE DAY
AND THEN A HALF AN HOUR LUNCH
LATER SO THEY GET TO LONGER
BREAKS.
PRIOR TO THE POD LEGISLATION.
EMPLOYEES CAN MANAGE THE BRIEF
THE THEIR BREAKS MEAL PERIODS
THE WAY THEY WANTED TO.
BUT WITH THE INFORMATION WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF PARGA
EMPLOYERS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
ARE HELD TO THE LETTER THE WAGE
ORDER. EVEN WHEN IT IS CONTRARY
TO BOTH COMMONSENSE AND HUMAN
NATURE.
AND NOW ATTORNEYS HAVE A TOOL TO
LEGALLY EXTRACT LARGE SUMS OF
MONEY FROM PEOPLE WHO ALLOW
THEIR EMPLOYEES FREEDOM TO WORK
THE WAY THEY WANT.
PART OF FAILED TO RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EMPLOYERS TO
ALLOW EMPLOYEES A FLEXIBLE
SCHEDULE AND THOSE WHO DENY
EMPLOYEES LEGITIMATE BEST TIME.
IN OUR CASE WE.
ENDED UP HAVING TO SETTLE FOR
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
WE ARE PUT INTO A POSITION OF
EITHER HAVING TO SETTLE.
OR GO TO COURT AND RISK LOSING
OUR BUSINESS.
THE UP PLAINTIFF IN OUR CASE
CLAIM.
.
PENALTIES OF OVER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WOULD FORCE US
INTO BANKRUPTCY.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE TO PAY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN IN
LEGAL EXPENSES.
AND THE PLAINTIFF ATTORNEYS IN
OUR CASE RECEIVED A FULL THIRD
OF THE SETTLEMENT.
THE SAME BUSINESS WHERE TO CUT
STAFF BY TEN PERCENT REDUCE
BENEFITS SUCH AS PAID VACATION
HOME PROFIT SHARING. WE HAD TO
DENY WHERE THE EMPLOYEES BONUSES
AND RAISES.
FOREGO REPLACING AGING
EQUIPMENT.
AND AND HAD TO BORROW MONEY TO
STAND BUSINESS
THERE WEEKS THIS PAST YEAR WHEN
I FEARED I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE OUR PAYROLL.
I ASK HOW IS IT JUST THAT
LEGISLATION CAN ALLOW GROUP OF
PROFESSIONALS TO COERCE MONEY
FROM ANOTHER GROUP IN SUCH A
WAY.
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS WITHOUT
CONSIDERING THE TRUE NATURE OF
THE SITUATION WITHOUT
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT ERRORS
AND OMISSIONS. GIVEN ONLY THE
CHOICE TO PAYER LOSE ONE'S
BUSINESS.
PARK IS A BLUNT INSTRUMENT THAT
FAILS TO SEPARATE GOOD EMPLOYERS
FROM BATON ALLOWS
ATTORNEYS TO EXPLOIT THE LEGAL
SYSTEM TO THEIR OWN BENEFIT.
SOMETHING WAS CHANGE.
SMART WELL CONSIDERED
LEGISLATION WILL PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF BOTH WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS
WE'LL JUST WE COMPENSATE THOSE
WHOSE RIGHTS HAVE BEEN VIOLATED
YET.
USE GOOD JUDGMENT AND COMMON
SENSE
WHEN DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN
THOSE WHO WOULD DENY THEIR
WORKERS THEIR RIGHTS AND THOSE
WOULD GIVE THEIR EMPLOYEES
FREEDOM TO LIVE AND WORK IS A
SEE FIT.
YOU VERY MUCH.
A CUTE WITNESS.
UP THINKING MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS KEN BARNES MYSTICISM AND
BARS AND JUST CHECK IN WITH YOUR
AUTHOR WE TYPICALLY ONLY GO
ABOUT FOUR MINUTES AND WE WENT
ABOUT THAT BUT WE WILL MAKE WIN
ANOTHER TWO MINUTES WE WITNESS
WE WOULD JUST HAVE TO EXTEND THE
SAME THING TO. THE OPPOSITION
SHOULD THE OPPOSITE THAT THAT ON
PUBLIC.
A SHORT MISTER CHAIRMAN.
UP CLAIMANTS CAN BARNES WITH
CITIZENS AGAINST LAWSUIT ABUSE
AND.
APOLOGIES FOR ANY NERVOUSNESS OF
MY SHOWS THE SECOND TIME I'VE
EVER SAT HERE IDEA. THAT I THINK
PART OF THE WELL INTENDED
MEASURE IT'S JUST BEING USED IN
A WAY TO MANIPULATE TELL
EMPLOYERS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES. NECESSARY
TO FIGHT BACK.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
SHOWING FLEXIBILITY I THINK.
WE WANT TO REWARD EMPLOYERS WHO
ARE GIVING WORKERS FLEXIBILITY I
THINK ALL OF US AT SOME POINT
OUR LIFE HAVE BEEN HOURLY
EMPLOYEES AND YOU. YOU WANT TO
LEAVE TEN MINUTES EARLY AND MOVE
YOUR BREAK BECAUSE YOU'RE THERE
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO GO TO.
SOME THE FREER FAMILY AND WE
HAVE PART IS BECOME A A COUPLE
BLUNT INSTRUMENT THAT PENALIZES
THOSE EMPLOYERS ARE NOT.
TREATING WAIT STAFF THEY'RE NOT
STEALING FROM THEIR EMPLOYEES
JUST WHAT HAPPENS THE THE WAY
THAT IT'S WRITTEN IT COMES OUT
AS ALL MY GOSH YOU DIDN'T DO
EXPIRE Z. THERE FOR YOU. IT
INSTANTLY FOR YOUR EMPLOYEES
THERE'S ONE EXAMPLE THAT I
WANTED TO GIVE THAT WAS JUST
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO. ARE
ADVANCE CALL CENTER TECHNOLOGIES
OPEN IN TWENTY TWELVE OF THE
CALL CENTER LOOKING TO HAVE TWO
THOUSAND JOBS
THEY WERE SUED UNDER PARDON
TWENTY FIFTEEN. ITSELF FOR TWO
POINT FOUR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THEIR SUIT AGAIN BY PAGA.
STUDENT TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN A LAID OFF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES.
I'D HAD IT YOU TO EVEN BE WORN
ACT AND THAT LAST MONTH THEY
ANNOUNCED THEIR CLOSURE.
THERE ARE TWO OTHER VIOLATIONS
WAS THAT THERE ADDRESS SAID WEST
SPACE LAKE INSTEAD OF WHAT LIKE
ONE WORD. AND THE OTHER
VIOLATIONS WAS ADVANCED CALL
CENTER TECH INSTEAD OF
TECHNOLOGIES AND THOSE WERE
THINGS WORD THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
LAW WAS INTENDED TO DO. AND SO
WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER.
SPELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
JOHN NERGIE JOHN DIRTY WITH THE.
CIVIL JUSTICE STATION JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT IT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF.
OF WHERE THINGS ARE BEING
ABUSED IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE
SOLUTION WE'D LIKE TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT WILL.
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR BUSINESSES
SO.
PLEASE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
MAKE YOU.
KRISTIN OLSON WITH JOB CREATORS
FOR WORKPLACE FAIRNESS WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
STATED. THANK YOU.
AARON DRIVERS WITH THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. AQ.
THEY BUT WE'RE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT
MAKE YOU.
LARA CURTIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JOHN LEWIS OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AWESOME SPORT
WAS ALSO ASKED AT THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL. ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN CAR WASH
ASSOCIATION FAMILY WINEMAKERS IN
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. BAKE YOU.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
AND GROWTH CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WISHING AT ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PROCEED.
EXCUSE ME MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MARK CHAKRA CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION HERE IN OPPOSITION.
TO AB TWENTY SIXTEEN BECAUSE IT
FUNDAMENTALLY UNDERMINES THE
CENTRAL PURPOSE OF THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACT. BY
ALLOWING EVEN SERIOUS LABOR LAW
VIOLATIONS LIKE WAGE THAT HAVE.
TO BE CURED RATHER THAT
PROSECUTED BY AND GRIEVED
WORKERS STANDING IN THE SHOES OF
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS PRIVATE
ENFORCEMENT UNDER PAGO ONLY%
OCCURS AFTER A PLAINTIFF IS
EXHAUSTED HER ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDIES AND GIVEN THE STATE OF
FIRST CRACK AT PURSUING. THE
VIOLATION ITSELF WHEN THE STATE
CHOOSES NOT TO CITE AN AGGRIEVED
WORKER CAN FILE A SUIT TO PURSUE
ALL. REMEDIES FOR ANY VIOLATIONS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER UNDER THE
LABOR CODE.
FROM RECENT CONVERSATIONS WITH.
OTHER RURAL LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS IN TWENTY COUNTIES
WE ESTIMATE THAT WE FILED MORE
THAN A HUNDRED PAGA LAWSUITS ON
BEHALF OF FARMWORKERS AND LOW
WAGE WORKERS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR. ALMOST ALL OF OUR PAGO
LAWSUITS INVOLVE WAGE THEFT AND
MANY OF THEM ALSO INVOLVE OTHER
SERIOUS LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS
LIKE DENIAL OF. MEAL AND REST
PERIODS AND PROVIDING WORKERS
WITH FRAUDULENT WAGE STATEMENTS
MEANT TO DISGUISE WAGE THEFT.
SINCE TARGET WAS ENACTED WE'VE
RECOVERED AND DISTRIBUTED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN WAGES AND
PENALTIES TO FARMWORKERS AND
OTHER LOW WAGE WORKERS. AND
PROVIDED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO THE STATE LABOR
AGENCY.
BY ALLOWING EMPLOYERS TO CURE
SUCH SERIOUS VIOLATIONS.
AB TWENTY SIXTEEN UNDERCUTS THE
MAIN PURPOSES OF PACA ONE IS TO
MAKE WORKERS HOLE FOR ALL OF THE
WAGES. AND PENALTIES THAT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER COULD RECOVER
SHE BROUGHT THE CASE. AND SECOND
TO DETER FUTURE MISCONDUCT.
BY UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYERS BY
PENALIZING THEM FOR ALL LABOR
LAW VIOLATIONS THAT.
HAVE OCCURRED I JUST WANT TO
DISPUTE THE OFFICE CONVENTION
THAT THE BILL MAINTAINS THE
EXISTING PAGA PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT ALLOWS.
ALTHOUGH ALMOST SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS TO BE CURED.
THAT DOESN'T PENALIZE EMPLOYERS.
AND IT DOESN'T PROTECT WORKERS
THE WAY PAPA WAS INTENDED.
I JUST OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG UP HALF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WERE ALSO POST
THIS BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD.
DELAYED JUSTICE FOR WORKERS WHO
ARE SEEKING REMEDIES FOR A THE
FOR LABOR.
VIOLATIONS AT THE WORK SITE.
OH SORRY.
.
YET WILL THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT WORKERS
TO BRING CLAIMS IN A POCKET AT.
SOME REQUIREMENTS ON WORKERS TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO BRING COLLECTIVE ACTION AND A
MOST DANGEROUSLY IT EXTENDS WHEN
ALMOST DOUBLES THE RIGHT TEACHER
PERIOD FOR A EMPLOYERS WERE
FOUND TO VIOLATE THE LAW. OF THE
DOUBLING THE RIGHT SECURE PERIOD
ESSENTIALLY A DISINCENTIVE I'D
SIMPLE ERRORS FROM FOLLOWING THE
LAW IF YOU CAN BREAK THE LAW IF
YOU DON'T THE BIBLE LABOR CODE
AND THEN YOU CAN JUST SIMPLY SAY
ONCE YOUR CALL. YOU HAVE A
CHANCE THE CORRECTED THERE'S
REALLY NO INCENTIVE TO FOLLOW
THE LAW IN THE FIRST PLACE A WE
FEEL IT IS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
AGAIN WITH THE.
PROLIFERATION OF ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IN THE PRIVATE
WORKPLACE.
POCKETS BECOME ONE OF THE ONLY
PLACES WHERE AGAIN WORKER CAN
BRING CLAIMS COLLECTIVELY AND
THEY CAN SEEK VIOLATION BECAUSE
IT JUST IS AGAINST THE EMPLOYER
FOR LABOR VIOLATIONS AT THE WORK
SITE WITHOUT HAVING TO GO TO
THROUGH THE.
EMPLOYERS PRIVATE ARBITRATION
PROCESS BUT THROUGH PIE THAT
THESE WORKERS ARE ALLOWED TO
HAVE THEIR CASES HEARD IN A
COURTHOUSE WITH THE JURY AND
THEY GIVE IT CAN BRING THESE CUT
BEAT THE COMPLAINT BRING THESE
CLAIMS. ENCONTRE COLLECTIVELY
TOGETHER UP FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE OPPOSED.
THIS WILL OPPOSITION.
VERY GOOD AS YOU ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION I
WOULD JUST.
AND THAT.
I THINK IT'S EASY TO PICK SOME
OF THE RELATIVELY MINOR
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE GOING ON IN
THE LAWSUIT BUT. THESE WORKERS
REALLY AREN'T COMING TO
ATTORNEYS BECAUSE THE SPACE IS
WRONG IN THE NAME THERE'S OFTEN.
A LOT OF OTHER VERY SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
WE'VE HEARD OF THIS EXAMPLE
ABOUT THE SAFETY THE THE.
CHRISTMAS BONUS BUT WE ACTUALLY
LOOKED INTO THAT CASE AND IT WAS
A SAFETY BONUS IN THERE WAS.
OVERTIME IN WHICH THAT
VIOLATIONS ALSO VERY SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS GOING ON.
SO JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THERE'S ALSO WORKERS SITES AS
SOME OF THE STORIES AS WELL THAT
NEED TO BE HEARD.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION THE MACHINISTS
UNITE HERE THE OUT W. AND OTHERS
ALL OPPOSE THIS BILL. WHICH MAKE
ONE QUICK POINT THAT THIS UP
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL REJECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THEY.
MADE A BUDGET DEAL TO REFORM
PAGA I THINK SOME OF THE.
ABUSES ARE ALLEGED ABUSES THAT
WERE.
SPOKEN ABOUT ARE ARE CURED BY
THAT.
BUDGET DEAL.
THANK YOU.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS CHAO'S ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN OPPOSITION MAKE
YOU.
EVAN AND I HAD MY THE AMOUNT
FROM THE THE REST OPPORTUNITY
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND IF I
MAY JUST MAKE ONE POINT.
ON AVERAGE RESTAURANT WORKERS
WHAT WORKED ABOUTTEN TO TWELVE
HOURS A DAY AND I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF YOU HAVE EVER WORKED IN
THE KITCHEN. BUT HOW TO OUR A
BREAK WHICH IN TWO HOURS IS NOT
CLOSE ENOUGH GIVEN THE WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT A LOT OF OUR
WORKERS FACE.
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIA
ALSO OPPOSE THANK YOU.
LOCAL MARKETS SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH WORK SAFE AND ALSO
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
FEDERAL OSHA HAS HOW STATED IN
ITS ONE OF ITS FX MEMOS THAT
THESE TYPES OF SAFETY
DISINCENTIVE. ARE WITH PAT
POTENTIALLY VIOLATE THE LAW. AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU.
JUST A DISHONORABLE HAVE EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES WE OPPOSE.
IF YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TRYING TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. IS THERE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
WOULD LIKE CLOSE I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY I I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE ROBUST
DEBATE AND IN THE FORCE OVER THE
FOLKS THAT WERE INVOLVED IN
DISCUSSION. UMNO WE ARE LOOKING
TO.
REFORM PARGANA WAY THAT
PRESERVES THE RIGHTS OF THE
EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO.
ALLOW SMALL BUSINESSES TO
EXPAND TO GROW AND NOT TO BE A
HIT WITH FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS THAT
WILL FORCE THEM TO MAKE THE
DECISION OF WHETHER TO CLOSE OR
GO OUT OF BUSINESS. THAT'S
REALLY GOOD RESULTING IN THEIR
EMPLOYEES BEING HURT WITH LOSS
OF WHAT WAGES A LOSS AND
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS AND AS YOU
CAN TELL FROM THAT THE LARGE
COALITION. OF OVER EIGHTY
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT OUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS THAT THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
IS A MESS HERE THAT THIS LAW IS
BEING ABUSED AND WE WE NEED TO
FIND A SOLUTION I WOULD HOPE
THAT WOULD WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. IN SOME WAY OF
FINDING THAT SOLUTION THANKS
VERY MUCH I REQUEST I'VE.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMOND NOW
THURMAN NO FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO KALRA.
KALRA NO MCCARTY. MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
THAT BILL FAILS WHEREBY GAS WE
CONSIDERATIONS ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU PRESENTATION.
WE CONSIDERATION BE GRANTED
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
BILL.
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL
YOU APPARENTLY HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. ON AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR AYE PLEASE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES.
THIS SHOULD BE AN EASY ONE FOR
YOU.
THIS SHOULD BE A PIECE OF CAKE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR WHICH PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY FOR EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES.
TO NEGOTIATE COMPENSATION FOR
TIME WORKED IN EXCESS OF THEIR
EIGHT HOUR WORK DAY OR FORTY
HOUR WORK WEEK.
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES AN
EMPLOYEE AND THESE ARE MAINLY
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
TO ACCUMULATE UP TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY HOURS OF PAID TIME OFF
IN LIEU OF OVERTIME PAY.
PROVIDED THE EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE AGREED TO THIS
AGREEMENT.
SOLITARY.
HOWEVER EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO INDUSTRIAL WELFARE
COMMISSION WAGE ORDERS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS VALUABLE
OPTION AND THAT'S. ALMOST
EVERYONE ELSE.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
EXPANDS THE PROFESSIONS AND
INDUSTRIES THAT CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES TO THIS VOLUNTARY
ARRANGEMENT BY REMOVING THE
CURRENT EXCLUSION OF HARD
WORKING INDIVIDUALS ALLOWING
THEM TO RECEIVE COMPENSATING
TIME OFF. IN PLACE OF OVERTIME
WAGES.
FOR MANY INDIVIDUALS THE VALUE
OF PAID TIME OFF MAYBE DIRETOR
THAT OVERTIME PAY.
EMPLOYEES NEED THE OPTION TO
SUBSTITUTE PAID TIME OFF AS
COMPENSATION FOR THEIR OVERTIME
SO THEY CAN HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
TO ATTEND A HEALTH CARE NEEDS
CHILD SCHOOL OBLIGATIONS AND
OTHER IMPORTANT ERRANDS.
LITTLE LEAGUE GAMES TO.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO BE MORE
COMPETITIVE BY OFFERING THIS
CHOICE IN FURTHER ASSIST THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WHO SEEK MORE
FLEXIBLE WORK ARRANGEMENTS.
FOR THESE REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU SIR THANK
AND MAKE SOME OF THEM ARE VOEPEL
WITNESSES.
SUPPOSED TO HAVE ONE.
ANYONE IN THE MEANTIME WISHING
TO ADD ON IN SPORT TO THIS BILL.
AARON I BROKE WITH THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
I GUESS THAT WAS THE ONE WHO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
IS HERE.
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARK SHOCK OF CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR NOT GETTING A LETTER
IN TIME.
WE RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF THE TIMING
OF OF THIS PARTICULAR CHANGE.
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ FLETCHER
IS A FARM WORKER OVERTIME BILL
FARMWORKERS.
.
WERE NOT THE BENEFICIARIES OF
THIS KIND OF A PROVISION. AND
THE ENTIRE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY.
UP I PUT BENEFICIARIES AND QUOTE
I BELIEVE I BELIEVE THE REASON
THEY WERE EXCEPT IT WAS TO
PROTECT THEM FROM THE.
IT OF THE WELL KNOWN WIDESPREAD.
FRAUDULENT.
ITEMIZE WAGE STATEMENTS.
PRACTICES IN THE INDUSTRY OF
THERE'S JUST A A SERIOUS CONCERN
THAT THAT FOLKS WILL BE
LEVERAGED INTO TRADING THEIR
OVERTIME FOR THE PROMISE OF.
OFF COMPENSATION OFF TIME.
IT WILL NEVER AND FACT
MATERIALIZE.
AL DON'T BE LEVERAGED OR COOL
WORST
INTO THAT AND THAT WAS THE
REASON FOR OUR CONCERN. AND JAM.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
BUT IT WAS LIMITED TO HAPPEN
DIGITAL OPPOSITION.
NICHOLAS HOUSE ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN OPPOSITION IN
LIKE ECHO THE COMMENTS STATED.
JUST IT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY GOSH I WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PLAN MILLERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION RUSSELL POST
THANK YOU.
WHEN A PARADISE HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA ALSO OPPOSED.
JESSICA CENTER EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES OPPOSE THANK YOU.
TRYING TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
YOUR BILL DOES HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES SIR.
CALIFORNIA HAS TO COMPETE THE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN WORLD.
AND WE HAVE MANY MANY.
HIGHLY VALUABLE AND HIGHLY PAID
AND RESPECTED AND LOWER PAID AND
RESPECTED PEOPLE WORKING IN
INDUSTRY I. T..
AND MANY OF THEM MIDDLE CLASS
NEED THE TIME OFF PAID.
AND THEY WOULD GLADLY.
TRADE THERE.
CHIPS IN FROM OVER TIME TO JUST
THE TIME OFF I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND
HOPE.
TO RECEIVE IT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER VOEPEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN NOW
THURMAN NO FLORA. FLORA AYE
CONSULTS FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER KNOWN JONES
SAWYER KALRA MCCARTY. MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
THANK YOU.
YOU BILLS ON CALL.
SAY GET YOUR BILLS ON CALL WILL
WAIT FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS
RETURN AND GIVE AT ON OKAY WE
CAN ASK FOR. RECONSIDERATION
WHEN WE FIND OUT THE RESULTS
CORRECT IF YOU WISH.
SO AGAIN YES IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU YOU'RE ON CALL FOR NOW
.
WE WELCOME THE VICE CHAIR TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE OH SEVEN.
AND LET'S LET ANYONE INTO.
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE IT.
YOU DON'T KNOW IT YET BUT YOU'RE
GONNA LOVE IT.
JERRY IT'S A PRIVILEGE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO YOU. AB TWENTY NINE
OH SEVEN AND I DO WANT TO JUST
RECOGNIZE IT'S IN THE SAME VEIN
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY.
HOWEVER THIS IS A SIGNIFICANTLY
OR SCALPEL APPROACH IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
TED DO ARISE.
ON SORT MORE THEY AGREE JUST
ISSUES.
IT'S AB TWENTY NINE OH SEVEN
WOULD EXPAND THAT LIST OF
ITEMIZE WAGE STATEMENT
VIOLATIONS THAT EMPLOYERS CAN
ATTEMPT TO CURE UNDER PAGA I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE. THAT AB
TWENTY NINE OF SEVEN DOES NOT
ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO WRONGFULLY
PAY. PAY LATE OR COMMIT ANY.
ACTIVE WAGE SET THOSE ISSUES
ARE CURRENTLY PROTECTED AND
LABOR CODE LABOR CODE TOOL FOR.
AND LABOR CODE ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO
POINT TWELVE THIS BILL MERELY
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO CORRECT AN
ADVERT PRINTING AIRS. ON
EMPLOYEE PAY STUBS.
EACH YEAR THE STATE RECEIVES OR
SIX THOUSAND NOTICES.
OF A TENT OF PAGA LAWSUITS PAGA
LAWSUITS CLAIM TO.
CLAIMS HAVE INCREASED MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE.
THE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN IN
OVER TWO HUNDRED PERCENT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN.
ATTORNEY FEES.
THE RESULT OF THE PARK WAS TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES.
A CODIFIED EMPLOYEES RIGHTS IN
LAW AND PROTECTED FROM POTENTIAL
ABUSIVE EMPLOYERS.
HOWARD HAS BECOME A SOURCE OF
IMMENSE FRIVOLOUS AND ABUSE OF
LITIGATION STRAIGHT AWAY FROM
FROM PROTECTING EMPLOYEES
RIGHTS.
INSTEAD OF BECOMING THE
CONTENTIOUS SOURCE OF INCOME FOR
ATTORNEYS AND POLITIC LITIGATION
FIRMS.
THERE'S A COUPLE EXAMPLES ONE
ATTORNEY FEES OF OVER SIXTEEN
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE AND FOURTEEN DOLLARS AND
FIFTY THREE CENTS OF THAT.
ANOTHER ONE ATTORNEY FEES OVER
TWO AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
LAWYERS ARE GETTING SEVENTEEN
DOLLARS AND NINETY TWO CENTS
A THIRD ONE OVER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ATTORNEY FEES.
EMPLOYERS ARE GETTING FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
UNDER CURRENT PAGA LOCKED SO
UNDER CURRENT LAW PAGA PROVIDES
EMPLOYERS THE RIGHT TO CURE TWO.
OF THE NINE PAYROLL REQUIREMENTS
WE GET IT DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY
AVENUE TO RECTIFY THE HEIRS
RELATED TO THE SEVEN. PAYSTUB
THE OTHER SEVEN PAYSTUB
REQUIREMENTS.
WE BELIEVE EMPLOYERS SHOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CORRECT THEIR
MISTAKES AND NOT BE
AUTOMATICALLY PUNISHED FOR AN
HONEST AIR. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE.
IT IS UNLIKE UNLIKE MANY OTHER
POTTER RELATED BILLS AB TWENTY
NINE OH SEVEN DOES NOT CHANGE
THE TIME PERIOD OR THE NUMBER OF
TIMES AND YOUR EMPLOYER CAN'T
YEAR.
IT ONLY ALTERS WHICH PAYSTUB
REQUIREMENTS EMPLOYERS ARE
ALLOWED TO CARE.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DAVID BOREN
OF BUSINESS OWNER FROM MY
DISTRICT AND FORMER SOMEONE
WOMAN CRYSTAL SENT.
TO TESTIFY MISTER BORING.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR FLOOR LET
ME.
FIRST OF KNOWLEDGE THAT A
COLLEAGUE A FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OLSON SUPERVISOR
HONORABLE WELCOME BACK TO THE
GREEN CARPET.
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU WELL MY NAME IS DAVID
BORING FIRST TIME AND FOR YOUR
GUY SO BEAR WITH ME.
AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK I HAVE A
SMALL AD AGENCY WE'VE BEEN
THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN BUSINESS.
LITERALLY STARTED WITH A HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN MY GARAGE.
AND I'M A BUILT UP OVER YEARS A
VERY FAMILY ORIENTED BUSINESS WE
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY EMPLOYEES.
AND AND A LOT OF WAYS WERE VERY
MUCH LIKE A FAMILY YOU KNOW WE
GET TO KNOW THOSE EMPLOYEES WELL
THEY THEY THEY.
WE HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM
IN THEIR.
VERY EXTENSIVE RELATIONSHIPS.
AND.
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE HAD EVEN
FORTY EMPLOYEES HAVE GONE ON TO
ANOTHER JOB AND COME BACK FACT
ACTUALLY WAS TEXTING WHEN THE
KIDS COMING BACK TODAY AFTER
SIXTEEN YEAR SOMEWHERE ELSE.
SO WE'VE HAD GOOD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH OUR EMPLOYEES WE REALLY
CARE ABOUT THEM WHEN THEY DO
WELL BY THEM.
WE GET BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY
SERVE ON A LOT OF COMMITTEES
DONATE TO ALLOW THE NON PROFITS.
WERE WERE LITERALLY ONE OF THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES JUST WANTS TO
ALWAYS DO AS BEST WE CAN FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. WERE NOT A BIG
BUSINESS IN TERMS OF REVENUE
WERE TWO TO THREE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SO WE'RE NOT ONE
OF THOSE KIND OF EMPLOYERS.
AND OFTENTIMES MY BUSINESS
PARTNER AND I MOST OF THE STAFF
IS WITHIN THIRTY TO FORTY
PERCENT OF WHAT WE MAKE SO WE'RE
NOT MAKING A LOT MORE THAN OUR
EVEN OUR OUR EMPLOYEES.
SO PRIOR TO PRAGA WE HAD NEVER
ACTUALLY HAD ANYTHING BROUGHT
AGAINST US WE NEVER HAD A
LAWSUIT WE NEVER HAD A WORKERS
COMP CLAIM.
AND WE HAD NEVER HAD REALLY HAD
ANY ANY ISSUES AT ALL THAT THAT
CAME UP WITH EMPLOYEES.
AND SO AS.
WE WERE PRESENTED WITH A POCKET
CASE.
FIRST THING WE DID IS GET OUR
RESEARCH WENT OUT QUICKLY AND
WANTED TO MAKE SECURE AND WE
ROUTE A VIOLATION FOR LEGAL NAME
ONLY OR AND VIOLATION FOR NOT
HAVING. A GLASS FOR THE SOCIAL
SECURITY SO WE CURED THAT SEND
THEM OUT TO ALL SEVENTY TWO
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK FOR US OVER
THE PERIOD OF TIME THAT WE WERE
REQUIRED TO DO IT.
SO NOW WORK LEFT EXPOSED BECAUSE
WE DID NOT HERE WE DON'T HAVE A
CURE FOR THE LAST FOR THE SOCIAL
SECURITY WE'VE OBVIOUSLY HANDED
THAT OUT TO ALL EMPLOYEES.
SO.
WE HAD THAT LITERALLY GO TO
MEDIATION.
AND THE THREAT OF WHAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO PAY.
GOING AGAINST A CLASS ACTION
SUIT.
YEAH I AM IN THIS WAY REALLY
MADE US HAD TO SETTLE.
AND DOWN IT WAS A REALLY HARD
THING FOR COMPANY WE HAD TO TALK
TO BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEYS AND LOOK
AT IT REALLY SERIOUSLY BECAUSE.
JUST ATTORNEYS FEES AS AS OF
MISTER FLORA SAID. ALONE COULD
JUST PUT US OUT OF BUSINESS.
.
SO YOU HAVE ONE CLAIM. WE WE
SOLVED IT MEDIATED IT.
IT WAS THREE YEARS ABOUT ROUGHLY
OF NET PROFIT FOR OUR COMPANY A
ONE EMPLOYEE WERE STILL OUT
THERE HUNG OUT TO DRY WITH
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WANTS TO DO
IT.
NEVER EMPLOYEES THAT RECEIVE
THIS INFORMATION SEVEN MONTHS
AGO HAVE COME FORWARD WITH ANY
ISSUES AND WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT WE JUST SEND IT TO A
WOMAN.
AND LET IT GO.
BUT.
FOR US IT COULD LITERALLY BE THE
END OF OUR COMPANY BECAUSE WE'VE
JUST SETTLED ONE.
AND IT FEELS LIKE IT'S JUST.
BUT.
LANDMINES WAITING TO GO OFF
EVERYWHERE WE'VE CURED IT WE'VE
TAKEN CARE OF IT WE WERE USING.
A LOCAL ACCOUNTING FIRM TO MAKE
SURE WE WERE IN COMPLIANCE
BIGGEST ONE IN A MARKET WE HAD A
NATIONAL PAYROLL SERVICE THAT WE
HAD OUR PAYROLL THROUGH.
NONE OF THEM KNEW THAT THESE
THINGS WERE ON THE BOOKS FOR
CALIFORNIA SO. WE END UP HAVE
MAKING AN HONEST MISTAKE AND.
HAVE GREAT CONSEQUENCES FOR IT.
AND SO. I'M JUST WRONGLY
PLEADING THAT LOOK AT THESE
THINGS IN THE PAGA.
AT. THE VIOLATIONS OF AB SLASH
FOR A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND
I GOT IT DISCOVER CARD APPROVED
YESTERDAY ON THE PHONE GIVING
LAST FOR MY SOCIAL SECURITY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE HARMING
AN EMPLOYEE THAT THAT'S NOT ON
THERE WE'VE PUT IT BACK ON THERE
BUT. THAT'S A VIOLATION.
AND WERE OUT OF A LOT OF MONEY
WE MAY NOT EVEN BE HERE NEXT
YEAR BECAUSE OF IT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS WELCOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HERE
ALSO EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY NINE OH SEVEN FROM JOB
CREATORS FOR WORKPLACE FAIRNESS.
AS WELL AS A COMPANY IN THE
CEMENT FLOORS DISTRICT VIP HOME
SERVICE HOME CARE SERVICES.
JOB CREATORS FOR WORKPLACE
FAIRNESS IS A COALITION OF
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES
DEDICATED TO MAKING SURE THAT
WAGE AND HOUR LAWS ARE FAIR FOR
BOTH EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS.
AS STATED AB TWENTY NINE OH
SEVEN SIMPLY ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO
CORRECT INADVERTENT ERRORS ON
EMPLOYEE PAY STUBS BEFORE THEY
CAN BE SUED UNDER PAGA.
UNFORTUNATELY PREDATORY
ATTORNEYS HAVE GOTTEN RICH BY
SEARCHING FOR THE SMALL ERRORS
AND THEN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEES TO
VICTIMIZE BOTH WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS.
THESE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS HAVE
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS AND THEY ARE RAPIDLY
SPREADING ACROSS THE STATE.
I'D LIKE TO READ A STATEMENT
FROM CANDACE BRIGHT SHE IS THE
OWNER OF THE IP HOME CARE
SERVICES WHICH IS LIKE THAT OF
AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN ASSEMBLYMAN
FLOREZ DISTRICT IN MODESTO.
CANDACE SAYS MY NAME IS CANDICE
BRIGHT NINE A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER I HAVE FOR RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES THAT SERVE TWENTY
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHO
ALSO EXHIBIT SEVERE BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES.
WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY EMPLOYEES AT ANY GIVEN
TIME.
RECENTLY WE HAD AN EMPLOYEE WHO
HAS WORKED FOR US FOR THREE
YEARS FILA PAGA CLAIM DO THE
LAST FOUR DIGITS OF THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER NOT BEING ON HIS
PAY STUB.
IN MARCH WE DECIDED TO SWITCH
FROM AN IN HOUSE PAYROLL SYSTEM
TO A NEW ACCOUNTING FIRM AND WE
DIDN'T ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE
PAY STUBS WERE CORRECT.
THE EMPLOYEE NEVER ADDRESSED HIS
CONCERN WITH US OR THE
ACCOUNTING FIRM.
WE ARE CURRENTLY NEED DEEP AND
ATTORNEYS FEES AT THIS POINT WE
ARE CONTEMPLATING CLOSING OUR
BUSINESS BECAUSE WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO CONTINUE THE FIGHT WHEN WE
DID NOTHING WRONG.
THE RIGHT TO CURE ALL POINTS IS
ESSENTIAL FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE A BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS WE ALL KNOW IT'S REALLY HARD
TO FIND ENOUGH HOMES TO SERVE
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND LET'S NOT
MAKE IT EVEN HARDER BY ALLOWING
THESE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS TO
CONTINUE AND PUT COMPANIES LIKE
THIS OUT OF BUSINESS.
WE SUPPORT AS JOB CREATORS FOR
WORKPLACE FAIRNESS MAINTAINING
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF PACA
WHICH IS TO PROTECT WORKERS FROM
BAD ACTOR BUSINESSES.
BUT THE LAW SHOULD NOT ALLOW
ATTORNEYS TO VICTIMIZE WORKERS
OR EMPLOYERS IN ORDER TO LINE
THEIR OWN POCKETS AND THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY.
SO PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB TWENTY
NINE OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
AARON DRIVER WITH THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JOHN DORY WITH THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN CAR WASH
ASSOCIATION OF FAMILY WINE
MAKERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATY HANSEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AARON GROWTH CVI A CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEAN THOSE THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO SUPPORT THINKING
THANK YOU.
MARK CURTIS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THINK YOU.
IF YOU.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I JUST HAD A MONTH THIS WITH A
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS SPECIALTY
CONTRACTORS.
IF YOU.
ATTY BERNACCHI A MAP NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION UNITED CONTRACTORS
IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE OH
SEVEN.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARK CHUCK OF CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION DAY BE
TWENTY NINE A SEVEN BECAUSE IT
TRANSFORMS WHAT WAS INTENDED
ORIGINALLY TO BE. A LIMITED
SOLUTION FOR DEMAND IN THIS WAGE
STATEMENT VIOLATIONS INTO SUCH A
BROAD AND ENCOMPASSING.
EXEMPTION THAT EVERYTHING IS
CURABLE.
INCLUDING THE ISSUANCE OF
DELIBERATELY FALSIFIED PAY STUBS
IT'S GOES FAR BEYOND THE ISSUE
OF THE LAST FOUR DIGITS ON
SOMEBODY'S PAYSTUB WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION WE
WORKED WITH THE PREVIOUS
CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE. TO
ADDRESS
SOME OF THE INEQUITIES IN THAT
HAVE BEEN REVEALED IN PAGA.
FROM SOME OF THIS LITIGATION WE
SUPPORTED THE CREATION OF A TEN
ATTORNEY UNIT WITHIN THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
TO SCREEN. FOR ABUSIVE PAGA
LAWSUITS
WE THINK THAT THE THE LITIGATION
THAT IS BEING TALKED ABOUT
PRECEDED THE CREATION OF THIS
UNIT AND OF THIS UNIT IS GIVEN.
A CHANCE TO OPERATE I THINK MANY
OF THE CONCERNS ARE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED BUT LET ME JUST
QUICKLY SAY SOMETHING. ABOUT
THE.
IMPORTANCE OF THE ITEMIZE WHICH
STATEMENT TO FARMWORKERS AND
OTHER LOW WAGE WORKERS IN OUR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF
REPRESENTING LOW WAGE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE FOUND IT'S
EXTREMELY COMMON FOR CLIENTS OUR
CLIENTS WAGE STATEMENTS TO
CONTAIN FALSIFIED INFORMATION
AND JUST LET ME READ THEM. GROSS
CENTER NET WAGES EARNED
DEDUCTIONS MADE FROM PAY TOTAL
HOURS WORKED TOTAL HOURS WORKED
EACH APPLICABLE HOURLY RATE
TOTAL HOURS WORKED WORK AT EACH
APPLICABLE PIECE RATE.
THE OF THE FACT IS THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THESE PAY STUBS
THERE'S A INCREDIBLE CONSISTENCY
THESE FALSIFIED PAY STUBS.
VIRTUALLY EVERY ERROR.
MISTAKE.
IN YOUR IT'S TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE EMPLOYER AND NOT THE
EMPLOYEE.
IT'S ARE IT'S A PROFOUND ERROR
FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO PASS A
BILL THAT WILL MAKE THOSE KINDS
OF DELIBERATE FALSIFIED WAGE
STATEMENTS.
CURABLE.
SIMPLY BY THE ISSUANCE OF A.
WAGE STUB THAT'S CORRECTED THE
WORKERS NOT MADE HOLE AS THEY
ARE ANOTHER CURE. CONSTANT EGG.
ANOTHER CURE INSTANCES THIS IS A
SPECIAL PURE PROVISION ONLY FOR
WHAT WERE TO BE DEMAND IN THIS
VIOLATIONS SO WE'D URGE AND NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
ADDITION OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG THAT THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WERE ALSO OPPOSE THE
BILL. ON ESSENTIALLY A MAKES THE
SPACE OF VIOLATIONS NOT SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS GIVEN THE EMPLOYER
THE RIGHT.
AS WE SAY IT'S BEFORE THE RIGHT
SECURE ESSENTIALLY.
ELIMINATE THE EMPLOYERS
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO UP WHILE
THE LAW BECAUSE IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THERE ACTUALLY CALL
VIOLATING THE LAW I HEAR SHE
FACES NO PENALTY.
BASICALLY EMPLOYERS GET THE GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BREAK THE LAW
AND SO THEY ARE CAUGHT IN ONLY
BEEN A FACE ANY RECOURSE AND
MAKE THE WORKER HOLE. A PIECE OF
VIOLATIONS ARE OFTEN A
REFLECTION OF A UNDERLYING
BELIEF THAT AT THE WORKPLACE IF
EMPLOYERS NO LONGER NEED TO. BE
CONCERNED WITH PROVIDING AN
ACCURATE PACE THE THE YOU'LL SEE
A PROLIFERATION OF A WASTE THAT
INABILITY FOR IMPORT FOR WORKERS
SAID.
STOOD TO GET RECORDS BUT AT
LEAST THAT OF ADDITIONAL ADS
LIKE SPEAKER BEFORE ME STATED
THAT.
THE LABOR FOR IT IN A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN YEARS PAST TO.
IMPLEMENT MORE STANDARD AND
TIGHTENED STANDARDS.
IN REGARDS TO HIGHER CLAIMS FOR
PIZZA VIOLATIONS AND THERE IS A
NEW STANDARD THIS IS THAT.
WORKERS THAT CANNOT SHOW OF THE
WRECK WITH RECORDS CAN ACTUALLY
WRECK WITH A HARMLESS THEY'RE
UNABLE TO DETERMINE FROM THE
PEACE THE IF THEY WERE.
IMPROPERLY PAID SO I WE WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN THE PAST
TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE BUT
EXPANDING.
.
EXPANDING THE RIGHT SECURE AGAIN
WORLD I'M A EMPLOYERS ABILITY OR
ELIMINATE THE IMPORTANT THINGS
ABOUT OF THE LAW ULTIMATELY
HARMING WORKERS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION JACQUI START
WITH CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AMALGAMATED TRANSIT
UNION THE AL W. UNITE HERE THE
OTHERS CAN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU.
BREAK A YOUR SHOWER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
JESSICA STERN NO EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
IT WAS CHVEZ ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
NICOLE MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF WORK
SAFE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
EVELYN I HAD MADE THE NOW WITH
THE REST OPPORTUNITY CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THE GERMAN RECESS IDEAS WE HAVE
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING.
SOME AMERICANS ALSO FLETCHER I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THEY'RE
THERE IS A LOT DISCUSSED ABOUT
EMPLOYERS
ENGAGE IN WHICH THAT TONIGHT IT
DON'T THINK ANYWAY AND ONE. WAS
ACCUSING HER OF THAT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IT SOUNDS LIKE
YET AN HONEST MISTAKE THAT
HOPEFULLY IN GOING FORWARD AND
HOW ADDRESSING THIS WOULDN'T.
I AT CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW THEY USE
I MIGHT GET MY CONCERN HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
THAT THIS WAS MEANT TO AUGMENT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S.
.
ADAM.
BUDGET.
AND THE AMOUNT THAT ACTUALLY
COMES BACK TO THE STATE OFTEN IS
NOT IT IT. DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
FOR FILLING.
WHEN WHEN THERE ARE SETTLEMENTS.
THAT.
PURPOSE AND SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK I'M GIVEN OUR
REFORMS WE SHOULD LET THEM SEE
IF WHERE WE GOT AN AND POSSIBLY
NAM VIEW THAT BECAUSE OUR LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
SHOULD ARE THAT ARE YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD BE DOING THIS WORK AND
JUST DON'T HAVE.
ON THE NECESSARY STAFF TO DO
THAT SO I I UNDERSTAND AND I'VE
HEARD FROM.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO.
KIND OF.
A MISTAKE IN AND THAT'S NOT
RIGHT EITHER SO I I JUST WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT IT NO WAY WOULD I
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THE
OPPONENT SAID BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF THAT BUT IT WASN'T
DIRECTED.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE YOU DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
OTHERS MAKE IT BRIEF YOU KNOW
THIS IS I KNOW IT'S A VERY.
.
FLUENT DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE
AND.
THIS BILL WAS DRAFTED IN A VERY
NARROWLY.
WAY BECAUSE I DO THINK THERE
ARE SOME DISCUSSIONS THE NEED TO
START HAPPENING AS RELATES TO
PAGA EMPIRE REFORM. THERE ARE
SOME.
GOODS ARE LEAVING OPPOSITION
SAID THAT YOU KNOW THEY SUPPORT
LIMITED SOLUTIONS.
TO SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
GET TO WE WANT TO GET TO THE
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE I DO THINK IF
IT. A GOOD ACTOR WERE NOT WE
WANT NOTHING TO DO WITH
PROTECTING ABOUT ACTORS
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BUDGET UNLIKE MR BORING AND THIS
OTHER LADY AND AND QUITE FRANKLY
THERE'S FOR OTHERS IN OUR
DISTRICT THAT HAVE GONE TO THE
SAME SYMBOLS SIMILAR THINGS. ARE
DEALING WITH THIS IT DOES NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED AND I WOULD LOVE
TO WORK WITH MISS FLETCHER ON
THESE ISSUES IN THE COMMITTEE
AND SO WE CAN FIND A SOLUTION
THAT WE CAN ALL CAN AND. CAN
AGREE ON SO APPRECIATE YOUR KIND
OF.
THANK YOU BYE SURE FLORA PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMAN. NO
THURMOND NOW FLORA AYE FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER NO JONES SAWYER KALRA
MCCARTY MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
IT GOES ON CALL STILL CHANCE
MCGEORGE VANNATTER.
WE WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL WHO IS HERE TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY TO TWENTY TWO WELCOME
SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY TWO TWENTY
TWO DEFINES PUBLIC WORKS TO
INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE FUNDING
THROUGH CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS RECEIVE PREVAILING WAGE
AND ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT FROM
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
CONDUIT REVENUE BOND FINANCING
IS CORNERED AND BY A NONPROFIT
OR PUBLIC ENTITY.
SUCH AS THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FINANCING AUTHORITY UNDER THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE.
THE STATE LOSES REVENUE ON THESE
BONDS AS INVESTORS DO NOT PAY
TAXES
IN TURN THE BORROWER BENEFITS BY
RECEIVING LOWER INTEREST RATES.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES THAT ARE
FUNDED BY STATE EDUCATION BONDS
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGHER.
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER THE
FIELD ACT.
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED WITH
CONDUIT BONDS DO NOT.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THOSE
WORKING ON THE STATE SUBSIDIZED
PROJECTS ARE SKILLED AND
QUALIFIED. THEY PUT THEY
ULTIMATELY PROVIDE A BETTER
PRODUCT.
THIS IS A POLICY THAT KEEPS
GIVING.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON OUR ECONOMY AND
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER THE I
A BILL THE COMMITTEE PASSED A
FEW YEARS AGO DEFINING PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS TO INCLUDE
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS.
FUNDED BY CONDUIT BON REVENUE SO
THIS IS NOT UNIQUE.
OUR. POLICIES LIKE THIS ENSURE
THAT A QUALITY PROJECT.
THAT IS.
DELIVERED ON TIME AND UNDER
BUDGET AND WITH ME HERE TODAY'S
CESAR DEALS FROM THE STATE
CONSTRUCTION BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER WHAT THE
FIRST WITNESS
THE YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HAS
IDEAS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AT THANK. YOUR STAFF IN
THIS COMMITTEE FOR LOOKING AT
THIS.
AND THE ANALYSIS AREN'T WE ARE
REFERRING TO A SITUATION WHERE
THERE IS A PUBLIC SUBSIDY IN OUR
VIEW. AND.
.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS LOOKED
AT VARIOUS WAYS DIFFERENT
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO FUND
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROJECTS OVER
TIME.
AND AND SO IN DOING SO THE
PREVAILING WAGE LAWS HAVE BEEN
UPDATED TO CATCH UP TO THOSE
DIFFERENT FINANCING MECHANISMS.
ONE OF THOSE FINANCING
MECHANISMS AS CONDUIT FINANCING.
IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE
THESE ARE PUBLIC FACILITIES OF
SERVING THE PUBLIC. AND THEY ARE
BEING SUBSIDIZED THROUGH THE
CONDUIT FINANCING AS WAS STATED
BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
ISSUER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING
BACK THE DEBT. BUT IF THERE WAS
ANY RISK.
IT WOULD BE ON THE STATE OR THE
PUBLIC ENTITY ITSELF BECAUSE OF
THE CREDIT RATING THAT WOULD
SUFFER.
SO IN TERMS OF.
PROVIDING MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FINANCING FOR CHARTERS
WE BELIEVE THAT.
BEYOND THE SCHOOL BOND THE
STATEWIDE SCHOOL BOND THAT HAS
INCLUDED A CERTAIN PART PORTION
OF AND THAT IT'S OVER. OVER.
.
OVERDUE BASICALLY IN TERMS OF
THE LONG LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE WAITING TO GET FUNDING FROM
THAT.
THERE'S ALSO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
LOAN PROGRAMS THAT EXIST TO TRY
TO HELP THE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THERE'S ALSO PROGRAM WHERE THE.
PROVIDE THIRTY FIRST RIGHTS TO
LOOK AT PUBLIC FACILITIES THAT A
PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICT TASK
TO PROVIDE TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL
ITSELF.
SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A MORE
SOPHISTICATED FINANCING
MECHANISM THAT SERVES THE LARGER
PUBLIC UP IN THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
OF.
PROPOSALS MAINLY THOSE THAT GO
TO THE C. S. HALF A.
THOSE HAVE HIGHER LEVELS OF
SCRUTINY.
AND THEY'RE ALSO HAVE A
GUARANTEE BASED ON THE EIGHTY A
AND THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO BASICALLY GUARANTEE
THAT THEY WILL GET THE FUNDING
BACK SO. WHAT WE'RE SAYING AS
THE SYSTEM GROWS?
AND COMPETES WITH THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT IS A. GOOD
JOB PROVIDER FOR A LOT OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN THE BUILDING
TRAINS AND THE APPRENTICES THAT
ARE GOING TO OUR PROGRAMS. THAT
THESE THIS INVESTMENTS SHOULD
NOT LEAVE BEHIND THOSE WORKERS
WILL CREATE MORE EFFICIENCIES IN
ACTUALLY CREATE SAFER WORK.
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS FOR THE
STUDENTS AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THE MEMBERS BOB JR
ON BEHALF OF THE PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES BOTH DISTRICT
COUNCIL THIRTY SIX IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SIXTEEN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL I AGO
MISTER.
DE IS COMMENTS WE ALSO FEEL
THIS IS THIS MAKES THE.
SCHOOL SAVOR THE WORK FORCE IS
MORE SKILLED AND THE PRODUCT IS
BETTER. AND WE SUPPORT THE.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT HE
BERNACCHI ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE CONFERENCE THE
PLUMBING HEATING A PIPING
INDUSTRY THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION. AND
UNITED CONTRACTORS A THIS BILL
TRACKS WITH OTHER.
PROCESSES AND POLICIES IN THIS
AREA.
MOST SPECIFICALLY WRITTEN
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED IN THIS
AREA RELATED CONDUIT REVENUE
BONDS RECLINE PREVAILING WAGE
WITH HOSPITAL DISTRICTS. ARM
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATIONS
BELIEVES STRONGLY IN THE POLICY
OF THAT THERE'S A PUBLIC BENEFIT
THAT ISSUE TRAILER PREP
PREVAILING WAGE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE DRIVE OUT ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONEY GONNA BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS A CALIFORNIA
STATE PARTRIDGE COUNCIL IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT DISS A.
UP A NEW.
PUBLIC INSTRUMENT USED TO
FINANCE SCHOOLS HENCE IT SHOULD
BE IN OF THE PREVAILING WAGE
STATUTES THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SHARON
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS DUBBED OVER SOME WE HAVE
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
THE BOILERMAKERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IT'S I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNGER THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
HE'S GOING FORWARD.
PLEASE PROCEED.
I FEEL KINDA LONELY APPEAR AFTER
THAT LESSEN PERCENTAGE XIN BY
THE SUPPORTERS.
I'M DOMINIC THE MARI AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TOOK.
IN HERE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HOW COME I WILL BE BRIEF OF MY
REMARKS?
WE DON'T FEEL IT IS APPROPRIATE
OR AT LEAST IN THE BEST INTEREST
STUDENTS.
HUB TO IMPOSE PREVAILING WAGE
UPON SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
I'M NOT THAT WE HAVE ANYTHING
AGAINST PREVAILING WAGE ITS JUST
THAT THE. SPONSORS OF THE BILL
MENTIONED THE SORT OF BENEFITS
THAT ACCRUE TO.
THOSE WHO INVEST AND OR THOSE
WHO BY BONDS THAT ARE MUNICIPAL
BONDS WITH LOW INTEREST RATES.
AND THOSE OUR BENEFITS THAT
ACCRUED INVESTORS THE BENEFIT
THAT ACCRUES TO THE CHARTER
SCHOOL IS THEN PASSED IS REALLY
BENEFIT THAT'S PASSED ON TO THE
STUDENT WHICH IS.
THE LOWER COST AVAILABLE OF THE
MONEY AVAILABLE TO FINANCE
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
SO WHEN WE PAY THAT LOWER
INTEREST RATE OR WHEN WE GET
THAT MONEY CHEAPER.
THE BENEFIT THAT WE GET IS
PASSED ON TO THE STUDENT IN
BEING ABLE TO BUILD MORE
BUILDINGS OR A BIGGER OR BETTER
CAMPUS.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE OFFSET
THAT YOU'RE SEEKING HERE WITH
THE PREVAILING WAGES IS
SHIFTING.
THAT BENEFIT AWAY FROM THE
STUDENTS AND ONTO THE FINE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WERE IN THE
BUILDING TRADES WHICH.
WE FEEL YOU KNOW THEY SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE COMPENSATED IN THE
APPROPRIATE SITUATIONS.
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE APPROPRIATE SITUATIONS
BECAUSE IT COMES AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE STUDENTS AND THE
FACILITIES THAT WOULD BE BUILT.
WITHOUT MONEY WERE IT TO BE AT
THE LOWER COST SO THAT IS OUR
MAIN OBJECTIVE I THINK OUR MAIN
OBJECTION. I THINK THE OTHER
THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS IS
THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS THESE ARE NOT
FOR PROFIT VENTURES THESE ARE
NOT VENTURES THAT ARE. ON THEIR
TO BE MAKING MONEY AND THEREFORE
ARE GAINING SOME SORT PECUNIARY
ADVANTAGE IN THE MARKETPLACE DUE
TO THE LOWER INTEREST THESE OUR
SCHOOLS THESE ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
USING PUBLIC DOLLARS.
EDUCATE STUDENTS AND THE SAVINGS
THAT WE A CREW THROUGH THE LOWER
INTEREST RATES AGAIN ARE. GIVEN
TO THE STUDENTS
TO BETTER FACILITIES AND SO
THEREFORE WE OBJECT IN.
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND MY
APOLOGIES TO THE AUTHOR I HAVE
NOT BEEN BY HIS OFFICE TO SPEAK
WITH HIM LIFE GOT IN THE WAY.
AND IT WAS MY INTENTION TO DO SO
BUT I HADN'T BUT.
HITO FOR NOW WE WOULD OPPOSE IT
AND I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MR O'DONNELL ON
FINDING OTHER WAYS TO. HELP
ACCOMPLISH HIS GOALS IT WHILE
ACCOMPLISHING OURS AT THE SAME
TIME.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
I ALSO WISH TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WITH TRYING TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IS OUR MOTION.
I MOVE TO MOVE THE BILLS ARE
SECOND. THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SEE.
I'M NOT REQUIRED.
HELLO.
WHY WOULD YOU MESS WITH ME
TODAY?
SEEING NO.
SEE YEAH.
SEEN THAT THEY'RE KNOW QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
.
THROUGH DOT THE OTHER A MOTION
AND A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE DISRESPECT LAST NIGHT OF.
THANK YOU.
THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY PASS
RECOMMENDATION UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMONDAYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MATHIS.
THE BILL WAS OUT GRADUATION.
I HAVE BEEN DOING.
BACK OFFICE.
LET US.
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESENT THEIR BILLS.
GIVE THE MEMBERS A MOMENT TO
COMPOSE HIMSELF THE CARE.
THE. IN A MOTION FOR CONSENT
PLEASE.
AS MOTION AND SECOND FOR CONSENT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO THIRTY TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION CONSENT THURMAN.
AYE THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MATHIS.
CONSENT IS OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER HAS A FEW
BILLS TO PRESENT FOR US.
THIRTY EIGHTY EN THIRTY EIGHTY
ONE.
IF YOU.
TO.
WE READY WHEN YOU ARE.
SINCE I HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE
STILL IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
I LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED SOME OF
THE STRONGEST WORKER PROTECTIONS
IN THE COUNTRY.
PART OF THOSE LAWS ARE WORTHLESS
IF THEY CANNOT BE ENFORCED IN
OUR COURT OR BY STATE AGENCIES
BECAUSE EMPLOYERS FOR SOME
WORKERS STOOD SIGNED AWAY THEIR
RIGHTS. IN AN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT AS A CONDITION OF
THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
THIS INCLUDES VIOLATIONS SUCH AS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PAY INEQUITY
OUTRIGHT DISCRIMINATION AND
AGREE JUST LABOR VIOLATIONS LIKE
WAGE THAT.
MANDATING THAT EMPLOYEES GO TO
ARBITRATION IS A PRACTICE THAT
ALLOWS COMPANIES TO FORCE
EMPLOYEE COMPLAINTS INTO
SECRETIVE HEARINGS. WHICH HIDE
LABOR VIOLATIONS FROM THE PUBLIC
SILENCE VICTIMS WITH NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS AND OFTEN
PROTECT SERIAL OFFENDERS.
ARBITRATION CAN BE A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
METHOD WHEN BOTH PARTIES CHOOSE
A FREELY.
IT'S FAR LESS SUCCESSFUL WHEN
THE MORE POWERFUL PARTY FORCES
THE OTHER TO ACCEPT IT AS A
CONDITION OF GETTING A JOB.
THIS IS Y. A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
DOES NOT PROHIBIT EMPLOYERS FROM
USING ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS
RESOLVE WORKPLACE DISPUTES BUT
INSTEAD IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT
EMPLOYEES CHOOSE TO SIGN SUCH
AGREEMENTS.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY DOES NOT SEEK
TO RENDER EXISTING ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS UNENFORCEABLE.
IT SIMPLY PROVIDES INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF WHEN PLAYERS ARE FORCING
WORKERS TO WAIVE RIGHTS IN ORDER
PURSUE A JOB. KEEP A JOB.
OR INCREASE THEIR BENEFITS.
AS ADDITIONAL PROTECTION A. B.
THIRTY EIGHT INSURERS A WORKER
OR INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IS NOT
PROHIBITED FROM DISCLOSING ANY
INSTANCES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THAT THEY SUFFER OR DISCOVER IN
THE WORKPLACE IN ORDER TO PURSUE
OR KEEP A JOB AND EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
ALL CONTRACTS MUST BE VOLUNTARY
NOT THE RESULT OF COERCION INTO
NINE TO WORKERS THEIR LIVELIHOOD
ANY JOB THEY DO NOT SAVE SIGN A
WAIVER OF THEIR RIGHTS IS
ANYTHING BUT VOLUNTARY. THIS
BILL TAKES NECESSARY STEPS
TOWARDS PROTECTING EMPOWERING
VICTIMS IN THE WORKPLACE FROM
PORTION HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION HAVE A FEW FOLKS
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY. A
REPRESENTATIVE IN OUT OF WORKER
FROM THAT RESTAURANT
OPPORTUNITIES CENTER. AND.
KILLER BIGGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
IF YOU SEE MR CHEN MEMBERS
KITTEN BAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WHERE THE
SPONSORS OF THE SPELL.
WE AT THE LABOR FEDERATION HAVE
NO HOSTILITY TO ARBITRATION AS A
DISPUTE RESOLUTION MECHANISM WE
HAVE SEEN IT WORK VERY
EFFECTIVELY IN MANY CONTEXTS FOR
EXAMPLE BETWEEN UNIONS AND
EMPLOYERS WHERE THEY NEGOTIATE
THE WAY THAT IT WORKS THEY TAKE
TURNS STRIKING ARBITRATORS. AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO USE THAT PROCESS
VERY EFFECTIVELY MANY BUSINESSES
USE THAT WITH EACH OTHER AND
THEY'RE CERTAINLY EMPLOYEES WHO
MIGHT CHOOSE AGAIN. APPRECIATE
THE ARBITRATION PROCESS.
THE PROBLEM WE SEE TODAY IS THAT
SEVENTY PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
WORKERS DO NOT HAVE THAT CHOICE
THEY ARE FORCED INTO THE
EMPLOYERS ARBITRATION SYSTEM.
I'M WITHOUT ANY ABILITY TO
OBJECT RAISE QUESTIONS REFUSE IF
THEY REFUSE THEY CAN BE FIRED
THEY CAN BE DENIED THE JOB. ALL
THIS BILL SAYS IS THAT THESE
AGREEMENTS SHOULD BE CONSENSUAL
A WORKER SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
OPTION. THE ECONOMIC POLICY
INSTITUTE JUST TO RELEASED A
REPORT SHOWING THAT THE THREE
GROUPS THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
RATE OF BEING I'M FORCED INTO
ARBITRATION. ARE WOMEN WORKERS
AFRICAN AMERICAN WORKERS AND LOW
WAGE WORKERS HERBAL.
HARASSMENT TO DISCRIMINATION AND
TO WAGE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE WORKERS BEING FORCED INTO.
THE EMPLOYERS PRIVATE SECRET
SYSTEM WITH NO CHOICE FOR ANY
OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE.
THAT THE RESTAURANT
OPPORTUNITIES CENTER THAT
ROBERTO CAME ALL THE WAY HERE TO
TELL HIS STORY SO I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO THAT BIG.
I'M HELLO AGAIN MY NAME IS
EVELYN WITH EVIDENT I HAD MAYBE
NOW WITH THE REST ON OPPORTUNITY
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ESTIMATE THAT IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION RESTAURANT WORKERS
MOST OF WHICH ARE LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO INSURE THAT
THESE LOW WAGE WORKERS WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
ARE ABLE TO BE PROTECTED AND RE
ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS AND WE'RE
HERE WILL PREVENT THOUGH HE'S
SO.
GUY BUT THE.
THAT MEET IS HE'S ARE WORKER
LEADER FROM.
LA WHO WANTS TO SHARE I'M
HISTORY WITH THE.
AND I'M GONNA TRANSLATE FOR.
WELL LOW ENOUGH BURDENSOME IN
THE MIDDLE OF PROGRAM IF.
THANK GOD FOR AN INTERN. WILL UP
WANT TO SEE CAMINO NAVISTAR
ALTHOUGH IT HAS ARE STILL
AROUND.
SO REMEMBER THAT LOOK AT ME.
THERE IS. A LINE YOU KNOW
FAMILIAR FIFA'S.
YUP I QUE LINDO THOUGHT EVER
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT BUT. IF
YOU'RE TRYING OF.
THANK GOD YOU KNOW WE ESTIMATE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION RESTAURANT WORKERS.
I AM A MEMBER LEADER OF BROCCOLI
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN.
I WORKED IN THE REST HONEST
INDUSTRY FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
CARL'S JUNIOR. A COMPANY THAT
HAS A CORPORATE POLICY A MANDATE
TO HAVE WORKER SIDE.
FORCED ARBITRATION.
I WORKED IN CARL'S JUNIOR IN THE
KITCHEN. AS THE FOOD PREP.
AND AS A CASHIER FROM NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. TO TWENTY FIFTEEN.
LOOK AT HIM BLOWING GOD YOU'RE
NOT CLEAR ME OTHER.
BUT REMEMBER YOU.
MINCING LITTLE BECAUSE THE JOKE
BUT THEN THE OTHER AND IT TOOK.
ARE ARE YOU WORK FOR THEM IN
VOWED HE WOULD TOTAL WILL DEFEND
IDEA.
WOMAN I HAVE NEVER WON'T IN
CHECK THERE WERE NOTHING MURMUR.
IT KNOW CHAMELEON ME THEY'VE GOT
MORE THERE AND THE FACT.
DURING DURING MY.
EMPLOYMENT I. CARL'S JUNIOR I
WAS HUMILIATED BY MY MANAGER. I
WAS INSULTED AND TOLD THAT THEY
COULDN'T HAVE RIGHT.
I EXPERIENCE WAIT STAFF AND MY
ONE OF MY MANAGERS STOLE A WEEK.
A CHECK FOR A WEEK OF WORK.
AND I WAS NOT GIVEN MY PRESS
BRAKES AS REQUIRED.
OTHER FOLKS. LIVE IN MY WORK.
YOU KNOW BUT THEY ARE NOT THE
LOOK UP. LOOK AT THE MAN TO.
REPRESENT BUT NOT NUMB ENOUGH I
WANT CONCORD ENEMY THIS TIME I.
SOMETIMES I WOULD HAVE TO GO
INTO WORK SAKE.
BECAUSE I WAS THREATENED WITH
BEING FIRED IF I DIDN'T SHOW UP.
ONE THE DEVELOPMENTS IN IRAQ
THIS BOOK GROWTH ARMY MOMENT
ELEMENT SECOND UP OF THE FM I
HAVE A. BOOK DEL THOUGHTFUL
SILENCE LET ME LET MICHAEL BY
YEAR.
WHEN I BROUGHT MY CONCERNS TO MY
MANAGER.
THEY TOLD ME THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING I COULD DO BECAUSE THEY
WERE JUST FOLLOWING COMPANY
POLICY.
LOOKED AT DFW.
BUT I'M GLAD A LOOK AT ME
FAMILIAR SONG.
THE PRODUCT OR MOUNT PUBLIC
ALTHOUGH IF SADDAM IN A FILM
BUFF YOU KNOW BE BY.
IF YOU LIVE FOR YOU YOU HAVE A.
GOT ALL THE ACTOR PROPHET UNA
FIFTY INTO THEIR OWN WHILE THE
CHROMAFFIN MOM.
I AM HERE TODAY TO TALK TO SHARE
MY STORY AND SO THAT OTHER
WORKERS CAN COME OUT OF THE
SHADOWS AND DO NOT LIVE IN
SILENCE. AND WITH THE SHAME OF
HUMILIATION.
IN A CONDITION WHERE YOU FEEL
THE VALUE ADDED AS A HUMAN
BEING.
UNIVERSITY BOMBER FOOTBALL YOU
INVEST THE GUIDELINE TO GOD THAT
LITTLE* WOULD LOOK UP AT THE
LACKEY. EITHER BUT THE CARE HINT
THAT.
OR WERE YOU KNOW.
THE UNDERTOW OF NEW YOU KNOW.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF DRIVE OUR
FOURTH.
NOTE THOUGH THAT IT'S A NO VOTE
ON THEM.
ONE IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE AND
THAT FIFTH NUMBER FOUR THOUGHT.
REFORM FOUNDER OF.
WE NEED TO INVESTIGATE THE
ILLEGALITY.
A FORCED ARBITRATION.
AND PROTECT PEOPLE WORKING
PEOPLE LIKE ME.
WHOSE LIVE THE DEPEND ON OUR
DOGS
.
VOTE.
YOUR BROTHER LITTLE OVERDONE IT.
THUNDERBOLT DUMP IF.
IF IF BERMAN REPORTS OF.
WHAT FORWARD LIVE BE LOOKED UP
OR YOU CAN LOOK YOU KNOW FEEL?
UP IT DIDN'T BURKE CHEN BAR.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT YOUR PRODUCT
WHICH OUT OF IT NEW FIFTY
MILLIMETER.
OUR OUR LABOR RIGHTS ARE
IMPORTANT AND THEY NEED TO BE
PROTECTED.
I PLEASE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT.
LEGISLATION THIRD A. B. THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO MY STORY.
THAT'S JUST PART OF BEING A THE
APPLY THIS WHO IS SPEEDY AND SEE
A CRISIS WITH ABOUT.
THE BOTTOM LIP FOR THE.
MORE YOUR MIND UP.
LOVE LOVE THAT FILM.
METHOD COULD NOT.
LIKE GOTHIC LEFT TO BE A FEW
ENOUGH TO PROFIT.
THE YOUNG OF GET A KICK OUT THE
LITTLE REFERRAL FEES.
YOU'RE LUCKY IF IT FINALLY GOT.
AND I LOOSE IF A BROTHER FOR
THEIR FOOD THAT IT.
THEY LOOK GOOD.
WHAT HAPPENED THE WAY I WAS
TREATED WAS VERY HUMILIATING
AND?
I DON'T WANT TO BE I WANT FOR
OTHER ABOUT THAT I MEAN IS TO
EXPERIENCE FOR OTHER WORKERS TO
EXPERIENCE THIS.
AND SO THAT THEY CAN COME OUT TO
THE LIGHT AND ENFORCE THEIR
RIGHTS.
BROOKE.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSONALLY IN
TRENTON REPRESENTING CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS THE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER RAMIREZ. NO
WORKER SHOULD EVER HAVE TO FEAR
RETALIATION FOR REFUSING TO GIVE
UP HIS OR HER LEGAL RIGHTS.
THANK YOU.
YOUR MEMBERS AS EARLY AS A WE
HAVE THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT DOES IT US AIRFORCE ABOUT
INDIA AND COMPETITIVE SO I JUST
GO CENTER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT? THANK YOU.
VERY CLEAR SHE HIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MARY CHRIS WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF SIDE
AFTER THE TEAMSTERS UNITED HERE
THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
UTILITY WORKERS UNION COLLEGE
SPORTS. MAKE YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSE THE CHAIR OF THE
COLLEGE REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
INSTRUCT SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS CHVEZ ON BEHALF
UNITED FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RENEE BYARDO IS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT MAKE
YOU.
YOUR NUMBERS KEVIN BACON FOR THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA I THINK YOU WILL
SHORTLY HEAR THE OPPOSITION SAY
THAT ARBITRATION IS FAIRER
FASTER AND CHEAPER FOR WORKERS.
NOT SURE THAT THAT'S TRUE BUT IF
IT IS I THINK EMPLOYEES CAN
CHOOSE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS MY
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS OVER JUNIOR ARM.
SURE COME INTERIM IN SUPPORT. OF
JUST ONE READ THIS BOOK.
ASSEMBLYMAN SENTIMENT FOR
ARBITRATION IS INTERVENTION.
THE DEFINITION OF INTERVENTION
THE ACTUAL PROCESS OF
INTERVENING.
ARE AN EXAMPLE INTERFERENCE BY
COUNTRY INTO ANOTHER'S AFFAIRS.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS REPORTED
TO BE CONSIDERING MILITARY
INTERVENTION.
ACTUAL DEFINITION ARBITRATION IS
ONE OF THE VARIOUS METHODS THAT
TOGETHER. ARE REFERRED TO AS
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
OR EDR.
AS SUGGESTED BY THE NAME THE
IDEA BEHIND METHODS OF AB ARE IS
TO PROVIDE AN ALTERNATIVE TO
FILING A LAWSUIT. AND GOING TO
COURT.
WHICH IS THE TRADITIONAL METHOD
FOR RESOLVING LEGAL DISPUTES.
WE SIMPLY WOULD ASK RESPECTIVELY
THAT THE DO MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THAT WE WOULD TURN THE RIGHTS OF
ALL CITIZENS OF THE U. S. THAT
HAVE GIVEN THEIR ALL IN
SUPPORTING THE LAWS PROTECTIONS
AND RIGHTS OF ALL WORKERS. AND
CITIZENS.
BY ABANDONING FORCED MANDATORY
ARBITRATION.
THANK YOU
IF YOU.
SANDI PERRY JETER ARE AYE ECHO
THE OF VOICE OF THOMAS AS WORKER
AND HIS* ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
DUE PROCESS IN AB THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAID IS
SYMBOLIC OF FROM OUR WEST AFRICA
ABANG A LIVING IN AND NOW I WORK
IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY PHONE
WAS HE LIVING IS. IN A STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT MANY OF THE WITNESSES OF
WAITED LONG PERIODS OF TIME
TODAY TO TESTIFIED WILL ALSO
EXTEND THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME
TO THE OPPOSITION.
DO YOU
I IS THERE OPPOSITION IF SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THE MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER BROWN HAVE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED A. B. THIRTY
EIGHTY I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WAS
RAISED. BY THE PROPONENTS FOR
SOME OF THE.
ISSUES THAT WERE DISCUSSED BY
THE WITNESS OUR LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS IN THOSE ALREADY
AGAINST THE LAW AND THEY SHOULD
BE. ON DEL WITHIN RESOLVES.
WHETHER IT'S IN COURT OR
ARBITRATION.
ARBITRATION DOESN'T CHANGE THAT
SO THERE WAS A DISCUSSION THAT
SAID THAT.
OUR LABOR LAWS ARE ONLY GOOD IF
THEY CAN BE ENFORCED IN THAT
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS ARE
SOMEHOW WAIVING THOSE RIGHTS
THERE'S THAT SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT DECISION THAT
SPECIFICALLY SAY. ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS CANNOT WAIT THE
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS THAT ARE
OFFERED IN THE LAW YOU CAN'T DO
IT.
IF THEY ARE THERE ON FORCIBLE
ALREADY IN THERE NOT A BALLOT
ARE BETWEEN. SO YOU CANNOT WAIT
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS ON THE COURTS
WILL STRIKE THOSE DOWN ON THERE
ISN'T ALSO DISCUSSION THAT THIS
WAS SOMEHOW A SECRET FORUM. A IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY THERE IS
CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE SECTION
TWELVE NINETY FOUR OF EIGHTY
NINE NOW. FOR NINETY ONE POINT
NINETY SIX SOMETHING LIKE THAT
ANYWAYS IT'S IN THE CODE OF
CIVIL PROCEDURE TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE POINT NINETY SIX.
AND IT'S
WE REQUIRES EVERY ARBITRATION
COMPANY THAT CONDUCTS
ARBITRATIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO POST A QUARTERLY SEARCHABLE
SPREADSHEET. THAT SETS FORTH THE
IDENTITY OF THE PARTIES THE
IDENTITY OF THE ATTORNEYS THE
ALLEGATIONS AT ISSUE.
WHAT'S HOW THE CASE WAS
RESOLVED AND IF ANY OF THE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN AN
ARBITRATION BEFORE IF ANY OF THE
POP UP PLAINTIFFS HAVE BEEN AN
ARBITRATION BEFORE ANY OF THE
ATTORNEYS HAVE BEEN ARBITRATION
BEFORE. HOW MUCH THE DAMAGES
REQUEST WERE HOW MUCH WITH
ULTIMATELY GIVEN HOW LONG IT
TOOK FOR THE ARBITRATION TO TAKE
PLACE THAT IS A A QUARTERLY
REPORT? THAT'S POSTED ON THE
WEBSITE OF EVERY ARBITRATION
COMPANY WHO CONDUCTS
ARBITRATIONS HERE YOU WOULD
NEVER FIND A COME A PARABLE
REPORT FOR THE COURTS IF YOU
WANTED TO CREATE THAT SAME
DOCUMENT. YOU WOULD HAVE TO GO
COURT TO COURT TO COURT IN ALL
OF THE COUNTIES AND TRY TO
GATHER THAT INFORMATION TOGETHER
YOU WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO FIND
THAT INFORMATION CORDON SO
ACTUALLY. ARBITRATION HEARING
CALIFORNIA IS A MORE OPEN FORUM
WITH MORE INFORMATION THAT'S
PROVIDED IN COURT THERE'S ALWAYS
A DISCUSSION THAT THEY NEED
THEIR DAY IN COURT. IN IN NINETY
OVER NINETY PERCENT OF THE CASES
THEY SETTLE THE PLAINTIFF FOR
INDIVIDUAL NEVER ACTUALLY SEES
THE COURTROOM IF IT'S A CLASS
ACTION THERE'S EVEN LESS CHANCE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET TO A
COURTROOM. SO ARBITRATION
ACTUALLY HAS A MORE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS WITH REGARDS
TO THE INFORMATION AND THE
PARTIES INVOLVED THEN DOES I'M
OUR COURT SYSTEM RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER POINT THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED A COUPLE OF TIMES AND I
THINK IN THE FACT SHEET WAS
THAT.
THAT THE ARBITRATION.
WEEPY THE ARBITRATORS AND SO
HOT SOMEHOW IT'S A BIAS SYSTEM
UP THE LAW SAYS THAT COMPANIES
HAVE TO PAY FOR ARBITRATION IF
THERE WAS A.
OPPORTUNITY TO SPLIT THE FEES
COMPANIES WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SHARE THE FEES BUT BY LIVE WERE
FORCED TO PAY FOR THE
ARBITRATION.
A LOT OF THE ARBITRATORS ARE
RETIRED JUDGES ON THERE'S ALWAYS
A DISCUSSION ABOUT A RIGHT TO
APPEAL THE ALLOWED FORTY SETS
FORTH THE GROUNDS FROM WHICH YOU
CAN APPEAL A DECISION.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WITH
REGARDS TO ARBITRATION OVER THE
LAST POINT ON THE ARBITRATOR'S
THANK YOU I'M IN ARBITRATION
THERE'S ALSO A REQUIREMENT IN
THE QUIKSILVER SEIZURE THAT THE
ARBITRATOR BEFORE THEY EVEN GET
PICKED TO BE AN ARBITRATOR.
HOUSE TO DISCLOSE BASICALLY
EVERY RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY
POSSIBLY COULD HAVE HAD WITH
ANYBODY INVOLVED IN THE
ARBITRATION IF THEY HAVE.
HAD A CASE IN WHICH THE COMPANY
WAS INVOLVED IN THE ARBITRATION
HOW THEY DECIDED THAT CASE
THAT'S AN UNDERGOING DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AGAIN THOSE SAME
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT
REQUIRED FOR JUDGES SO A JUDGE
COULD HAVE DECIDED THE CASE FOR
A COMPANY THE DAY BEFORE. AND
THE PLANE OF COMING INTO THAT
CASE NEXT THEY WOULD NEVER KNOW
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS SO AGAIN
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED I DON'T THINK
ARE. RELEVANT WITH REGARDS TO
THIS ACT CALIFORNIA LAW THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE IN THE LAST
POINT IS. THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT IT'S PROBABLY
PREEMPTED THE CASES BEEN VERY
STRONG FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS
FROM THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT FOR EVERY CASE HAD GONE UP
TO THE SUPREME COURT. THAT
ANYTIME A STATE STATUTE TRIES TO
LIMIT PROHIBIT BAN ARBITRATION
IT'S PREEMPTED THERE'S A BILL
PENDING RIGHT NOW AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BIPARTISAN BILL THAT SEEKS
TO PROHIBIT. I'M SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS FROM GOING
THROUGH OR BEING A PART OF THE
FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT THAT'S
WHERE THE DISCUSSION IS STATE
ATTORNEY GENERALS HAVE WEIGHED
IN AND SAID. EVERYBODY SHOULD
SUPPORT THAT PROVISION
THE FEDERAL ISSUE THAT SHOULD BE
WHERE THE DISCUSSION IS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU DISSOLUTION YES MISTER
MEMBERS JOHN DORY ABOUT THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA WANNA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. OF THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IS BRINGING
FORWARD AN IMPORTANT PROBLEM
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF IT ON IT
NEEDS ATTENTION FOCUS AN ACTUAL
SOLUTIONS. ON BUT UNFORTUNATELY
EVERY PROPOSED SOLUTION IS NOT
THE RIGHT ONE FOR THE ALL THE
PARTIES INVOLVED.
AS WRITTEN A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
CREATES AN ANTENNA BITE
UNTENABLE DYNAMIC IT UNDERCUTS
THE ABILITY TO SETTLE CASES. ON
AND PROHIBITS NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS EVEN WHEN BOTH
PARTIES DESIRE THEM.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF FILED
CIVIL LITIGATION IS SETTLED BY
VOLUNTEERING BILLION AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE PRO PARTY'S.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG HAD A SMART
IN IMPORTANT POLICY THAT
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGES SETTLEMENT
THAT REDUCES CONFLICT.
BECAUSE AMICALE AMICABLE
RESOLUTION IS THE BEST WAY TO
HANDLE THESE THINGS ARM AND ON
TOP OF THAT IT PRESERVES VERY
IMPORTANT.
PRECIOUS PUBLIC RESOURCES UP
SECTION FOR IN THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY UNDERCUTS THE
ABILITY TO SETTLE A CASE.
ON THE OTHER.
THE EFFECTIVE PROHIBITION WHICH
MAY BE INTENTIONAL BUT THE
EFFECT OF PROHIBITION IN THE
BILL ON NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS IS ALSO PROBLEMATIC.
ON THE CALVET CALIFORNIA FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING CLAIMS OF
SOME OF THE MOST SENSITIVE
ISSUES THAT ARE LITIGATED TODAY
AND ELIMINATING ANDY A IS WILL
NOT PROTECT CLAIMANTS.
FOR THOSE REASONS AND THE
REASONS ARTICULATED BY THE.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOVA.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHES. ARE AND
ON IN OPPOSITION.
RICHARD MAY I JUST ADD ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT ON THE ISSUE OF
FAA PREEMPTION.
SO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
GOVERNOR VETOED A SIMILAR
MEASURE THAT WOULD HAVE
PROHIBITED ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IN AND OF THE
EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT. AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT.
AND THE GOVERNOR IN VETOING THAT
MEASURE CITED SOME PENDING U. S.
SUPREME COURT LITIGATION.
AND SHORTLY THEREAFTER IN
DECEMBER THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
ISSUED ITS DECISION IN DIRECT TV
VERSES AMBROSIA.
WHICH CRITICIZE A CALIFORNIA
FOR DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
CONSUMER ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS.
AND THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
SAID.
CALIFORNIA PLAYED AN INVALID
STATE LAW TO ONLY ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS AND NO OTHER
CONTRACTS AND SUCH AN
APPLICATION WOULD NOT PLACE
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS ON EQUAL
FOOTING WITH OTHER CONTRACTS AND
THEREFORE WAS PREEMPTED BY
FEDERAL LAW. ADDITIONALLY LAST
SPRING IN THE KINDRED NURSING
HOMES CASE.
WRITTEN BY JUSTICE KAGAN
CERTAINLY NOT A MEMBER OF THE
CONSERVATIVE WING OF THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT.
RULED IN A KENTUCKY CASE
I ALSO PREEMPTION SO THE MOST
RECENT DECISIONS OF THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT HAVE CLEARLY
STATED. AS.
MISS BARRERA INDICATED THAT
ANYTIME THAT YOU TREAT
ARBITRATION DIFFERENTLY THAN
OTHER TYPES OF CONTRACTS THEY
ARE PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW
THERE FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS
MEASURE CAN PASS MUSTER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION.
ANKARA CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MICHAEL RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WERE POSE FOR ALL
THE REASONS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
STATED THEY CAN THANK YOU.
JOHN LEWIS OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION SEEN NONE
I'M TRYING TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SO REMEMBER KALRA.
THINK YOU I'M I I THINK IT
GIVING THE OPTION.
IF ARBITRATION IS AS GOOD AS
STOPS IN CLAIMS COMMITTEE OPTION
WORKERS TO CHOOSE IT.
I THINK THEY'LL BE.
FALLING OVER EACH OTHER TO
CHOOSE ARBITRATION.
A BUT BUT THAT I'M NOT GONNA GO
I I'D BE HAPPY TO. THE REFORM
DEBATE AS A DEBATE OPPOSITION ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE.
THINK INTO IT CAN GILLESPIE'S
MY EMPLOYER SKILLS AT ALL IS
OFTEN AS I USED TO ENJOY. BUT.
IN ANY CASE I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL.
AND WE JUST LIKE TO. THANK THE
AUTHOR EXITING THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. ARM.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD UP ALTHOUGH IT IS IT'S A
CHALLENGING ONE TO BRING POOR
BECAUSE IT DOES BRING WITH IT A
LOT OF FUN UP OPPOSITION BUT I
THINK. THE REALITY IS THAT I I
THINK THAT THE END OF THE DAY
THE ACTUAL IMPACT.
UP ON EMPLOYERS I THINK WILL BE
NOMINAL BUT THE IMPACT ON
WORKERS WILL BE SIGNIFICANT A A
AND I THINK ULTIMATELY.
WE ALL WANT TO HAVE WORKPLACES
WHERE THE WORKERS AND THE
EMPLOYERS ARE HARMONIOUS AND AND
WORK WELL.
WILL WITH ONE ANOTHER BY THAT'S
ALWAYS THE CASE AND IN. THOSE
CASES I THINK THAT THE THE
WORKER XIN OF OPTIONS AS TO HOW
THEY CHOOSE TO PROCEED. THEIR
GRIEVANCES JUST AS EMPLOYERS TO
HARPER KNOW HOW THOSE OPTIONS
AND.
OFTENTIMES HIM BACK GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE AND OUR
CONTRACTS BUT ARBITRATION AND
THERE. ARE NOT FORCED TO DO SO
WHEN THEY DO THEIR PRIVATE
PRIVATE. A INTERACTIONS AND SO I
JUST LIKE TO THANK MISS RAMIREZ
AT THE KEY MAY BE MAY HAVE
STEPPED OUT. OF FOUR OF FOR HIS
COURAGE
OF LOSING YOUR REMAINS GLASSES
PERSON UNLOAD. OUR COMPETITORS
WHO ASTORIA PERSONAL PERSONALLY
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
PERSONAL STORY I WAS VERY
MEANINGFUL. AND WITH THAT I'M OF
THE.
A MOTION AND A SECOND I'LL
SECOND IT.
WOULD YOU CARE CLOSE
I JUST SAY THAT I'M THIS BILL
HAS BEEN NARROWLY TAILORED IN A
WAY THAT WE THINK WILL WILL AND
WITHSTAND JUDICIAL SCRUTINY.
THAT DOES NOT INVALIDATE AN
EXISTING ARBITRATION AGREEMENT
DOESN'T SEEK TO DO SO OR ANY
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT WHAT SEEKS
TO DO IS.
PREVENT THAT TO BE A CONDITION
OF EMPLOYMENT GOING FORWARD AND
ALLOW INJUNCTIVE RELIEF TO
PREVENT OUT SO.
.
I APPRECIATE THE MOTION SECOND
MY RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I MET.
THANK YOU.
THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMOND AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA KNOW
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. AYE CONSULTS
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
MCCARTY MATHIS.
THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRADULATIONS.
IF YOU WISH TO PROCEED WITH AB
THIRTY EIGHTY ONE YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THE ME TOO MOMENT IT'S GOT A
LONG WAY TO FOR THE DIALOGUE ON
HOW TO BETTER PROTECT WORKERS
FROM SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE
WORKPLACE
HOWEVER THE EXPERIENCE OF
WORKERS IN. AGRICULTURE OUT
AGRICULTURE HOSPITALITY RETAIL
RESTAURANT JANITORIAL IN OTHER
SERVICE INDUSTRIES ARE FAR TOO
OFTEN LET OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION.
PERPETRATORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THESE INDUSTRIES TEND
AVOID BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE OF SUCH STARK WAGE AND
POWER DIFFERENCES.
THE WORKERS THEY HARASS FEAR
BEING RETALIATE AGAINST OR BEING
THREATENED DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS OR BECAUSE
THEY SIMPLY NEED THEIR PAYCHECK.
AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THOSE LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE WOMEN
AND LEAST A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
WOMEN OF COLOR. THEY'RE THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO HAVING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD THREATENED WHEN THEY
SUFFER SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT IN THE WORKPLACE.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY ONE TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE THREAT
RETALIATION AS A BARRIER FOR
WORKERS TRYING TO SECURE SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN THE WORKPLACE
AFTER FACING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE A WORKER
HAS AT LEAST THREE YEARS TO FILE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT RETALIATE.
RELATED RETALIATION CLAIM.
WORKER CHOOSES TO FILE A CLAIM
THE BILL ESTABLISH A NINETY DAY
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION OF
UNLAWFUL RETALIATION
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WILL HOLD
LABOR CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE BY
REQUIRING CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
CASES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
ASSAULT AND DISCRIMINATION.
UNDER THE SPELL WORKERS WOULD
HAVE TO WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A
HOTLINE TO REPORT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS TO LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. AND MEANS
TO SUBMIT A WRITTEN COMPLAINT
THAT ALLOWS A WORKER THE OPTION
TO REMAIN ANONYMOUS.
FINALLY THIRTY EIGHTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS WITH AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES TO PROVIDE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING TO
ALL EMPLOYEES EVERY TWO YEARS.
THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES A
REQUIREMENT FOR EMPLOYERS TO
REGULARLY NOTIFY THEIR EMPLOYEES
OF THEIR RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS
REGARDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT. I
THINK THIS IS MUCH NEEDED WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT SEX
THIS IS ABOUT POWER AND IN
INDUSTRIES WHERE THE POWER
DIFFERENTIAL IS THAT MUCH BIGGER
IT'S. EVEN MORE NECESSARY.
I RESPECT LAST NIGHT THAT.
THANK YOU WHICH GUY FIRST
WITNESS MISTER CHAIRMAN BRUCE
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR UP FEDERATION. WE WORKED
WITH MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER TO TRY
TO IDENTIFY GAPS IN THE LAW THAT
WE THOUGHT WERE ON PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO PROTECTING SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE WOMEN
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL
WORKERS WHO FACE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. ON THE JOB AND IN
PARTICULAR WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
ISSUE OF RETALIATION IS ALWAYS
CENTRAL IF WORKERS CANNOT COME
FORWARD AND REPORT VIOLATIONS
NOTHING WILL EVER CHANGE.
AND SO WE THOUGHT THAT
EXTENDING SOME OF THESE
PROTECTIONS AROUND RETALIATION
GIVING WORKERS MORE TIME TO COME
FORWARD. AND IT MAKING IT EASIER
TO ESTABLISH THAT YOU WERE
RETALIATED AGAINST BECAUSE YOU
COMPLAINED ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AS EVERYONE KNOWS
MOST WORKERS ARE OUT WILL CAN BE
FIRED AT ANY TIME FOR ANY
REASON.
SO YOU FILE A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIM YOU GET FIRED AND YOU SAVE
THE WILL THAT'S NOT FAIR YOU'VE
YOU FIRED ME BECAUSE I REPORTED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THEY SAY
NO WE FREDDIE BECAUSE YOU RELATE
ONCE WITH REGGIE BECAUSE WITHIN
LIKE.
THE WAY YOU ACTED YESTERDAY YOU
CAN BE FIRED FOR ANY REASON THE
BOSS HAS NO OBLIGATION TO PROVE
I THAT THERE WAS A A COULD
REASON FOR GETTING RID OF YOU SO
IT'S VERY EASY TO RETALIATE
AGAINST WORKERS.
WHO FILE THOSE KINDS OF CLAIMS
ARE ALSO OF COURSE WORKERS IN
THE SUB CONTRACTED ECONOMY WE'VE
SEEN A HUGE RISE IN THE USE OF
TEMP WORKERS AND CONTRACT
WORKERS?
AND THOSE WORKERS ARE ALSO VERY
VULNERABLE FOR THESE KINDS OF
ABUSES AND WE'RE SAYING TO
EMPLOYERS IF YOU WANNA USE LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO SUPPLY YOUR
WORKFORCE YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE NOT COMMITTING.
SEXUAL ASSAULT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
OR DISCRIMINATION AGAINST THOSE
WORKERS THAT'S OF THIS BUT
THAT'S THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTER SAG AFTRA UNITE
HERE MACHINIST.
OF THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
OTHERS HOLLAND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ES MISS VEGA POINTED OUT THE
RETALIATION A REALLY IS WHAT
PREPARE PERPETUATES THE FEAR OF
RETALIATION IN THE WORKPLACE WE
SAW THAT IN ALL OF THEIR.
HOLLYWOOD CASES.
PEOPLE WERE AFRAID TO COME
FORWARD
BECAUSE THEY WERE FEARFUL THAT
THEIR CAREER WOULD BE ENDED NOT
JUST FIRED FROM THEIR CURRENT
JOB BUT JUST DON IN THE INDUSTRY
SO. THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND WE ARE TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT. NICOLAS CHVEZ
ON BEHALF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TIFFANY PULLEYBLANK WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
MEGAN SUPERSONIC OVER THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
PLAN TROUT NO BEHALF OF CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'RE NAY BAYARDO SEIU
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD YOUR CHARLOTTE THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES OF
JUSTICE DINNER IN SUPPORT OF
THOSE ADDING ON IN SUPPORT SEEN
NONE ZERO OPPOSITION.
THE SUPPORT.
I NEVER ASSUME THAT IS
OPPOSITION AND THEN. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION.
BUT WE WELCOME THE OPPOSITION.
HELLO GOOD EVENING THIS TIME
LARA CURTIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND.
THIS IS ALREADY PROTECTED UNDER
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT AND AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WENT THROUGH THAT THEIR
RETALIATION FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS IS PROTECTED
UNDER THE LAW THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT
SPECIFICALLY STATES. THAT
RETALIATION IS NOT A LOT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL MAKES A CLAIM FOR
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION YOU
CANNOT RETALIATE AGAINST AN
EMPLOYEE FOR MAKING THOSE
CLAIMS.
AND ADDITIONALLY THE SPECIFIC.
ASPECTS OF THIS BILL ALSO STATE
VERY.
BUT THERE'S TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS NOTICE REQUIREMENTS
ALL OF THOSE REGARDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AGAIN THOSE ARE
ALREADY IN THE PROVISIONS OF THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT. AND
ADDITIONALLY MRS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER HAD A PREVIOUS BILL
REGARDING AND.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
DISCRIMINATION AND LAST YEAR
GOVERNOR BROWN IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE SAID I BELIEVE THESE
TYPES OF CLAIMS SHOULD REMAIN
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING. AND THAT BILL WAS ALSO
PUTTING THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AND CLAIMS IN THE LABOR CODE AND
AGAIN HE TOOK ONCE AGAIN STATED
THAT IT SHOULD BE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING JURISDICTION. SO THOSE
ARE SOME OF OUR CONCERNS AGAINST
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION CONCERN
BECAUSE IF YOU MAKE A CLAIM FOR
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY YOU STILL
FROM YOUR EMPLOYER THERE IS A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
YOU'RE FIRED BECAUSE OF THE
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION UNDER
THIS BILL. BUT IF YOU AND THE
THEATER THEREFORE THE EMPLOYER
COULD NOT ACTUALLY TERMINATE YOU
FOR BECAUSE REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE CAUSES IF YOU DO HAVE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION SO THAT
DOES CAUSE SOME CONCERN FOR US.
ADDITIONALLY THEIR JOINT
LIABILITY FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND BECAUSE ALL EMPLOYERS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNMENT ALL
EMPLOYERS THAT HAVE FIVE MORE
EMPLOYEES ARE AND COVERED BY THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING SO EVEN
THESE JOINT CONTRACTORS THE.
INDIVIDUAL OR THE COMPANIES
WHAT ARE TO BE COVERED BY FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT AND SO
IT.
THERE'S NO WAY FOR SOMEONE ELSE
THAT'S CONTRACTING WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE.
COMPLYING WITH THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT THEY THEY
CANNOT OVERSEE THESE INDIVIDUALS
THOSE INDIVIDUAL THOSE EMPLOYER
SHOULD BE HELD LIABLE
SEPARATELY.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND WE APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON EVENING
WAS VERY MEMBERS AS SEAN DOES
THE NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING. OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
HERE IN OPPOSITION AS WELL FOR
ALL THE REASONS VERY WELL
ARTICULATED JUST NOW.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR MEMBERS THAT AND
IF I BE.
I HAVE BETWEEN THREE AND TEN
EMPLOYEES AND AS I PREVIOUSLY
DESCRIBED EARLIER IN THE
COMMITTEE I THAT WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR OUR MEMBERS AND SO MANY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS IS THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE AN ENTIRE HR
DEPARTMENT OR LOOKED AT OR
COMPLIANCE DEPARTMENT LEGAL
DEPARTMENT THEY DON'T HAVE
ATTORNEYS AND A LOT OF EXPERTS
AROUND THEM I'M EXPLAINING IN
NAVIGATING ALL OF A VERY COMPLEX
LABOR LAWS. AND UNFORTUNATELY I
WE VIEW THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL A CONFUSION IN THE
LAW SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO
THE DEEP PIT DUPLICATIVE NATURE
OF ADDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PROTECTIONS AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS DIRECTLY INTO THE
LABOR CODE ITSELF. OF SUBTLY
CONFUSING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
BUT ALSO OPERATE OPENS OUR
MEMBERS.
TO ADDITIONAL AND A WHOLE NEW
WAVE OF LAWSUITS UNDER PAGA
WHICH WE ON A SEPARATE ISSUE
THINK IS OVERDUE FOR REFORM
ITSELF. BUT IT CERTAINLY. ADDS
TO THE REASON THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS CONSISTENTLY RANKED AS THE
NUMBER ONE JUDICIAL HELL HOLE IN
THE NATION FOR SEVERAL YEARS
NOW.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER.
LET THIS BILL DOESN'T ADD
THAT'S AN OFFICIAL RANKING I CAN
SEND YOU THE COMMITTEE. AND IT
IS FOR THE AMERICAN TORT REFORM
ASSOCIATION SOUTH WHEN YOU HAVE
A LIGHT ON IMPUGN OUR STATE.
.
IT'S NOT MY WORDS BUT THERE TO
THE LEGISLATION AT HAND. THANK
YOU.
THE RANKING ASIDE.
WHEN YOU JUST BOIL IT DOWN AND
CONSIDER THAT THIS BILL REALLY
WHEN WRITTEN LINES DOESN'T ADD
ANY PROTECTIONS BEYOND WHAT FEEL
HOT OR D. FE H. ALREADY PROVIDE.
SUCH AS COMPENSATORY DAMAGES
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF PUNITIVE
DAMAGES AND ATTORNEY'S FEES
INSTEAD ONLY ADDS COMPLICATION
PATIL POTENTIAL LITIGATION A
SPECIAL OR SMALL BUSINESS JOB
CREATORS ARE WE DO UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION.
SEE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO YOU DON'T
HAVE.
ALL THAT WE MUST.
NICOLE RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST THANK YOU.
KATIE KANSEN RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION OF POST BAKE YOU. UP
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST TWO
SMALL THINGS AND IF YOU STILL
FROM YOUR EMPLOYER THAT GIVES
THE EMPLOYER.
THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
THEY FIRED YOU FOR SUCH A
HARASSMENT I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
A PRETTY CLEAR CASE RIGHT IT'S A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
MEANS EMPLOYER COME IN AND SAY
HEY YOU STOLE FROM ME AND IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT YOU
CLAIMED.
I'M SO I AM NOT SURE HOW.
HOW THAT TAKES AWAY A RITE OF
EMPLOYER THE OTHER THING THAT?
ARGUE IN AND ONE THE REASONS I
REALLY LIKE THE LABOR CODE.
IS I DON'T THINK IT IT WILL
INCREASE LITIGATION IN FACT THE
HUT IT YOU KNOW IS A TOOL FOR
LITIGATION IT ACTUALLY ALLOWS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
IT ALLOWS AT AN INDIVIDUAL
WORKER TO SEEK REMEDY THROUGH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
TOOL AS WELL ON ONE WHICH.
SOME WORKERS A WORKER
REPRESENTATIVES ARE MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND SO I I WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND
THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS AND SO
THAT IS WHY WE.
DOUBLE THAT BASICALLY SAU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I BET.
TAKE YOU THIS BILL AT THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THURMAN AYE THURMAN
AYE FLORA. FLORA NO GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE CONSULTS BUT YOU'RE
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MATHIS.
THAT BILLS OUT CONGRATULATIONS.
I THINK IT.
SUMMIT MEMBER JONES SAWYER WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY NINE.
YES WE ARE WELCOME SIR.
SO WHEN I STARTED SAID GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SO I WILL NOW
SAY GOOD EVENING MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE WERE
REQUIRED CANNABIS LICENSE
APPLICANT PROVIDE A STATEMENT
ALONG WITH THEIR APPLICATION
AFFIRMING THAT THEY WILL EMPLOY
ONE EMPLOYEE. AND ONE SUPERVISOR
TRAIN AND CAL OSHA.
SPECIFICALLY DISPEL RICARDO
EMPLOYEES TO CAL OSHA THIRTY
HOURS GENERAL INDUSTRY TRAINING
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THE
CANDIDATES APPLICANT RECEIVING
THEIR LICENSE.
AT THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY GROWS
IT SHOULD BE A PRIORITY THAT
CANVASSED BUSINESSES ARE
FAMILIAR WITH CALIFORNIA'S
WORKPLACE SAFETY REGULATIONS IN
ORDER TO PREVENT NEEDLESS HARM
TO WORKERS.
REGARDLESS.
ACQUIRING EMPLOYEES TO BE
TRAINED IN CALLOSUM.
STANDARDS WILL ENSURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND WORKPLACE SAFETY.
WORKERS RIGHTS RESPONSIBILITIES
OF EMPLOYERS AND HOW TO FILE
COMPLAINTS.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
IMPORTANT MEASURE IS.
JAZZY.
JEFF THE GROW FROM UFCW WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU WHAT TEN WITNESS.
AND MEMBERS GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS
A GRANDMA AND I
AROUND PATH OF UFCW WESTERN
STATES COUNSEL. REPRESENTING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND WORKERS INCLUDING MANY
WORKING IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
RIGHT IT REGULATING CANNABIS IS
UNIQUE NEVER BEFORE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE HAS A
WIDESPREAD INDUSTRY LONG SKILLED
AT OPERATING OUTSIDE THE LAW.
ALL THE SIDE IN BECOME LEGAL AND
EXPECTED TO COMPLY WITH ALL
LAWS.
INCLUDING CRITICAL WORKPLACE
SAFETY LAWS THAT PREVENT MY
MEMBERS AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
FROM DYING BEING INJURED ARE
FALLING ILL.
JUST SOME OF THE HOUSES IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY INCLUDE HE LNS
CARBON MONOXIDE FROM THE USE OF
FUEL BURNING EQUIPMENT.
FLAMMABLE CHEMICAL HAZARDS WHILE
PERFORMING EXTRACTIONS
ECCENTRIC.
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE REPEATEDLY
ATTESTED TO THIS NEW INDUSTRIES
LACK OF AWARENESS OF THE CALLERS
TO PROGRAM. BASIC EMPLOYER
WORKER RESPONSIBILITIES AND
WORKERS RIGHTS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE
APPLICANTS FOR ANY TYPE OF
CANNABIS LICENSE. TO USE PROVIDE
A STATEMENT THAT THE APPLICANT
EMPLOYEES OR WILL EMPLOY WITHIN
ONE YEAR OF RECEIVING A LICENSE
JUST ONE SUPERVISOR AND JUST ONE
EMPLOYEE. WHO WILL HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THE
CALLER CHAU THIRTY OUR GENERAL
INDUSTRY OUTREACH COURSE
ON BEHALF OF MY MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR A
FELLOW?
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS
MITCH DYER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. AS MUCH OF THE
REALLY DOES OFFER AN A CAN OF
PREVENTIVE IN PROACTIVE SOLUTION
TO THE PRETTY UNIQUE CHALLENGE
OF KEEPING WORKERS SAFE IN THIS
INDUSTRY THAT. AGAIN AS
MENTIONED HAS SINCE DAY ONE
REALLY OPERATED OUTSIDE THE LAW
AND SO THERE'S THERE'S A REAL
CULTURE THEIR OF FINDING OTHER
WAYS TO DEAL WITH PROBLEMS OF AN
UNSAFE WORKPLACE USUALLY JUST.
WORKING THROUGH IT.
IF IT'S NOT A SITUATION WHERE
WORKERS ARE FAMILIAR WITH
CALLING THE STATE GOVERNMENT
WITH PROBLEMS LIKE THIS AND SO.
THAT CULTURES LIKE WE GONNA TAKE
AWHILE TO TURN AROUND AND SO IN
THE MEANTIME WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MORE PEOPLE
THERE. IN THESE WORKPLACES THAT
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE CALLUSES
SYSTEM AND CAN LOOK AROUND AND
SAY WE SHOULD DO THIS
DIFFERENTLY WE SHOULD DO THAT
DIFFERENTLY. ARM AND IN DOING SO
IT'S REALLY AN OFFER A WIN WIN
WHERE THE EMPLOYER IS GOING TO
HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE UNDER THE
LAW. THEIR LOT LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH CITATIONS THE
EMPLOYEES ARE A LOT LESS LIKELY
TO FACE HAZARDS AND GET INJURED
AND. EVERYONE GETS TO FOCUS MORE
ON THE WORK AT HAND RATHER THAN
TRYING TO DEAL WITH INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES AFTER THEY TAKE PLACE
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOUS OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON AND SUPPORT. CHRIS FOR WHICH
OF THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KURT CAMPBELL SHOW ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON A TURN TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NINE YOU DO YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD LIKE
CLOSE RESPECT LAST REGARD VOTE.
THIS BILL DOES A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL YOU.
MOTION AS YOU PASSED TWO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MATHIS.
THAT BILLS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU
.
RIGHT MISTER CHAIRPERSON IN
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IT'S MY HONOR BEFORE YOU PRESENT
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR.
PROVIDES ENHANCED TRACKING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO WORKPLACE
INJURY AND ILLNESS INFORMATION
INTO A SIXTEEN THERE ARE OVER
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION WORK
RELATED INJURIES. AND ILLNESSES
REPORTED IN THE U. S. THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ALONE.
THERE ARE FIFTY TWO HUNDRED WORK
RELATED DEATHS THAT YEAR FEDERAL
OSHA COLLECTS.
ELECTRONIC DATA FROM MOST
EMPLOYERS.
AND LAST YEAR FEDERAL OSHA
ISSUED A NOTICE OF RULE TO RELAX
INJURY AND ILLNESS THAT WE THINK
PUTS EMPLOYEES HEALTH AND SAFETY
IN DANGER CAL OSHA ALSO REQUIRE
SOME REPORTING. BUT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL SUMMARY OF INJURIES AND
ILLNESS.
SINCE FEDERAL SHIRT MAY REDUCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANGELENOS
REPORTING IS UP TO CALIFORNIA TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT UNDER THIS
BILL CAL OSHA WILL COLLECT THE
ANNUAL SUMMARY INFORMATION. AND
DEVELOP A SEARCHABLE DATABASE OF
THAT INFORMATION ON ITS WEBSITE
BY DOING SO.
INFORMATION THE PUBLIC AND HAVE
ACCESS TO CRITICAL WORKPLACE
SAFETY INFORMATION
THE DATABASE WILL CREATE
TRANSPARENCY GIVING NEW
EMPLOYEES ACCESS TO IMPORTANT
SAFETY INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
WORKPLACE. STRONGER REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT CAUSES INJURIES
THAT WORK AND HOW TO PREVENT
THEM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EMPHASIS
IS. MAY CONSUMERS OF THE PERFECT
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MAY CONSUMERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS. BILL FORWARD OF
TODAY THAT AS YOU KNOW PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS.
IN CALIFORNIA ROUTINELY ARE
TACKLING COMPLICATED LOVE LIFE
THREATENING SCENARIOS AND
REPORTING OF WORKPLACE INJURY
AND ILLNESS.
ILLNESSES IN CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
INJURIES THAT ARE OCCURRING IN
THE STATE WHERE THEY'RE
OCCURRING WHAT TYPES OF INJURIES
ARE OCCURRING.
EVER HAPPENING IT.
AT DIFFERENT PLACES AT THE
STATE DIFFERENT INJURIES OF SO
REALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO
WITH THIS BILL. IS.
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
ALREADY TO REQUIRE REQUIRED TO
TRACK AND POST THIS INFORMATION
IN THE WORKPLACE.
TO REPORTED ELECTRONICALLY TO
CAL OSHA AND ASK CAL OSHA TO
DEVELOP THIS ONLINE SEARCHABLE
DATABASE WHICH WE THINK WILL
PROVIDE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS CURRENT
EMPLOYEES AND PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYEES TO HAVE A BETTER IDEA
OF WORKPLACE INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
WHEN.
THEY'RE LOOKING INTO
PERSPECTIVE EMPLOYMENT.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD ASK
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
IT WAS ARE CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THIS IMPROVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE HELPFUL FOR
A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS
PROBABLY PRIMARILY THAT. THE
MORE THAT WE LEARNED ABOUT THE
KIND OF INCIDENTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING OUT THERE WITH THE
KIND OF DETAIL THAT FOR FIRED IN
THE SLOT THREE HUNDRED REPORTS
IN THE MORE THAT WE CAN KIND OF.
BILL THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND THAT
INFORMATION AND SEE WHERE THE.
EFFICIENCIES ARE MAYBE WHERE WE
NEED TO TIGHTEN SOMETHING UP
WHERE WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
WORDING OF A DIFFERENT
REGULATION AND SO WE CAN MAKE.
NOT JUST THE SYSTEM WORK BETTER
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYER AND
SEE WHERE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
ARE THAT THEY MIGHT BE HAVING
AND HELP. DO A BETTER JOB OF
PREVENTING INJURIES IN THAT
WORKPLACE BUT ALSO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE AND SEE
WHAT BROADER AREAS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
KEEPING WORKERS SAFE AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE. PREVENT INJURIES
BEFORE THEY OCCUR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
I WAITED ALL DAY FOR THE.
MY ONLY BUILD TODAY SO I WILL BE
BRIEF.
WERE OPPOSED I'M MARTY FISHER
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
OVER OPPOSED BECAUSE IT'S GOING
TO BE VERY COSTLY TO DEVELOP
THIS WEBSITE.
ESTABLISH THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ALSO COLLECTED MAINTAIN THE
DOCUMENTS FOR FIVE YEARS AND
RESPOND TO PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST.
IN ADDITION TO THE THREE THREE
HUNDRED A SUMMARY DOCUMENT THAT
THE BILL. REQUIRES TO BE POSTED
ON THE WEBSITE. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES TO OTHER FORMS TO BE.
COLLECTED AND MAINTAINED BY
OSHA BUT AND THEN THEY WOULD
JUST BE SUBJECT TO THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST.
OF.
SO WHAT IT DOES BASICALLY IS
THAT CREATE IT HAS THE STATE
CREATE THIS.
LIST OF SHAME FOR EMPLOYERS AND
THAT.
CAN BE USED TO MISCONSTRUE AND
DISTORT.
THE MATTER THAT.
IN A MANNER THAT DOESN'T REFLECT
THE EMPLOYERS COMMITMENT TO
WORKPLACE SAFETY.
A WE DON'T THINK THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL ARE GOING TO
ADVANCE WORKER PROTECTION IN ANY
WAY BUT RATHER DIVERT SCARCE
RESOURCES AWAY FROM IMPORTANT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
AND AND INSTEAD TO AN
UNNECESSARY AND EXPENSIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION OPPOSITION FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY MS FISHER.
THE CALL RISE CALVARY
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
KATIE HANSON RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION RIPOSTE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION SEEN NONE
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
CULTURAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA NO FLORA NO
CONSOLES FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
MATHIS.
BILLS UNCLE SIR THANK YOU.
SO THAT ALLEN.
THE LAST ONE LAST MAN STANDING
BEST WHILE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS EACH
YEAR.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPERSEDES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION.
BUT LAST YEAR JERRY BROWN THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS
INTENTIONALLY IGNORED THIS FACT
ENACTED SB FIFTY FOUR ANY BEFORE
FIFTY. THE ILLEGAL SANCTUARY
STATE LAWS.
THE EXPRESS INTENT OF THESE LAWS
WAS INTERFERE WITH THE ABILITY
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ENFORCE IMMIGRATION LAW.
AN AREA WHICH IS GREAT EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION BY THE US
CONSTITUTION.
IT IS MY BELIEF.
AS WELL AS WE THE US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE
THAT THESE LAWS ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL INFRINGEMENT
INFRINGEMENTS
ON FEDERAL AUTHORITY.
MY BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD UNDO THE DAMAGE
INFLICTED BY AB FOR FIFTY.
PLACES CALIFORNIA PLAYER
SQUARELY IN THE CROSSFIRE
DEMOCRATS POLITICAL DESTRUCTIVE
WAR RESISTANCE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AB FOUR FIFTY SUBJECTS
CALIFORNIA PORTERS TO PENALTIES
AND PROSECUTION
IF THEY COOPER WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES.
IT EVEN GOES SO FAR AS TO MAKE
IT ILLEGAL FOR AN EMPLOYER TO
RECHECK EMPLOYEES IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
IF INFORMATION SERVICES THE
EMPLOYEES ON IS UNDOCUMENTED.
MEETING HERE ILLEGALLY.
IT IS AGAINST FEDERAL LAW TO
HIRE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AB FOR
FIFTY BUT CALIFORNIA NO WITH THE
POSITION OF DECIDING WHETHER
THEY WANT TO BE PROSECUTED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SIMPLY PUT A BEFORE FIFTY IS
UNJUST AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IS RECKLESS UNFAIR AND IMMORAL.
IT TREATS THE EMPLOYERS OF THE
STATE THE BUSINESS OWNERS AND
THE RISK TAKERS WHO ACTUALLY
CREATE JOBS.
AND PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH
OPPORTUNITY AS PAWNS IN THE
IDEOLOGICAL WAR OF THE DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE MORE CONCERNED WITH THE
RIGHTS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THEN THOSE OF LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS.
AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN IS
MEASURED IN A REASONABLE.
IT SIMPLY PUTS THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT BACK ON THE SIDE OF
JUSTICE FAIRNESS AND THE US
CONSTITUTION.
WITHOUT I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
SO WE CAN REPEAL AB FOR FIFTY.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL YOUR FIRST
WITNESS.
NO WOULD ASSIST ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ANY SUPPORT
ON THE MATTER.
BUT SEEING NONE IS THERE
OPPOSITION ON THE MATTER PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ARE NAY BAYARDO ES YOU YOU
CALIFORNIA WHERE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF AB FOR FIFTY.
.
I THINK THE AUTHOR JUST HAS A
WRONG SO AB FOR FIFTY IS
DIRECTED AT THE ACTIVITY OF
EMPLOYERS IT'S NOT.
AS THE. AUTHOR RATE REPRESENTED
SO.
WHEN ICE COMES INTO A WORKPLACE.
THEY ARE GONNA.
IT WILL IMPACT IN EVERY PERSON
IN THAT WORKPLACE INCLUDING.
CITIZENS PERMANENT RESIDENTS
ANYONEWITHIN THAT WORKPLACE
WILL BE DETAINED THEIR RIGHTS
WILL BE TAKEN AWAY FOR THAT
TIME.
AND CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY HAS A
RIGHT.
TO.
GOVERNED THE LAWS THAT ARE HOME
BUSINESSES HAVE TO APPLY BY AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT TELLS EMPLOYERS HOW THEY
NEED TO RESPOND. AS HAS WHEN
THAT YOU NEED TO ASK FOR A
WARRANT THAT YOU NEED TO ASK FOR
A SUBPOENA THAT'S FAIR THAT'S
JUST IT'S LEGAL WE THINK IT'LL
STAND UP IN COURT.
THIS BILL.
ALSO WAS MISREPRESENTED BY THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE IT DOESN'T REPEAL
AB FOR FIFTY IT ACTUALLY GOES
MUCH FURTHER THAN THAT VIEWS
REPELLING INDUSTRY JUST DELETED
IT. ARM.
THIS BILL ACTUALLY GIVES THE
EMPLOYERS THE RIGHT.
TO AT ANY TIME INVITE I SEE HIM.
WHICH ACTUALLY WOULD COMPLAIN
CONFLICT WITH CURRENT LAW ALSO A
LIVER CHO TO FORTY FOUR BE.
PREVENT EMPLOYERS FROM
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST OUR THEIR
WORKERS ON THE SPACES ARE THIS
WOULD PUT THE LAW IN DIRECT
CONFLICT WITH THAT COAT IT ALSO
VIOLATES LABOR CODE TEN
NINETEEN.
I KEEP GOING THIS GETS ME WORKED
UP I'M GONNA LET MICHAEL GO.
THANK YOU AND IT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG A WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WERE ALSO ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF A EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY.
THE PERMISSIVE THAT BILL WAS TO
ENSURE THAT IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ARE PROTECTED AT THE WORK SITE
IN THE FACE OF.
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
A.
AGAIN I WANNA LIMA CUMMINGS
WITH.
RENEE.
BEAR WITH SEIU.
IT'S OUR POSITION THAT.
MISTER SIMPLY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GONE MUCH FURTHER THEN ADD HE
PORTRAYS HIS BILL THAT THE
DANGERS PRESIDENT WHERE IT
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO.
IMPAIR OR ENCOURAGES EMPLOYERS
TO.
AND BUY ICE AGENTS INTO THE
WORK SITE.
WITH NO JUDICIAL REASON TO KNOW
ABOUT REASON TO BE THERE.
AGAIN THAT THE BILL THAT THE
BILL ESSENTIALLY REPEAL THOSE
VERY HARD AREN'T PROTECTIONS
THAT WE FOUGHT FOR OF BOTH
THROUGH THIS BODY AND WE
NEGOTIATED STRONGLY NOT JUST
WITH.
THIS LEGISLATURE BUT WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH A BUSINESS GROUP WE
WORKED WITH COMMUNITY GROUPS TO
DEAL WITH ANY ISSUES THEY HAD
WON THE EMPLOYER SIDE ON THE
COMMUNITY SIDE TO ENSURE THAT WE
WERE. HAVING A ROBUST FEEL THAT.
BOTH DEAL WITH ISSUES THAT MAKE
SURE THAT WORKERS ARE PROTECTED
WILL ALSO A WAS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT A
BEFORE FIFTY ESSENTIALLY SAYS.
THREE THINGS IT SAYS THAT YOU
HAVE TO ASK FOR A WARRANT BEFORE
YOU I THINK SINCE THE WORK SITE
YOU GIVE EMPLOYERS NOTICE YOU
GIVE EMPLOYEES EXCUSE ME NOTICE
OF AYE AUDITS IN IT LIMITS AS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW OR AS
ALLOWABLE TO FEDERAL LAW. RE
VERIFICATION ISSUES.
AND WE WE FEEL THAT THOSE
PROVISIONS WERE NECESSARY AND
THAT WERE.
ALLOWABLE UNDER BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW AGAIN THE STATE HAS
THE ABILITY TO A REGULATE CLEAR
BEHAVIOR.
AND WHILE THE STATE MIGHT BE
LIMITED IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
DEAL WITH IMMIGRATION ACTIONS
THEY CAN'T AGAIN REGULATE
EMPLOYER BEHAVIOR TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE MEETING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO WORKERS EMPLOYERS
HAD THE APPLICATION INSURE THEIR
WORKERS PRIVACY RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED.
THIRTY PROCESS RIGHT TO PROTECT
IT WHILE THAT WORKER IF AT THE
WORK SITE WON'T WORK TIME.
DISABILITIES IN THEM WHEELS
GOES A LITTLE BIT TOO FAR WHERE
IT PUTS WORKERS IN DANGER OF THE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
WHERE WE KNOW IN THE PAST THAT
SUCH RATES HAVE CAUSED.
WORKERS RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS WERE VIOLATED WE'VE KNOWN
INSTANCES WHERE.
WORKERS MAY HAVE BEEN A CITIZEN
AS I THINK IT'S AS WE HAVE BEEN
DETAINED ELECT.
LIKE THE BILL TO GET COUNSEL.
SO AGAIN FOR THOSE REASONS
RIPPLES.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION AJUSCO SYNDROME
HAVE EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES FOR
ALL THE REASONS EXPLAINED IN
VERY STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU.
VERY CLEAR CHARLOTTE THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN OWNERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES THAT LABOR FATNESS
YEAH UNIT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GINA DISAVOWED CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES DANGEROUS BUSINESS
PRACTICES.
NOW OPPOSITION. ALONG DAY GUYS.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
WHICH ENCOURAGES DANGERS PIGEONS
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND TARGETS
ARE IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE WHO ARE
ALSO IMPORTANT RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE THAT CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR SOCIAL FABRIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND YOU INDIAN N. STRONG
OPPOSITION.
BUT ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AGREEING OF
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSES DELUDE COALITION
REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING AT ON
OPPOSITE
XENON TRYING TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED THEIR
SECOND.
BILL'S BEEN IN MOTION BUT THERE
IS NO SECOND.
.
THE BILL COULD NOT BE ACTED ON
FOR LACK OF A SECOND BUT IF YOU
WISH TO HAVE A FINAL WORD WE
WILL GRANT YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE CLOSING REMARKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN I
LOVE TO.
LOOK VERY SIMPLY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT DUE PROCESS.
THERE IS.
NOTHING.
THAT SHOULD STOP FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES
CARRYING OUT THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTIES.
ICE DOESN'T TAKE AWAY ANY RIGHTS
OF ANY CITIZENS WHEN THEY RAID
ANY WORKPLACE.
AND IF THERE ARE ANY
VIOLATIONSOF DUE PROCESS THOSE
CAN CLEARLY
BE REMEDIED IN THE COURTS.
IT IS WELL WITHIN EVERY
EMPLOYERS.
LEGAL RIGHTS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ONLY HAVE A
LEGAL WORKFORCE.
AND LET'S BE VERY CLEAR THERE IS
A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PEOPLE THAT ARE IMMIGRANTS TO
OUR COUNTRY AND DELIVERY LEGALLY
IMMIGRATED TO OUR COUNTRY.
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES VERY
SIMPLY AND VERY CLEARLY IS IT
INSURES THAT THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION S. SUPREMACY OVER
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
AND IT CORRECTS THIS ILLEGAL AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PRACTICE.
OF THE ILLEGAL SANCTUARY STATE
YOU MAY RECALL THAT I'VE I.
PROPOSED SIMILAR BILL IN A
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE WITH SOME OF
THE SAME COMMITTEE MEMBERS JUST
YESTERDAY.
AGAINST A I SP FIFTY FOUR. BOTH
OF THESE LAWS WILL BE FOUND TO
BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND THIS IS THIS THIS BILL RIGHT
HERE A. B..
.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
WILL ACTUALLY SERVE TO CUT THAT
PROCESS SHORT AND ENSURE THAT
THE RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS ARE BEING PUT FIRST NOW
PRIOR TO THE COURT'S DECISION
AND WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY FOLLOW FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU A BILL
FAILS FOR LACK OF A SECOND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
.
AT ON FOR.
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL.
WE LIVE THE CALL ON A BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL.
AB TWO THREE THREE FOUR.
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MATT MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
THE BILL IS OUT.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
VOEPEL.
ABSENT MEMBERS JONES SAWYER.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE
VOEPEL.
JONES SAWYER NO KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO BILL.
AB TWO FOUR A FOUR FAILS.
AB TWENTY NINE OH SEVEN ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
JONES SAWYER NO.
KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO BILL.
AB TO NINE OH SEVEN FAILS.
I DON'T WORK.
LET.
OKAY WE'RE DONE WITH ALL THE
BILLS ARE ON CALL. NOW WILL
ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN ABSENT
MEMBERS KALRA.
MATHIS.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ABSENT
MEMBERS KALRA.
MATHIS.
AB NINETEEN NO TWO. ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
AB TWENTY SIXTEEN FONG. ABSENT
MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO.
AB 23-14.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE. MATHIS.
AB TWO THREE THREE FOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
AB TWO THREE THREE EIGHT.
LEVINE ABSENT MEMBERS MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MATHIS.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ABSENT
MEMBERS KALRA.
I
KALRA I. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
VOEPEL ABSENT MEMBER AB TWENTY
SIX TEN. ABSENT
MEMBER KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN RADIUS OF
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE OF.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE
JONES SAWYER ABSENT MEMBERS
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN.
LACK OF MOTION.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ABSENT
MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY RUBIO. JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE.
AB TWENTY NINE OH SEVEN FLORA
ABSENT MEMBER. KALRA.
KALRA NO.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ABSENT MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
AB THIRTY AB ONE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
ABSENT MEMBERS MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE MATHIS.
IN B. THIRTY NINETY TWO
PATTERSON.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO.
AB THIRTY NINETY THREE ABSENT
MEMBER MCCARTY. MCCARTY NO.
AB THIRTY NINETY FOUR ABSENT
MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO.
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY TWO
O'DONNELL ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MATHIS.
AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY ONE ABSENT
MEMBER KALRA AYE KALRA AYE.
COMPLETENESS.
YEAH.
YOU'RE.
YOU'RE NOT.
YEAH THIS. LAST WEEK EVER ABCS
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN KALRA FIVE
KALRA AYE.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY KALRA. KALRA
AYE.
THE.
IT IS IN A.
INTELLECTUAL.
YEAH.
ANY.
THANK. YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YEAH.
BOB.
NOW LIKE I SAID IT WOULD.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR.
LIKE ABOUT THAT WE CALLED.
THIS IS PROBABLY GOING TO WORK.
I WANT FIVE THE EXACT MOMENT
LAURIE PROBLEM ALRIGHT MONTHLY.
BIG.
MEETING ADJOURNED